TO OUR JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ENTITLED THE AGE OF WILD
FIRES PRE AND POST WHILE FOR
FIRE PLANNING.
AND HOUSING DELIVERY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A TO NOTE THAT
IT IS A WHILE FOR FIRE.
AWARENESS WEEK AND I KNOW CAL
FIRE IS PROMPTING A NUMBER OF
EVENTS THIS WEEK TO HIGHLIGHT
THE IMPORTANCE OF PREPARATION
FOR WILD FIRES GOOD TIMING GUYS.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK MY TWO
CO CHAIRS ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM GRAY
CHAIR OF THE GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONAL COMMITTEE WE'RE
HOPING YOU CAN JOIN US TODAY.
AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE STAFF
OF ALL THE COMMITTEES FOR
ORGANIZING THIS HEARING.
SECOND I'D LIKE TO PASS ON MY
APPRECIATION TO OUR PANELISTS
TODAY FOR JOINING US -- THIS
AFTERNOON IT'S A BUSY TIME OF
YEAR AND WHAT'S GOING ON AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THE CONCEPT FOR THE HEARING AT
LEAST FOR ME HAS BEEN.
BREWING FOR A WHILE.
I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE
DEVASTATION OF SO MANY FOR OIL
FIRES IN MY DISTRICT TOO MANY TO
COUNT SINCE I WAS ELECTED IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
I'VE TALKED WITH TOO MANY
CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
HOMES.
WHERE FACE SO MANY CHALLENGES
AND DIFFICULT DECISION POST
WILDFIRE?
I WANT TO WATCH STAR LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS CITY COUNTY
AND SPECIAL DISTRICT STAFF.
AND OUR FIRST RESPONDERS DOING
EVERYTHING EVERYTHING THEY CAN
AFTER A WHILE FOR FIRE TO
ADDRESS COMMUNITY NEEDS AND
BEGIN TO HEAL.
ARTICLES IN THE NEWSPAPER CALL
THIS THE NEW NORMAL.
THE REALITY OF WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA THE REALITY OF FIRES
IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT I CAN'T HELP FEELING THAT WE
NEED TO DO MORE AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND DO BETTER PLANNING AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BEFORE WE ACCEPT
THIS NEW AT THIS NEW FATE.
WITH THAT IN MIND WE'VE GATHERED
THE EXPERTS FOR WHAT I THINK
WOULD BE A GREAT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS ON THE IMPORTANT
ISSUES.
OUR FIRST PANELIST WILL DISCUSS
THE STATE'S ROLE IN PERSPECTIVE.
THEY WILL HELP US TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
STATE'S INTERACTION WITH LOCAL
PLANS.
AS WELL AS WHAT CAL FIRE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
ARE WORKING ON GIVEN THE LAST
FEW USE.
OF INCREDIBLE DEVASTATION.
THE SECOND PANEL WILL LOOK AT
ISSUES FROM A LOCAL LEVEL.
WE WILL HEAR THE LAND USE OF
PLANNING PERSPECTIVE AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE WRIST
PERSPECTIVE.
FINALLY WE WILL CONSIDER THE
TYPES OF ISSUES WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT THAT AFFECTS THE
OTHER CRISIS THE STATE IS FACING.
A SHORTAGE OF HOUSING SUPPLY.
AND HOW WE CAN ATTEMPT TO
ACCOMMODATE THE GROWTH WE NEED
WHILE RESPECTING THE REALITY OF
WILDFIRE RISK.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK BY CO
AUTHORED ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
FOR HIS REMARKS AND THEN OTHERS
IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A REMARK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR PARTICIPATING IN
TODAY'S HEARING ARE LIKE MY
FELLOW CO CHAIR -- THIS IS A
TOPIC THAT I THINK WE'VE ALL
BEEN THINKING ABOUT SINCE -- THE
BEGINNING OF OF THE TRAGEDIES
AND CERTAINLY SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN I'VE HAD.
MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH
COLLEAGUES SOME OF THEM ARE HERE
TODAY AND OTHERS OF US
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATURE
REPRESENTING.
DIFFERENT VULNERABLE PARTS OF OF
OF THE STATE IN WHAT CAN WE DO
TO AVOID FUTURE -- HORRIFIC
TRAGEDIES -- WE ALL IN OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE HAD TO DEAL
WITH THE AFTERMATH OF TRAGEDIES
BUT I THINK PART OF TODAY'S
HEARING.
IS TO BOTH PLAN FOR WHAT WE DO
IN THE AFTERMATH BUT HOW DO WE
PREVENT IN IN THE FUTURE -- IT
CERTAINLY IS THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
ELEMENT COMMITTEE -- THERE ARE
SPECIFIC ISSUES WITHIN THOSE TWO
WORLDS OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
OUT MEANT THAT WE WANT TO THINK
ABOUT.
HOW DO WE ASSIST COMMUNITIES AND
PLANNING FOR WILDFIRES HAD WE
RESPOND AS A COMMUNITY ONCE A
HAPPEN?
AND HOW DO WE REBUILD QUICKLY
OFFICIALLY AFTER DISASTER.
WILDFIRES HAVE MADE OUR STATE
HOUSING CRISIS WHICH IS ALREADY
THE MOST INTENSE HOUSING CRISIS
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY.
EVEN MORE INTENSE WITH RECORD
VACANCY RATES WITH INCREDIBLY
HIGH RENTS WITH A RECORD NUMBER
OF ON SHELTERED PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
WE KNOW THAT THE STANDARD
CHALLENGES TO BUILDING HOUSING
WHICH ARE HIGH COSTS LABOR
CHALLENGES SLOW LOCAL APPROVALS.
ARE THE SAME IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE IMPACTED BY
WILDFIRE BUT THERE INTENSIFIED
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT YOU ADD TO
THAT DISPLACED FAMILIES WERE
FACING HOMELESSNESS OR
OVERCROWDING.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE A STATE
HOUSING DEFICIT -- SUCH THAT
WERE BUILDING ABOUT EIGHTY
THOUSAND UNITS A YEAR BUT WE
NEED TO BE BUILDING OVER A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND UNITS A
YEAR.
AND WHILE WE MOVE FOR POLICIES
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE TO FUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. TO EXPEDITE
HOUSING PRODUCTION TO HOLD
CITIES ACCOUNTABLE TO BUILD
THERE ARE OTHER UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THAT WE NEED TO FACE
WHEN IT COMES TO GRAPPLING WITH
THE ISSUES THAT IS ARE THE
SUBJECT OF TODAY'S HEARING.
HOW DO WE DECIDE WHERE IT IS
SMART TO BUILD AFTER A WILD FIRE
HOW DO WE BUILD AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE ONCE WE DECIDE WHERE
DOES THAT WE BUILD WHAT IS IT
THAT WE REQUIRE A REBUILDING
STANDARDS?
AUTOMATION THIS YEAR MY HOPE IS
WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING FORWARD A
NUMBER OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BILLS.
THAT FOCUS ON THE THREE PIECE OF
HOW WE PRODUCE MORE HOUSING.
HOW WE PRESERVE THE HOUSING WE
HAVE AND HOW DO WE PROTECT THOSE
RESIDENTS FROM BEING FORCED OUT
OF THE HOUSING THAT THEY
CURRENTLY ARE IN -- AND THIS IS
A CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS TO
REALLY SHOWCASE AND HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
THAT ARE FACED.
IN COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
GRAPPLED WITH TOO MUCH SO WITH
THAT AGAIN WANT TO THANK ALL OF
OUR COLLEAGUES WHO HERE TODAY
AND OPEN IT UP THERE ANY
COLLEAGUES I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
OPENING REMARKS. TO GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY.
MR OUR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND IN APPRECIATE TO BOTH YOU
AND GERMAN AG AGUIAR-CURRY FOR
HOLDING THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TODAY -- YOU KNOW AS YOU
KNOW I'M.
LIVE IN THIS ISSUE RIGHT NOW --
AND AND I KNOW.
THE CHAIR WOMAN HAS HAD TO DEAL
WITH THIS -- ALSO IN CINEMA AND
LAKE COUNTIES AND SO.
OBVIOUSLY I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS OR REALLY
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
BOTH -- HOW DO WE DEAL WITH THE
THE IMMEDIATE IMPACT OF THESE
DISASTERS -- AND AND CERTAINLY
IT IS SIGNIFICANT MY DISTRICT
RIGHT NOW -- WITH THE CAMPFIRE --
AND THE DEVASTATION TO THE TOWN
OF PARADISE Và GALIA CON CO --
YANKEE HILL. FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN DISPLACED AND
YOU KNOW AS AS ARE A REPORT KIND
OUTLINES THERE WAS ALREADY A
HOUSING CRISIS IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS -- PRIOR -- TO THIS
DISASTER BUT CERTAINLY WHEN YOU.
WHEN YOU LOSE HOUSING THAT WAS
HOUSING FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE --
IT IS BEATEN GREATLY EXACERBATED
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE VERY
PRECARIOUSLY HOUSE RIGHT NOW
LIVING.
WITH FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND FRIENDS AT BEST -- BUT IT
WORST INTENSE -- YELLOW HOMELESS --
TRYING TO FIND OUT HEY HOW DO WE
MAKE THAT NEXT STEP IN AND YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE MOST IMMEDIATE
THINGS IS HOW DO WE GET HOUSING
DELIVERED -- YOU.
AS EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE --
IN THESE REGIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
MEANT THAT HAVE BEEN REALLY
DEVASTATED -- SO THE PEOPLE WHO
WHO WHO HAVE THEIR LIVES THERE
THEY HAVE THEIR SCHOOL THEIR
KIDS ARE IN SCHOOL.
THERE YOU KNOW STILL EMPLOYED AT
AT JOBS THEIR FAMILY AND
CONNECTEDNESS COMMUNITY IS STILL
ALL THERE THEY WANT TO STAY IN
THE REGION BUT THERE'S A ZERO
VACANCY RATE -- SO AND AND WE'VE
HAD SOME GOOD CONVERSATIONS AND
OTHERS -- YES SOME GOOD POLICY
PROCESS -- POLICIES AND BILLS
THAT ARE MOVING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW THAT WERE
THEIR HELP IN THAT THAT
SITUATION -- BUT ALSO THINKING
ABOUT THE LONG TERM YOU KNOW AS
AS AS BOTH OF YOU OUTLINED.
YOU HOW CAN WE GET TO A BETTER
PLACE IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE FIRE
RESILIENT THAT THEY'RE SAFE.
THAT WE HAVE -- THIS COULD THIS
CONVERSATION I CAN TELL YOU IS
HAPPENING.
IN PARADISE RIGHT NOW IS THERE
PLANNING DOING THEIR PINE
EFFORTS TO REBUILD THAT THEY
WANT TO YOU KNOW ENSURE THAT THE
COMMUNITY IS BUILT.
HOUSES ARE BUILT OUT OF BETTER
MATERIALS -- THAT THEY'RE BETTER
PRACTICES IMPLEMENTED DEFENSIBLE
SPACE.
IS NOT ONLY CONDUCTED BUT THEN
AND FORCED -- AND YOU KNOW SO A
LOT OF THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE
HAPPENING -- AND YOU KNOW IT'S I
THINK IT IS INCUMBENT ON US TO
HEY FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE THE
POLICIES THAT WILL ENSURE --
LONG TERM SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND PERHAPS JUST AS
IMPORTANT MAYBE MORE IMPORTANT
HOW DO WE GET OUT THE VEGETATION
BUILD UP THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
FORESTS AND AND WILD LANDS --
AND ENSURING THAT WERE REALLY
GETTING ON TOP OF THAT BECAUSE
WE COULD BE FACING.
THE NEXT CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
IF WE DON'T AND SO WITH THAT I
JUST THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING AND AND LOOKING.
FOR TO FROM THE EXPERTS ON ON
SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
YES.
SOMERS TRANSFER.
HOUSE ONE OF FOR FOR BRINGING US
TOGETHER -- IN IN MY MISSPENT
YOUTH WHICH SAVE LOS ANGELES THE
HOUSE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
COORDINATOR FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND ALSO WAS.
DIRECTOR REAL ESTATE AND MANY
TIMES I WOULD COME.
TO THE CITY COUNCIL AND ASK FOR
FUNDING FOR BREAST PRIOR%
CLEARANCE IN.
AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE AND WE
WOULD PUT IN.
THE BUDGET ONE MILLION TWO
MILLION FIVE MILLION TEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND BECAUSE IT WAS TOUGH TIMES
IT WOULD.
BE TAKEN OUT OF THE BUDGET AND I
WOULD.
INSIST THAT WE NEED TO DO MORE
NOT LESS WE NEED NOT TO ZERO IT
OUT BECAUSE ONE DISASTER WOULD
COST.
NOT ONLY IN LIVES BUT IN
PROPERTY IN THE VALUE OF THOSE
PROPERTIES WOULD.
OUTWEIGH THAT ONE MILLION TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AN AMOUNT OF
MONEY WE COULD SAVE JUST BY --
LISTENING TO PEOPLE LIKE TO
DEPARTMENT OH OH YES -- AND AND
AND THEIR PLANS FOR HAZARD
MITIGATION -- I DON'T THINK WE
DO ENOUGH -- AND GOVERNMENT HAS
A MITIGATION.
BECAUSE WE TRY TO TAKE YOUR
THINGS THERE RIGHT IN FRONT OF
OUR EYES -- WE NEED TO DO MORE
ABOUT LOOKING. FOR FIVE YEARS
TEN YEARS DOWN THE LINE WHEN WE
KNOW.
WITH JUST ONE MATCH WHEN
CAMPFIRE IT COULD CAUSE THE
DEVASTATION THAT WE'VE
UNFORTUNATELY EXPERIENCED AND SO
I'M I'M HERE. TO TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- IS A VOICE.
FOR FOR EARLY PLANNING -- OF OF
MY STAFF MEMBER ASKED ME OF
SORRY TALKING ABOUT A TIME WHERE
WE CAN JUST TOTALLY STOP ALL OF
THESE.
FIRES LIKE I SAID KNOWS ABOUT
MITIGATING.
THE THE POTENTIAL DAMAGE AND
THAT COULD HAVE HAPPENED AND SO
LIKE -- I APPLAUD YOU IN DOING
THIS I'M HOPEFUL WE HAVE A
PRESCRIPTION -- AND HOPEFULLY
DISCUSSION HOW WE CAN FUND.
MITIGATION EFFORTS SO THAT THE
IMPACTS ON ON ON MY ON EACH OF
YOU THAT HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS
DEVASTATION THAT WE CAN MITIGATE
IT TO A POINT.
WHERE WE CAN OVERCOME A LOT
QUICKER AND FASTER THANK YOU?
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ANY OF
THAT ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK.
OKAY SIGNAL ONE WE GO AHEAD AND
INVITE OUR FIRST PANEL TO UP TO
THE DíAS -- I'D LIKE TO ASK
MEMBERS TO HOLD THE QUESTIONS TO
THE END OF THE PANEL.
AND WE WILL HAVE CHIEF THOMAS
PORTER THE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND MANAGEMENT SECTION.
CHIEF MICHAEL RICH ONE STATE
FARM ARE MARSHALL CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION.
ALSO I BELIEVE MARK ILA DO
CHEESE HERE.
THE OTHER IS.
OF DIRECTOR OF GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
CAKE GORDAN.
DIRECTOR GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH SENIOR
ADVISER TO THE GOVERNOR ON
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND WILL HAVE THE NEW IN TARA
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF
THIS -- IMPORTANT COMMITTEE --
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND OPEN --
THIS IS TOM PORTER -- AND
DIRECTOR OF CAL FIRE -- IN FRAME --
KIND OF THE PICTURE AS WE SEE IT
AND THANK YOU MEMBER STORIES
PASSED IT JONES SAWYER -- YOU
YOU HAD A LOT OF THE ITEMS THAT
THAT ARE VERY IMPORTANT I THINK
IN THIS LONG RANGE KIND OF
PLANNING -- PLACE THAT WE NEED
TO BE -- SO.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS -- WELL
FIRE WELL WILDFIRES ARE A
NATURAL PART OF CALIFORNIA'S A
LANDSCAPE AND VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF THE LANDSCAPE -- THEY
ARE BECOMING MORE -- PREVALENT
ON THE ROUTE THE LANDSCAPE --
AND MUCH MORE DESTRUCTIVE --
THERE MANY -- MANY ISSUES THAT
ARE CAUSING THAT -- AND IT WILL
BE A KIND OF A ALL OF THE ABOVE
APPROACH THAT'S NECESSARY IN
ORDER.
TO MITIGATE THE RISKS TO THE
PEOPLE AND PROPERTY.
OF THE STATE.
I WELL WE ALSO ALLOW FOR SOME OF
THE LANDSCAPE TO BURN AND
REPLENISH ITS NATURAL STATE AS
WELL.
SO OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS --
WE'VE HAD THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
SEASONS AND I'M JUST GONNA JUST
GONNA PUT IT IN IN -- STRUCTURE
TERMS. TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE
HAD OVER TEN THOUSAND STRUCTURES --
THAT BURNED DUE TO WILDFIRES.
THAT WAS THE WORST IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
COMES AROUND.
AND WE DOUBLE THAT MORE THAN
DOUBLE THAT MORE THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND STRUCTURES BURNED IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND THE
MOST -- OF DESTRUCTIVE AND
DEADLY.
WILDFIRES OCCURRED.
OVER A HUNDRED PEOPLE -- PASSED
AWAY DUE TO WILDFIRE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SIX OF THOSE
BEING FIRST RESPONDERS.
A TRAGIC YEAR -- FOR SURE.
SO WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS A
COMBINED EFFECT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE -- FIRE SUPPRESSION
ACTIVITIES LAND USE PLANNING
ACTIVITIES OVERGROWN -- FOREST
AREAS.
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN MANAGED OR
ALLOWED FOR NATURAL MANAGEMENT
THROUGH FIRE ACTIVITY -- AND
THAT IS CONTRIBUTING TO THESE
LARGER AND MORE DAMAGING FIRES.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE'RE
SEEING IS.
A LOT OF GROWTH OF OF HUMAN
ACTIVITY AND DEVELOPMENT INTO
THESE AREAS.
AND THAT'S HAPPENED OVER DECADES
IT'S NOT ANYTHING THAT'S A NEW
PROBLEM.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
BECOMING VERY CLEAR TO US IS
THAT THERE IS -- A VULNERABILITY
ISSUE THAT WE DID NOT PREVIOUSLY
REALLY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT -- THE
OLD VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES --
INCLUDING -- YOU PEOPLE THAT ARE
HAVE MOBILITY ISSUES
COMMUNICATIONS ISSUES -- OR EVEN
A LACK OF OF TRANSPORTATION FEW
CARS PER HOUSEHOLD -- MAYBE
YOUNG CHILDREN.
SCHOOL AGE AT HOME AND ARE NOT.
OUT OF THEIR COMMUNITY DURING
THE DAYTIME -- ALL OF THOSE
ISSUES ARE ARE -- VERY KEY -- TO
MITIGATING THIS PROBLEM IN THE
FUTURE AND IT'S NOT JUST A RURAL
PROBLEM.
THERE CITIES THROUGHOUT --
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE VERY MUCH IN
PERIL -- CLOSE TO US -- SANTA
ROSA AS WE KNOW.
GLARING EXAMPLE OAKLAND AS WELL
AND MANY OTHERS [inaudible]
SO.
I WANT AYE IT'S NOT NOT ALL
DESPAIR -- CAL FIRE AND THE
OFFICES OF OF A STATE GOVERNMENT
THAT HAVE RESPONSE --
RESPONSIBILITY -- INCLUDING --
CALLOW YES -- ARE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES TO PLAN FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES THAT NEED TO BE DONE --
AND PREPARING FOR A RISK
REDUCTION -- WELL IT'S NOT JUST
FIRE RESPONSE -- IT INCLUDES --
HAZARD ASSESSMENT RISK
ASSESSMENT -- AND THEN FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES DOING
THOSE THINGS THAT I TALKED ABOUT
PREVIOUSLY FUELS MANAGEMENT.
PRESCRIBED BURNING -- AND THOSE
KIND OF THINGS.
AND I THINK -- WHAT WE'D LIKE TO
DO I MEAN I I'M GONNA PASS THIS --
TO MY PARTNER.
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL -- MIKE
RICH WINE -- TO TALK MORE ABOUT
THOSE THOSE -- PLANNING AND KIND
OF LONG RANGE -- PLANNED
DEVELOPMENT ISSUES THAT WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH. TWENTY THANK
YOU CHIEF.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES GOOD
AFTERNOON.
A PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU.
OF THE ALSO THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL SUPPORTS THE FIRE
PREVENTION MISSION OF CALIFORNIA --
THROUGH A WIDE VARIETY OF FIRE
SAFETY RESPONSIBILITIES
INCLUDING REGULATING.
LIFE SAFETY AND BUILDINGS WHICH
PEOPLE LIVE CONGREGATE OR
COMPLYING.
WRITING STATEWIDE DIRECTION FOR
FIRE PREVENTION WITH THEM WHILE
AND AREAS.
DEVELOPING IN REVIEWING
REGULATIONS AND BUILDING
STANDARDS AND PROVIDING TRAINING
AND EDUCATION AND FIRE
PROTECTION METHODS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
SINCE OUR FOCUS TODAY IS ON
HOUSING AND THE THREAT TO
HOUSING POSED BY WILDFIRE.
I'M GOING TO CONCENTRATE OUR
PROGRAMS.
THAT MOST DIRECTLY IMPACT THE
SAFE DEVELOPMENT IN OCCUPANCY OF
HOMES IN WELFARE PRONE AREAS.
AND WHILE I'M GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS
INDIVIDUALLY.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
ADOPTING A WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA REQUIRES A SYSTEMATIC
APPROACH.
IT REQUIRES PLANNING COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE HARDENED AGAINST
WILDFIRES WITH FEW BREAKS IN AND
AROUND THE COMMUNITIES.
ENSURING COMMUNITIES HAVE PROPER
EVACUATION ROUTES WATER SUPPLIES
IN FIRE PROTECTION RESOURCES.
IN BUILDING HOMES AT A TIMBER
REDEEMER RESISTANT MATERIALS
WHILE MAINTAINING A ONE HUNDRED
FOOT DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
BY REMOVING DEAD AN OVERGROWN
VEGETATION WHICH ALSO AND ALSO
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC TO PREVENT
THE START AND SPREAD OF HUMAN
BECAUSE WILDFIRES.
WELL BEFORE HOUSES ARE BUILT IN
COMMUNITIES ARE DEVELOPED THOUGH.
WE IDENTIFY AND MAP FIRE HAZARD
AREAS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THESE AREAS ARE ZONES ARE MAPPED
USING A SCIENCE BASED COMPUTER
MODEL.
THAT ASSIGNS A HAZARD SCORE
BASED ON MANY FACTORS THAT
INFLUENCE FIRE LIKELIHOOD AND
FIRE BEHAVIOR.
THE FACTORS CONSIDERED INCLUDE
FIRE HISTORY.
EXISTING AND POTENTIAL FUEL
NATURAL VEGETATION.
TOPOGRAPHY FLAME LINK BLOWING
MEMBERS AND TYPICAL WEATHER FOR
THE AREA.
OUR FIRE RESOURCE ASSESSMENT
PROGRAM.
USES THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE
AND DATED TO OF AVAILABLE TO
DEVELOP AND FIELD TESTING MODEL.
THAT IS USED TO IDENTIFY THREE
INCREASING FIRE HAZARDS.
MEDIUM HIGH IN VERY HIGH.
WE HAVE BEGUN THE PROCESS FOR
UPDATING THE FIRE HAZARD TO
THEIR DESIGNS USING THE LATEST
TECHNOLOGIES AND MAPPING.
NEW MAPPING WILL INCLUDE NEW
FACTORS INCLUDING.
THE RECENTLY AND USE CHANGES NEW
SIGNIFICANT WIND EVENT DATA AS
WELL AS THE MODEL THAT IS MORE
SPATIALLY DETAILED. TWO HUNDRED
ACRES DOWN TO TWO ACRE PARCELS.
MAPS ARE IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY IN
LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY AREAS.
WHERE THE VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONE TRIGGERS WELL IN
BUILDING CODES FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION?
OF COURSE THESE CODES APPLY TO
ALL THREE ZONES IN THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
IT'S BEEN ASKED AT THESE MAPS
SHOULD BE UPDATED MORE
FREQUENTLY AND THE REALITY IS
MOST OF THE FACTORS ARE CONSTANT.
OVER THE YEARS AND ARE STILL
RELEVANT.
HOWEVER WE UPDATE THE MODEL IS
NEW TECHNOLOGY AND SCIENCE
BECOMES AVAILABLE.
AND FOR EXAMPLE WE ARE JUST NOW
COMPLETING NEW DATA AVAILABLE ON
SIGNIFICANT WHEN DEFENSE.
THESE ISOLATED AND EXTREME WIND
EVENTS HAVE BEEN THE ROOT OF
SEVERITY.
OF THE NORTH BAY FIRES IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IN THE CAMP
FIRES IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AND BUTTE COUNTY.
SO THIS NEW DATA ON MICRO
CLIMATES IS AN IMPORTANT CHANGE
THAT WILL REQUIRE RE MAPPING.
AFTER FIRE HAZARDS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED THE LONG BEFORE
CONSTRUCTION BEGINS.
CAL FIRES LAND USE PLANNING
PROGRAM WORKS WITH THE LOCAL
PLANNING BUILDING AND FIRE
OFFICIALS TO ASSIST THEM IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SAFETY
ELEMENTS IN THEIR GENERAL PLAN.
THE PROVIDE THEM WITH
INFORMATION TO ENSURE THAT THEY
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS BASED ON
FIRE THREAT AND RISK IN THEIR
AREA.
THIS PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED BY
SENATE BILL TWELVE FORTY ONE
SENATOR KEOGH IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWELVE AND REQUIRES THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION. TO REVIEW AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVEMENTS
TO SAFETY ELEMENTS TO ADDRESS
THE RISK.
OF FIRE IN THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
AND LOCAL RESPONSIBLE AREAS WITH
VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARDS VERITIES
OWNS.
WE ARE IN CONTACT WITH FIFTY SIX
COUNTIES AND A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES IN THE STATE.
AND THIS YEAR WE WILL BE
ASSISTING THIRTY ONE COMMUNITIES
TO UPDATE THEIR SAFETY ELEMENTS.
AS A PART OF THEIR THEIR PLAN
UPDATES.
THE LAND USE PLANNING PROGRAM
PROVIDES GUIDANCE ON STATE FIRE
REGULATIONS.
INCLUDING ROAD STANDARDS FOR
FIRE EQUIPMENT ACCESS.
STANDARDS FOR STREET SIGNS AND
BUILDING IDENTIFICATION.
MINIMUM PRIVATE WATERSUPPLY
RESERVES FOR EMERGENCY USE.
AND FUEL BREAKS IN GREEN BELTS.
WE ALSO ASSIST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITH INCORPORATING WELFARE
MITIGATION MEASURES IN OUR CAL
FIRE UNIT PLANS.
OUR LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION
PLANS AND EVEN THE COMMUNITY
WHILE FIRE PREVENTION PLANS WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
PLANNING ELEMENTS ARE ALL SINK
IN CONSISTENT.
WE'RE IN THE INITIAL STAGES OF
OUR WORK WITH THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
IN REVIEWING SUBDIVISIONS AND
WHILE IN AREAS BUILT WITHOUT
SECONDARY EMERGENCY EGRESS. TO
IMPROVE BOTH PUBLIC EVACUATIONS
AND EMERGENCY ACCESS.
AS A RESULT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN SPILL.
AND THOSE POSITIONS ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
WHEN CONSTRUCTION OF RESIDENTIAL
HOUSING IS READY TO COMMENCE?
CALIFORNIA HELPS ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES ARE RESILIENT TO
WILDFIRE THROUGH THE APPLICATION
OF SOME OF THE MOST STRINGENT
WHILE AND BUILDING AND FIRE
CODES IN THE WORLD.
AS YOU KNOW AFTER TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE NEW BUILDINGS LOCATED
IN ANY FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONE
WITHIN THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
IN VERY HIGH FIRE ZONES AND
LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY AREAS.
ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH THE
NEW BUILDING AND AND FIRE CODES.
ARE KNOWN AS ARE WE WE CODES.
THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE OR
WE WE BUILDING CODES ARE
REVIEWED EVALUATED AND
AMENDMENTS ARE RECOMMENDED AT
REGULAR INTERVALS.
ARE WE WE COMMITTEE
REPRESENTATIVE OF BUILDING AND
FOREST PRODUCTS MANUFACTURERS.
BUILDING AND FIRE OFFICIALS
ACADEMIA.
THEY SERVE THE DEPARTMENT -- TO
ADVISE A NEW AMBER RESISTANT
PRODUCTS TECHNOLOGIES.
AND EVEN BUILDING TECHNIQUES --
IN RECENT CO DEVELOPMENT CYCLE
THROUGH THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION FIVE PROPOSALS FROM
THE WE COMMITTEE WERE APPROVED.
INCLUDING UL LISTED GARAGE DOOR
WEATHER STRIPPING.
AN AMBER RESISTANT SCREENS OVER
SKYLIGHTS.
AND OF COURSE.
AS YOU KNOW THE ONE MILLION
DOLLAR QUESTION.
IS HOW DO WE PROTECT THE TWO AND
A HALF MILLION HOMES ESTIMATED.
IN THE S. R..
THAT WERE BUILT BEFORE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL MAINTAINS A LIST OF
UPGRADES THAT HOMEOWNERS IN HIGH
FIRE HAZARD AREAS.
CAN UNDERTAKE TO HARDEN OR MAKE
THEIR HOMES MORE RESILIENT TO
WILDFIRE WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING
TO UPDATE THAT LIST.
INCLUDING GETTING RID OF WOOD
SHAKE SHINGLES WOOD SIDING AND
REPLACING IT WITH AMBER
RESISTANT BUILDING MATERIALS.
A LOT OF REALLY.
GREAT INFORMATION IS FOUND ON
OUR WEBSITE.
READY FOR WILDFIRE DOT ORG SLASH
HARDENING YOUR HOME.
WE'RE ALSO DEVELOPING A LOW COST
BUILDING RETROFIT LIST.
WE THINK IT'LL BE EXTREMELY
HELPFUL GUIDE TO HOMEOWNERS --
THAT WILL HARDEN THE HOME
AGAINST WELFARE EMBERS.
BUT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
EDUCATE AND INCENTIVIZE
HOMEOWNERS TO UPGRADE THEIR
HOMES THAT WERE BUILT BEFORE THE
NEW.
WE WE BUILDING AND FIRE CODES.
THE SEPARATE MUST BE COMMUNITY
BASED TO AVOID IN CONSISTENT
APPLICATION.
BECAUSE WHEN ONE HOME IS
COMPLIANT IN THE NEIGHBORS NEXT
DOOR AREN'T -- BOTH HOMES ALL
HOMES ARE STILL AT RISK --
MORNING IS A CRITICAL STEP IN
MAKING A COMMUNITY FIRE
RESISTANT.
IN FACT OR DAMAGE INSPECTION
ANALYSIS OF WILDFIRES HAS SHOWN
THAT 93% OF ALL THE STRUCTURES
THAT CATCH FIRE.
IN A WILDFIRE WILL BE DESTROYED.
REPORTER RETURNED BACK TO YOU.
I THANK YOU CHIU CHEAPER RICH --
ONE AND WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS
KIND OF FRAME THIS BACK -- TO
KIND OF JUST.
MAYBE A LITTLE MORE SIMPLE TERMS
OF WHAT ALL THIS MEANS --
THERE'S A LOT OF TECHNICAL WORK
THAT'S GOING ON IN THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT AND IN THE THE
ANALYSIS OF WHAT.
WHAT -- WILD FIRE CAN AND WILL
DO UNDER CERTAIN WEATHER
CONDITIONS AND AND FUELS
CONDITIONS AND ALL THOSE THINGS.
AND SO -- WELL WELL -- WE'RE
WORKING HARD I DILIGENTLY ON
THAT -- WHAT WE ARE ALSO DOING
AT SAME TIME IS NOW TAKING THAT
INFORMATION -- MAKING IT MORE
DIGESTIBLE TO THE PUBLIC --
LOOKING -- FOR AT WAYS OF OF
UTILIZING OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THROUGH OUR OUR
COMMUNICATIONS SHOPS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OUR SISTER
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS. TO
REALLY -- FOR REALLY BETTER AND
DESCRIBE WHAT IT IS THAT'S THE
STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY LOCAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND THEN THE
LANDOWNERS RESPONSIBILITY -- AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE VERY
MUCH ARE DOING THIS WEEK -- WITH
WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS WEEK AND
HEALTH -- PEOPLE GOING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC BOTH
THROUGH THE MEDIA BUT ALSO TO
THOSE THAT ARE ARE ATTENDING
THESE EVENTS -- IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO UNDERSTAND THAT --
WE'RE LOOKING TO DECREASE AND
MITIGATE THE DAMAGE CAUSED BY
WHAT HAPPENED TO BE MOSTLY HUMAN
CAUSED EVENTS THESE FIRES.
AND SO PART OF THAT IS EDUCATING
THE PUBLIC ON WHAT THEY CAN AND
NEED TO BE DOING TO ENSURE THAT.
THAT WE AS HAS PEOPLE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT OR NOT CAUSING THESE
FIRES.
SO THAT THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
TO TO THE THE MESSAGING. 95% OF
THOSE FIRES ARE CAUSED BY HUMANS
WILDFIRES [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT ELSE ARE WE DOING IN THAT
IN THAT SPACE -- YOU FOR THIS
FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND I'M I'M
NOT GONNA TAKE -- I'M NOT GONNA
MISS AN OPPORTUNITY TO SAY IT
AGAIN BUT READY SET GO IS WHAT
WE NEED TO BE TEACHING --
BECAUSE READY IS WHAT YOU DO AS
A PERSON NO MATTER WHERE YOU ARE
IN CALIFORNIA TO GET PREPARED.
FOR EMERGENCIES HAVE.
PREPARED -- FOR ANY KIND OF
EVENT THAT MAY HAPPEN EARTHQUAKE
WHILE FIRE PILE POWER OUTAGES.
ALL OF IT.
WINTER STORMS -- THAT AND THAT
IS -- THAT'S THE GET READY AND
YOU NEED TO DO THE SAME FOR
WILDFIRE PLAN YOUR EVACUATE
EVACUATION ROUTES ALL THOSE KIND
OF THINGS -- HAVE HAVE ALL OF
YOUR COMMUNICATION PLANS WITH
YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS AND
ACTUATION KITS READY TO GO.
OR EMERGENCY KITS -- SET IS WHEN
WE'RE IN BIG CONDITIONS THAT
THAT WARRANT.
RED FLAG WARNINGS -- JUST BEING
THERE AND BEING -- THE PEAK FIRE
SEASON FOR MOST OF CALIFORNIA.
HAVE THE STUFF READY TO GO
[inaudible]
THE SET.
AND WHEN IT'S TIME TO GO.
IT'S TIME TO GO AND GO AND GO
EARLY -- SO RELATED TO THAT --
AND THEY FURTHER THE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES -- CAL FIRE
DEVELOPED SEVERAL YEARS AGO AN
APP -- THAT IS READY FOR WILD
FIRE -- IT CAN BE -- YOU CAN
SEARCH CAL FIRE ON ANY ANY APPS
STORE -- ON YOUR WHATEVER YOUR
PREFERRED MOBILE DEVICES AND YOU
CAN GET -- YOU CAN GET VERY
DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
TO DO EVERYONE OF THESE THINGS
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HERE TODAY --
HARDENING YOUR HOME DEFENSIBLE
SPACE -- EVACUATION OF PLANNING
COMMUNICATIONS PLANS.
GETS ALL OF THAT IS ON THIS APP
AND AND YOU CAN TRACK YOUR
PROGRESS IN MEETING YOUR GOALS
TOWARD MEETING THAT [inaudible]
THE NEXT THING.
MOVING OUTSIDE OF THE THE HUMAN
AND TO THE OUTSIDE OF THE
STRUCTURE.
IS DEFENSIBLE SPACE WE NEED.
EVERYBODY TO DO THEIR DEFENSIBLE
SPACE EVERYBODY.
IS LIKE HARDENING HOMES IF 90%
DO AND 10% DON'T.
THAT 10% IS GOING -- TO HAVE AN
ADVERSE EFFECT ON SOME OF THE
OTHER 90% PROBABLY NOT ALL OF IT
FOR MAYBE.
SO WHAT YOU YOU MIGHT WANT TO
KNOW IS THAT WE WE FIND AT THAT
AND WE'RE TRYING TO TOUCH EVERY --
EVERY HOPE HOUSEHOLD ONCE EVERY
THREE YEARS WE ARE NOT MEETING
THAT BUT THAT IS THE THE GOAL --
WE FIND THAT -- 82% OF OF OUR
FIRST INSPECTIONS ARE COMPLIANT
INSPECTIONS.
AND BY THE TIME WE GET TO THE
THIRD INSPECTION -- 92% OF ALL
STRUCTURES ARE MEETING THAT --
THAT COMPLIANCE.
IT DOESN'T MEAN EVERY.
PROPERTY IS COMPLIANT.
SO.
FROM THERE WE NEED TO MOVE INTO
THE KIND OF THE THE WE WE THE
THAT ZONE THAT IS BETWEEN THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND WHAT I'LL
CALL THE WOODS OR THE BACK
COUNTRY.
OUT THERE A LITTLE BIT FURTHER
THAN THEN WHERE WE HAVE DANCE
HOUSING.
DEVELOPMENTS MAYBE THERE'S A
HOUSE EVERY FIVE TO TEN ACRES
BUT THAT'S KIND OF OUT THERE
THIS WILL EASE OWN IN BETWEEN --
THE THE CONSTRUCTED AREA OR THE
OR THE BUILT OUT AREA AND AND
THOSE MORE WERE OF RURAL AREAS --
WE NEED TO DO OF LANDSCAPE LEVEL
FUEL STREETS [inaudible]
AND THE GOVERNOR KNEW SOME --
ORDERED -- THE CALIFORNIA YOU
LOOK AT WHERE WE WOULD DO THOSE
IN THE SHORT TERM THIS YEAR THIS
SEASON -- IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE
RISK TO THE VULNERABLE --
ELEMENTS OF COMMUNITIES WHICH I
WAS MENTIONING PREVIOUSLY.
AND WE DID WE PUT THOSE SCREENS
OVER -- OUR PLANNING PROCESS WE
CAME UP WITH THIRTY FIVE
PROJECTS THAT WE COULD GET DONE
THIS YEAR -- THAT NEEDED TO GET
DONE THIS YEAR TO PROTECT --
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES OF TWO
HUNDRED PLUS -- COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THE IMPORTANT THING THAT IS
DIFFERENT IS THIS SOCIO ECONOMIC
AND MOBILITY SCREEN THAT WE PUT
OVER IT.
SO IT'S NOT EVERY COMMUNITY
THAT'S IMPERIL TO WATCH WILDFIRE.
BUT IT'S PARTICULARLY THE COOLEY
THOSE THAT HAVE VULNERABLE.
ELEMENTS WHERE WE COULD HAVE
CATASTROPHIC SITUATIONS OCCUR A
FIRE RUNS THROUGH THOSE AREAS
MEETING.
LOSS OF LIFE [inaudible]
SO.
WE'VE UNDERTAKEN THOSE PROJECTS
THE OTHER SCREENING ELEMENT OF
THOSE PROJECTS WERE THEY THEY
DID NOT HAVE SEEK WHAT ON SO.
THE REQUIREMENT WAS THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE AN EMERGENCY --
DECLARED IN ORDER -- TO
UNDERTAKE THEM.
WE DID THAT -- THOSE THIRTY FIVE
PROJECTS WHILE THEY DO NOT HAVE
A FORMAL SEEK WHAT PROCESS.
ALL OF THAT PLANNING AND ALL OF
THAT REVIEW PROCESS IS TAKING
PLACE -- UNFORTUNATELY WE WE
DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO DO THE
THE PUBLIC SCREENING OF THAT BUT
WE DID DO THE THE WORK ON THAT
TWENTY EIGHT OF THOSE THIRTY
FIVE PROJECTS ARE ARE -- BEING
ACTED ON NOW AND THE OTHER SEVEN
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF GETTING
FINAL APPROVAL.
NEXT FACE.
LANDSCAPE LEVEL THE CARBON PLAN --
CALIFORNIA CARBON PLAN.
FIRST CARBON PLAN CALLS FOR A
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
OF TREATMENT -- BY A THAT STATE
AGENCIES AND PRIVATE LANDOWNERS --
IN -- EVERY YEAR.
STARTING IN ABOUT -- TWO
THOUSAND I'M -- TO TWO THOUSAND
THIRTY IN ORDER TO GET TO THAT
AND YOU KNOW IN ORDER TO BRIDGE
THE GAP FROM WHERE WE ARE WITH
THE THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS.
AND START TO DO THESE PROJECTS
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS IS WE NEED TO
GET THE CAL -- CALVI T. P. WHICH
IS CALIFORNIA VEGETATION
TREATMENT PROGRAMMATIC HE I ARE
APPROVED -- IT'S UNDER
DEVELOPMENT BY THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY THIS YEAR -- WE EXPECT
BY THIS TIME NEXT YEAR WE WILL
TEAR ALL OF OUR FUELS REDUCTION
PROJECT WORK.
UNDER THAT SEQUEL COMPLIANT
DOCUMENT -- FOR FOR THE FUTURE
SO THAT'S WHERE WE BRIDGE AND WE
STOP HAVING TO CALL IT -- CALL
OUT EMERGENCIES FOR THESE FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECT WORK -- LAST
THING.
IS RELATED TO GRANT GRANT
PROJECTS -- IN THE WE WE AREA WE
HAVE -- WE HAVE GRANTED -- FOR
FIRE PREVENTION -- GRANT TYPE
PROJECTS -- ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS --
FUNDS TO DO THAT THAT WE WE TYPE.
LANDSCAPE LEVEL BUT CLOSE TO THE
STRUCTURES AND CLOSE TO THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT WORK -- WE
HAVE HAD WE HAVE GRANTED ANOTHER --
ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF FOREST HEALTH
GRANT.
GRANTS AND THAT'S TO DEVELOP
THAT RESILIENCE OUT IN THE
ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE WHERE WE
ARE PROTECTING WATERSHEDS
WILDLIFE -- AIR QUALITY -- AND
AND ALL OF THOSE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND REDUCING THE
THREAT OF FIRE COMING OUT OF
THOSE AREAS INTO THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT [inaudible]
IN CONCLUSION.
WE ARE REALLY DESCRIBING FOR YOU
TODAY A AND ALL OF THE ABOVE
APPROACH.
WE NEED TO DO ALL OF THESE
THINGS.
THERE IS NO SILVER BULLET.
THIS IS THIS IS A DEFINITELY A
PLACE WHERE WE NEED TO WORK
THROUGH EVERYTHING YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR ON ALL PANELS TODAY -- IN A
SYSTEMATIC BUT ALSO -- ALL OF
THE ABOVE TYPE OF WAY.
AND THAT WILL.
DEVELOP A RESILIENT.
FIRE SKATE FOR CALIFORNIA AND
FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- VERY
INFORMATIVE AGAIN WE'LL WAIT IF
FOR SOME OF THE MEMBERS TODAY
WILL BE TAKING QUESTIONS AT THE
END OF THE PANEL -- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR GOING TO CHI.
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU AND WE'RE
NOT IN A FIRE
.
ALL RIGHT GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON.
THAT'S SO WRONG WITH THAT.
GET OUR TECHNICAL PEOPLE OVER
HERE TO FIX THAT FOR YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE THE
MARKET RDG DIRECTOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES -- THANKS FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY I LET ME LET ME START
OFF BY JUST [inaudible]
REALLY.
CAPITALIZING ON JI PORTER CHI
FOR TRANS COMMENTS THEY HEADED
SPOT ON I MEAN THE AND AND WE
KNOW.
AS WELL WE'RE ALL WORKING
THROUGH THESE -- COMPLEX -- AND
REALLY YOU KNOW THE SCOPE AND
SCALE OF THE DISASTER THREE
SENIOR WHICH IS REALLY DRIVEN
HOME THE THE POINT THAT THAT.
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE HERE TODAY
AND THAT IS THAT.
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY.
WE NEED TO THINK DIFFERENTLY IN
OUR COMMUNITY PLANNING WE NEED
TO THINK DIFFERENTLY IN OUR
COMMUNITY PREPAREDNESS-- WE
NEED TO BUILD CAPACITY WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITIES TO PREPARE FOR
THESE KINDS OF DISASTERS AND
TODAY WE'RE FOCUSING ON WALL
FIRE BUT YOU KNOW NEXT WEEK
AFTER AN EARTHQUAKE WE COULD BE
TALKING ABOUT EARTHQUAKE SO.
WERE WERE CERTAINLY DISASTER
PRONE IN CALIFORNIA AND WE'VE
GOT PLENTY OF REST THAT WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH.
AND SO YOU KNOW COLLECTIVELY ALL
OF THESE EFFORTS THAT WERE
TALKED ABOUT -- TRULY OUR OUR
SPA ARE SPOT ON AND YOU KNOW NO
ASKED WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR WITH OUR OTHER STATE AGENCY
PARTNERS BUT WERE ALSO VERY MUCH
ENGAGED WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
WHICH IS REALLY YOU KNOW THEY
SAY ALL THIS ACTORS ARE LOCAL
AND IT REALLY IS WHERE.
WHERE COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW
THRIVE WHERE PEOPLE GO TO WORK
AND GO TO CHURCH AND SHOP AND
AND AND AND THAT AND IT'S AT
THAT PLACE THAT?
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE BY
DOWN THE REST CAN WE DO THAT IN
CALIFORNIA REALLY -- THROUGH --
HAZARD MITIGATION PLANNING AND
AND IN FACT -- BOB WHERE THE
MOST IMPORTANT WAYS THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT COMMUNITIES DON'T.
EXPERIENCE THESE LARGE SCALE
DISASTERS TO THE DEGREE THAT
THEY HAVE IS TO PRIORITIZE AND
WHERE APPLICABLE FIND HAZARD
MITIGATION PROJECTS -- IT'S IT'S
NOT.
EXCLUSIVELY A GOVERNMENT
RESPONSIBILITY IT'S A WHOLE OF
COMMUNITY APPROACH PUBLIC
PRIVATE NON GOVERNMENTAL THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY FAITH BASED AND THE
CITIZENS ALL COMING TOGETHER. TO
WORK TOGETHER AS CHIEF PORTER
SAID ALL OF THE THINGS YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR HAVE TO COME
TOGETHER -- IN AN EFFORT THIS IS
THIS IS A THIS IS A WHOLE OF
COMMUNITY APPROACH AND AND
REALLY WHAT IS MITIGATION IT IT
IT IS THE IS THE EFFORT TO
REDUCE LIFE.
A LOSS OF LIFE AND PROPERTY --
BY LESSENING THE IMPACTS OF THE
DISASTER WE'RE BUYING DOWN WHAT
THE IMPACTS WE'RE NOT GOING TO
PREVENT THE DISASTER FROM
HAPPENING.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO BUY
DOWN THE IMPACTS OF THE DISASTER
AND AS WE'VE SEEN IN SEVENTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN UP AND DOWN THE
STATE IT'S IT'S AN R. M. YOU
KNOW WHY WE RESPOND TO ALL OF
THESE IN SUCH A TREMENDOUS WAY.
TRULY THE ACHILLES HEEL OF ANY
THESE DISASTERS IS THE RECOVERY
IT'S THE COMPLEX -- ABILITY TO
GET PEOPLE'S LIVES BACK UP
ONLINE THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES AND AND AND
HELPING OUR PARK OUR COMMUNITIES
RECOVER -- THAT CAN BE LESSENED
SIGNIFICANTLY BY STRONG HAZARD
MITIGATION PROGRAMS AND REALLY
THERE'S MEDICATION IS IN A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT FORMS AS PRE
DISASTER MITIGATION THAT'S
THAT'S THE EFFORTS THAT CAN BE
PUT IN -- DURING AB A BEFORE AN
EVENT ACTUALLY OCCURS AND THEN --
POST DISASTER MITIGATION WHERE
WE'RE LEARNING FROM WHAT
OCCURRED -- MUCH LIKE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY -- AND
BEING ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
ADDITIONAL EFFORTS -- TO BUY
DOWN ANY FUTURE RISKS -- THE
FIRST PART OF THAT OF COURSE IS
UNDERSTANDING -- THE WHAT WHAT
RISKS KIRK AND OUT AGAIN IS AB
AND SO ARTICULATELY CHEAP FOR
AND SHE FOR TRIED LAID OUT IS.
IS THEY THEY REALLY TALKED ABOUT
THE RISKS THAT EXIST IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S REALLY
WHERE -- THE REPORT THAT CHIEF
PORTER TALKED ABOUT GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S REPORT AND BEING ABLE
TO IDENTIFY THOSE THOSE -- THOSE
THIRTY FIVE PRIORITY --
LOCATIONS AND AND BY DOWN THE
RISK.
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE BUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO REALLY THINK
ABOUT THIS THEY NEED.
TO GO INTO -- THEIR COMMUNITIES
WORKING WITH THEIR EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT THEIR FIRE DEPARTMENT
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE ROB
PUBLIC SERVICES AND REALLY DO AN
ASSESSMENT OF THEIR COMMUNITY TO
FIND.
OUT WHERE THE HIGHEST CHRIS ARE
AND THEN PRIORITIZE -- UP
POTENTIAL MITIGATION PROJECTS
WHERE THEY CAN START TO BUY DOWN
THOSE.
THOSE RISKS -- IN THIS CASE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WILDLAND
FIRE AND OF COURSE -- I TEACH
SHE'S RATE RETRY REALLY.
LAID OUT A GREAT NUMBER OF OF
THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE IN
ADVANCE OF THE NEXT -- A VENT.
IN CALIFORNIA WE DO HAVE THE
STATE HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN.
THAT PLAN REPRESENTS THE STATE'S
PRIMARY HIT -- HAZARD MITIGATION
GUIDANCE OF FOR NOT ONLY JUST
ALL THE STATE AGENCIES BUT ALSO
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- IT
PROVIDES -- AN UPDATED ANALYSIS
OF THE STATE'S HISTORICAL AND
CURRENT HAZARDS.
HAZARD MITIGATION GOALS
OBJECTIVES AND STRATEGIES AND
WHAT ACTIONS THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE THE MOVE FORWARD -- IT SETS
UP -- THE PRIORITIES AND
STRATEGIES FOR ALL OF THE
FUNDING THAT WE MAY GET. FOR HAS
MITIGATION AND UP IT ALSO
DESCRIBES HOW RISK ASSESSMENTS
AND MITIGATION STRATEGY
INFORMATION IS COORDINATED AND
LINK BETWEEN LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
GOVERNMENT -- LOCAL HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS AND THE STATE
AS MITIGATION PLAN AND PROVIDES
A A RESOURCE FOR OR LOCAL
PLANNERS -- OF RISK INFORMATION
AND AND THAT MAY AFFECT THE
PLANNING AREA.
THIS IS ALSO DONE IN
COORDINATION WITH OUR GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
WHICH IS WORKING ON LAND USE
PLANNING SO THE IDEA IS THAT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE GENERAL
PLAN AND THE HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN THEY COME TOGETHER.
THEY LINK TOGETHER AS
DEVELOPMENT STARTS -- TO BE
CONSIDERED -- THEY'RE THINKING
ABOUT WHAT ARE THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT DEVELOPMENT
IT SHOULD GO FORWARD AND THEY'RE
PUTTING A MITIGATION EFFORTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
DEVELOPMENT OUR COMMUNITY IS AS
RESILIENT AS POSSIBLE MOVING
FORWARD.
IN ADVANCE OF THE NEXT DISASTER
SO THERE'S A LOT OF EFFORTS AND
ACTIONS DEPENDING ON WE'RE A
COMMUNITY IS SITTING OR
INDIVIDUAL IS SITTING WITH THEIR
HAZARD MITIGATION PROGRAM.
INDIVIDUALS THEMSELVES WHEN YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW TO
MISSION PLANS BUT AS CHIEF FOR
MY MENTION INDIVIDUALS
THEMSELVES REALLY HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY AS WELL. TO LOOK
AT THE RISKS THAT EXIST AROUND
THEIR HOUSE THEIR HOME THEIR
PROPERTY.
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT IT IS
THAT THEY CAN DO TO START TO BUY
DOWN THE REST A SIMPLE THING IS
DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
RIGHT BUT IT COULD ALSO BE --
BASIC RETROFITTING OF YOUR HOME
IF YOU LIVE IN THE MOVIE -- IN
THE WILD AND LAND URBAN
INTERFACE AND YOU KNOW THAT
THERE IS A SPECIFIC PARTICULAR
RASK -- TO ENSURE THAT YOU'VE
DONE SOME BASIC MITIGATION
EFFORTS TO YOUR HOME -- ISSUES
SHOULD THERE BE A FIRE IN THE
AREA TO BUY DOWN THAT RISK.
IN IN IN THIS IS AN AREA WHERE
WHEN I STOCK ABOUT HALL OF
COMMUNITY WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAXIMIZE HAZARD
MITIGATION FUNDING.
THAT MAY BE AVAILABLE FROM THE
STATE OR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THEY MAY GO TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THE COULD HELP INDIVIDUALS --
THROUGH -- GRANTS -- OR
DIFFERENT KINDS OF PROGRAMS TO
HELP DO THAT RETROFITTING TYPE
PROGRAM THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
IS ANOTHER KEY PLAYER AND ALL OF
THIS AND THAT AND A KEY PLAYER
IN THAT.
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE A VESTED
INTEREST TO ENSURE THAT
HOMEOWNERS -- HAVE AS RESILIENT
A HOME AS POSSIBLE TO THE KIND
OF RISKS THAT THEY FACE WHETHER
YOU LIVE ON AN EARTHQUAKE FAULT --
AND YOU RICH FOR YOUR HOME FOR A
POTENTIAL EARTHQUAKE WELL YOU
LIVE IN THE WILD LAND FIRE AREA
RETROFITTING YOUR WHOLE FOOTBALL
FIRE IS A PRUDENT RESPONSIBLE
THING TO DO.
AND IT IS IN THE INTEREST OF THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY TO HELP
HOMEOWNERS BE ABLE TO GET THERE
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
ARE IMPORTANT NOTE THAT THE THE
PLAN CALIFORNIA OUR STATE HAS
MITIGATION PLAN WAS JUST UPDATED
APPROVED IN -- TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN YOU KNOW IT -- IF IT IS
ALSO FOLDED IN ALL OF THE
CLIMATE IMPACTS INTO THE
PLANNING ACTIVITIES -- IN FACT --
IT HAS THE MOST EXTENSIVE
CLIMATE SCIENCE AND STRATEGIES
THAN ANY OTHER PLAN IN THE
NATION AT THIS POINT.
WITH REGARDS OF A CURRENT --
SCIENCE UNDERSTANDING AND WHAT
WE'VE WE'VE PUT INTO THE A
PROGRAM.
AND BECAUSE OF THE HISTORIES OF
DISASTERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA --
YOU KNOW ENCOURAGING COMMUNITIES
TO ADOPT THEIR LOCAL HAZARD
MITIGATION PLAN.
EARLY IS A HIGH PRIORITY FOR US --
IN FACT YOU BE SURPRISED THAT --
OR MAYBE NOT THAT -- WHEN THESE
DISASTERS YET WE STILL HAVE
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE UP TO DATE
HAS A MEDICATION PLAN OR HOW
FAST MITIGATION PLAN?
AND SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT IT'S
A PRIORITY FOR AS IS BEEN A
PRIORITY FOR US TO GET
COMMUNITIES -- FOCUSED ON THEIR
HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN -- AND
THEN MAKE SURE THIS TIED TO THAT
GENERAL PLAN -- IN FACT THE
FEDERAL DISASTER MITIGATION ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND DOES REQUIRE
THAT STAGE REVIEW LOCAL HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS AS PART OF
THEIR STATE.
HAZARD MITIGATION PLANNING
PROCESS WHICH WE DO WHEN WE WENT
AWAY AT YES -- THE INTENT OF
THAT IS THREE FULL FIRST IS TO
GATHER HAZARD VULNERABILITY AND
MITIGATION INFORMATION FROM OUR
LOCAL -- LEVEL AND AND USE IT
FOR STATE LEVEL PLANNING.
SECOND IS TO ENSURE THE STATE
LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION PLANNING
IS COORDINATED TO THE GREATEST
EXTENT.
PRACTICAL AND THIRD IS TO ENSURE
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
MADE AWARE.
OF THE HAZARD -- HASN'T
VULNERABILITIES WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION AND TO DEVELOP
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE THOSE
VULNERABILITIES -- SO.
WE GET FUNDING THROUGH FEMA
TYPICALLY SO THERE'S A COUPLE
WAYS WE GET FUNDING TO SUPPORT
HAZARD MITIGATION PROGRAMS AT
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL --
WHEN WE HAVE A FEDERALLY
DECLARED DISASTER IN CALIFORNIA --%
ROUGHLY BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND 20%
OF THE TOTAL COST OF THAT
DISASTER IS COMES BACK TO THE
STATE.
IN THE FORM OF FUNDING FOR
HAZARD MITIGATION PROJECTS.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE WORK
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO GET
THEM TO IDENTIFY IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT A SPECIFIC FOR ANY.
PARTICULAR TYPE OF DISASTER.
WHEN HAS A MITIGATION FUNDS
COMMAND IT'S UP TO US TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION OF HOW HOW WE WANT
TO USE THOSE FUNDS -- BUT WE
WORK WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
SEEK THEM TO APPLY FOR GRANTS
THAT WE CAN -- WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD ON FOR EXAMPLE -- TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE HAD SIXTY
SIX MITIGATION PROJECTS -- THAT --
TOTALED CLOSE TO NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT WE MOVE FORWARD WE THEN
MOVE THOSE MITIGATION --
PROJECTS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THEY WERE FUNDED
BY FEMA AS PART OF THE FEDERAL
DOES -- HAZARD MITIGATION
PROGRAM IN -- TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE HAD AN ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
PROJECTS -- TOTALING CLOSE TO
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
HAZARD MITIGATION PROJECTS AND
THESE PROJECTS RANGED FROM --
SOMEWHERE SEISMIC IN NATURE
SOMEWHERE DROUGHT POST DROUGHT
RELATED IN NATURE -- SOMEWHERE --
WILDFIRE IN NATURE COMMENTS SO
WE WE WE LOOK AT WHERE THE
PRIORITIES EXIST FOR THE STATE
BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
SO MANY HIGH RISK -- CHALLENGES
IN CALIFORNIA FROM NATURAL
DISASTER IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WHILE WE'RE FOCUSING ON HIGH
PRIORITY WE ALSO NOT LOSING
SIGHT OF THE FACT THAT WE'VE GOT.
ALL OF THESE RICH THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE A SEVERAL
ONGOING FIRE MITIGATION PROJECTS
FROM MULTIPLE EVENTS IN THE PAST
INCLUDING YOU KNOW PROJECTS LIKE --
RETROFITTING OF WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE FOLLOWING THE
FIRES IN MENDOCINO COUNTY IN --
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN AND
WORK IN THE NORTH BAY -- AND
SANTA ROSA WE WE GET WEEK BUT I
RELATED TO REVEGETATION SLOPE
ARE WE PLANTING MEDICATION TO
WATERSHED.
AREAS -- IN MARIPOSA COUNTY --
ECCENTRIC.
AND OF AT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
SORRY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- DID CHANGE
UP THEIR THEIR POSTURE ON HAZARD
MITIGATION AND THE THE PRESIDENT
DID SIGN IT INTO LAW THE
DISASTER RECOVERY REFORM ACT --
AND THIS PARTICULAR ACT --
ALLOWS FOR A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF PRE DISASTER FUNDING WHICH WE
HISTORICALLY HAVE NOT GOT IN
CALIFORNIATO ANY DEGREE -- PRE
DISASTER FUNNY NOW IS IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED MILLION.
I TO COMPETITIVE PROCESS THAT
CALIFORNIA IS APPLYING -- FOR TO
BE ABLE TO GET -- A SHARE OF THE
MONEY BUT THESE ARE THESE ARE --
TO DO MITIGATION PROJECTS IN
ADVANCE OF A DISASTER WHICH IS
VERY SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IT
PLAYS INTO WHAT A LOT OF CAL
FIRE IS DOING NOW IN BEING ABLE
TO IDENTIFY HIGH RISK AREAS.
AND BEING ABLE TO PUT FUNDING
AND CAPABILITIES -- BEHIND THOSE
THOSE PRE EVENT -- PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
SO -- I JUST SAVE -- INC IN
CLOSING YOU KNOW IS A FOCUS ON
HOW TO MITIGATION.
PLANNING IS ANOTHER PIECE -- MOB
PART OF THE A LOCAL PLANNING --
INCLUDES -- EVACUATION PLANNING
ON HAVING AN UPDATED EMERGENCY
PLAN -- THAT REFLECTS THE
CURRENT RISK THAT COMMUNITIES
FACE -- THESE ARE PLANS THAT
SHOULD BE ALL HAZARD IN NATURE A
CHEAPER MENTIONED A LITTLE BIT
BUT OUR OUR PLANS ALWAYS HAVE TO
LOOK AT HOW WE GOING TO DEAL
WITH ALL THE KINDS OF DISASTERS
ARE GOING TO FACE -- SO THAT
THERE'S AYE AYE NOW IF OF
ATTENTION GIVEN TO DO WE HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES HOW WE THOUGHT
THROUGH THE RESILIENCY AND
CAPACITY OF OUR COMMUNITY.
DO WE HAVE A AFFECTED ENOUGH
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER
CAPABILITY.
IF I DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCE TO
I KNOW WHERE TO GET THEM.
AND THEN OUR ABILITY TO RAPIDLY
AS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT TRANSITION
FROM RESPONSE INTO RECOVERY MODE
WHICH INCLUDES EVERYTHING FROM
HOUSING -- TOO YOU KNOW --
INFRASTRUCTURE REBUILDING -- KEY
THINGS LIKE WATERS IN SEWERS AND
OTHER KINDS OF THINGS THAT GET
DAMAGED AFTER A DISASTER.
THERE ARE.
LITERALLY A MILLION CASCADING.
ISSUES FOLLOWING A MAJOR
DISASTER OF THAT THAT WE ALL
HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER.
HOPING TO THINK THROUGH AS MANY
OF THOSE.
AS POSSIBLE ON THE PART OF OUR
LOCAL AND STATE GOVERNMENT IS
REALLY REALLY CRITICAL TO BE
ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY -- AND
EFFICIENTLY RECOVER FROM AN
EVENT LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- GOOD
AFTERNOON MISS CORDON WELCOME
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I SO I'M K<c.cyan> GORDON AND THE</c>
DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
WHICH ALSO HOUSES THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL WHICH I CHAIR I'M
ALSO THE GOVERNOR SENIOR ADVISER
ON CLIMATE CHANGE AND SO.
IN THOSE MULTIPLE ROLES I HAVE
HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATION OVER
THE LAST HUNDRED DAYS ABOUT FIRE
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE -- THANK YOU
SO MUCH CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF
THE THREE COMMITTEES FOR
INVITING US HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH AND THOSE OF OVERALL
CLIMATE -- OVERLAY OF THIS OF
THIS TOPIC DURING THE WILDFIRE
AWARENESS WEEK AND I THINK WHAT
WHAT ALSO A REALLY BUILDS ON
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN HEARING -- FROM
MY COLLEAGUES -- TO MY LEFT.
SO AS IN THE VARIOUS ROLES THAT
I PLAY IN PARTICULARLY THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
WE DO A LOT OF WORK ACROSS ALL
OF THESE AREAS PARTICULARLY ON I
PLANNING IN LAND USE WHICH I'LL
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT BUT
ALSO THE INTERSECTION WHICH YOU
SAID AT THE BEGINNING -- AND
EMPHASIZED PARTICULARLY CHURCH
YOU ON OF HOUSING -- AND
TRANSPORTATION ON THESE ISSUES.
HOW WE INTEGRATE THESE ISSUES
THAT YOU'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT
OF RISK AND RESILIENCE INTO OUR
LONG TERM HOUSING?
AND PLANNING IS A CRITICAL ISSUE
FOR THE STATE GOING FORWARD AND
ONE THAT I THINK WILL REALLY
SHAPE CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE.
LET ME GIVE A QUICK OVERVIEW
FIRST OF OF THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH IS ROLE IN
LONG TERM PLANNING WE EXISTENCE
STATUTE AS I'M SURE YOU KNOW AS
THE LONG TERM PLANNING AGENCY
FOR THE GOVERNOR AND THE CABINET.
AS A RESULT OF THAT ROLE WE END
UP DOING A LOT OF WORK SORT OF
AT A HIGH LEVEL ON GENERAL
PLANNING CLIMATE RESILIENCE --
WE ALSO AS YOU KNOW I'VE MANAGED
TO SEE WHAT GUIDELINES BUT WE
ALSO DO AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
WORK INTERACTING DIRECTLY WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE'RE PROBABLY
ONE OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
DEPARTMENTS AND SPENDS THE MOST
TIME TALKING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND SO WE'RE IN A PRIVILEGED
POSITION TO REALLY.
HEAR ALL THE TIME ABOUT HOW
THESE POLICIES AT A HIGH LEVEL
ARE INTERACTING AT A LOCAL LEVEL.
WHICH I THINK IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT IN THIS MOMENT OF
CRISIS.
WE'RE IN TODAY IN TERMS OF
PLANNING.
OPR PRODUCES THE GENERAL MIND
GUIDELINES -- WHICH GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE INFORMATION AND
THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED TO
DEVELOP A LONG RANGE PLANS AND
BLUEPRINTS FOR HOW THEIR
COMMUNITIES WILL GROW.
AND DEVELOP GIVE AND POPULATION
PROJECTIONS DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTIONS LAND PROJECTIONS --
THE GENERAL PLANS AS YOU MAY
KNOW -- INCLUDE BOTH REQUIRED
ELEMENTS SO YOU HEAR A LOT ABOUT
THE HOUSING ELEMENT WHICH IS A
REQUIRED ELEMENT OF THE GENERAL
PLAN ALSO RECOMMENDED
RECOMMENDED ELEMENTS THERE'S A
CLIMATE ELEMENT FOR INSTANCE
WHICH IS RECOMMENDED.
AND DATA TOOLS AND WE AT OPR DO
A LOT OF WORK HELPING PEOPLE
KIND OF SORT.
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE UP TO DO
THE GENERAL PLANS HAPPEN TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND ADDITIONAL
CHANGES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
INCLUDED. FIVE EIGHT AND
IMPORTANT FOR THIS CONVERSATION
GUIDANCE FOR CLIMATE
INCORPORATING CLIMATE CHANGE
INTO THOSE.
GUIDELINES WE ALSO.
AS YOU HEARD FROM DIRECTOR GO
GEE GEE WE'RE WE'VE BEEN VERY
INVOLVED IN WORKING WITH WITH
HIS OFFICE ON THE HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS WE ALSO HELP
COMMUNITIES WITH THE SAFETY
ELEMENT.
OF THE GENERAL PLAN WHICH IS A
MANDATORY ELEMENT OF THE GENERAL
PLAN AND THAT INCLUDES
SPECIFICALLY CONSIDERATIONS FOR
WILD FIRE HAZARDS AS WELL AS
OTHER HAZARDS.
IN THE STATE IN THE SAFETY ON OF
THE GENERAL PLANS COMMUNITIES
MUST IDENTIFY FIRE HAZARD
STONE'S.
EXISTING AND PLANNED DEVELOPMENT
WITHIN THE AREAS OF HIGH FIRE
HAZARD AND IDENTIFY THE AGENCIES
AND SORT OF THAT RESPONSE
PLANNED OUT RESPONSIBLE FOR FIRE
PROTECTION.
AND THE GOAL THAT SAFETY ALLMAN
IS REALLY TO PROTECT COMMUNITY
FROM UNREASONABLE RISKS SITE
ESSENTIAL FACILITIES AWAY FROM
HIGHEST SO IF FIRE HAZARD DOES
WHEN POSSIBLE INTAKE MITIGATION
MET MEASURES TO REDUCE RISK TO
CURRENT STRUCTURES.
WE ALSO -- I SHOULD SAY THAT SB
THREE SEVENTY NINE PASSED BY
SENATOR JACKSON IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN REQUIRED UPDATES TO THE
SAFETY ELEMENT. TO SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCY AND I'LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT
INTERSECTION IN A MINUTE -- BUT
THAT UPDATE.
NEEDS TO BE BASED ON STATE
RESOURCES THAT WE AND OTHERS
MANAGE INCLUDING KHALLID OUT AND
CALIFORNIA ADAPTATION PLANNING
GUIDE -- AT OPR WE ALSO PRODUCE
THE FIRE HAZARD TECHNICAL
ADVISORY TO HELP COMMUNITIES --
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THINK
YOU'RE WILD FIRE MITIGATION AND
PREPAREDNESS SO.
ALL OF THOSE PIECES IN
COMBINATION WITH EVERYTHING YOU
HEARD HERE ARE REALLY THE SHORT
TERM WHAT COMMUNITIES DO WITH
THEIR EXISTING STRUCTURES WITH
THEIR EXISTING PLANS.
UP TO BETTER PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND TO REDUCE RISK BUT THERE'S
ALSO A LONGER TERM PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION WHICH IS THE HOW DO
WE START TO PLAN FOR THE FUTURE.
WHEN WE KNOW AND MY COLLEAGUE
AND TERRIBLE TALK MUCH MORE
ABOUT THIS BUT WE KNOW THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS EXACERBATING
ALL THESE IMPACTS?
OF THAT WET SEASONS COMBINED AND
DRY SEASONS AS YOU KNOW CREATE
MORE VEGETATION WHICH THEN DRIES
OUT WHICH CREATES A SITUATION.
THAT'S RIGHT FOR MORE FREQUENT
AND SEVERE WILDFIRES THAT IS
HAPPENING IN COMBINATION WITH.
AND AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IN THE
STATE THAT'S MOVING PEOPLE
FURTHER AND FURTHER OUT OF SOME
OF THE MORE URBAN JOB CENTERS OF
THE STATE.
I I WAS THAT I IDEA EVENT WITH A
NUMBER OF FOLKS FROM PARADISE
RECENTLY WHO WERE TALKING ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLAR A MONTH TWO
BEDROOM HOUSES IN PARADISE.
THAT'S NOT A NUMBER YOU HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
ARE MOVING FURTHER OUT IN PART
TO FIND AFFORDABILITY A LOT OF
THOSE FOLKS ARE SENIORS ON MIXED
AND ON FIXED INCOMES.
WE KNOW FROM ALL THE DATA AS YOU
ALL KNOW THAT THE MAJORITY OF
THE FATALITIES IN THESE FIRES WE
HAVE BEEN PEOPLE OVER.
SIXTY FIVE ON ZERO SORT OF
GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED SOCIALLY
ISOLATED FOLKS HAVING LESS
MOBILITY HARDER TO GET OUT OF
THEIR HOMES AND A LOT OF THAT IS
EXACT NOT ALL BUT SOME OF IT IS
EXACERBATED BY THE AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS.
SO ALTERNATELY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO START
THINKING ABOUT THESE RISKS WHEN
DOING LONG TERM PLANNING.
WE NOW ON THE HOUSING SIDE WHICH
WERE ALSO VERY INVOLVED IN THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE REQUIRED
TO PLAN FOR THEIR HOUSING NEEDS
WERE HAVING A VERY ACTIVE STATE
CONVERSATION AND OF COURSE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS.
HAVING AN ACTIVE CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT THOSE PROJECTIONS
LOOK LIKE AND WHAT ARE HOUSING
NEEDS ARE.
UNFORTUNATELY SHORTFALLS IN OUR
HOUSING HIS COULD HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THIS THIS URGENCY
IN THIS EMERGENCY AFFORDABILITY
SITUATION THERE IS AN EXTREME
SHORTAGE OF HOUSING IN THE STATE
AS YOU KNOW EVERYONE OF YOUR
DISTRICTS HAS THIS PROBLEM.
YOU POINTED OUT -- REQUIRING
CALIFORNIANS TO SPEND AN
INCREASING AMOUNT OF MONEY ON
HOUSING BUT ALSO AN INCREASING
AMOUNT ON TRANSPORTATION.
SO IT'S SORT OF EXACERBATING ALL
THESE ISSUES AND THEN ULTIMATELY
PUSHING FOLKS -- IN SOME CASES
INTO THESE WE WE AREAS THESE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE AREAS.
WE CANNOT USE THE HOUSING CRISIS
AS A REASON TO EXPAND HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT OVER THE LONG TERM
INTO AREAS OF THE STATE THAT ARE
THAT ARE.
EXTREMELY HIGH RISK.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW JUST FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
ACROSS ALL THESE AREAS WHETHER
IT'S RISK AND LIABILITY TO THE
STATE AND INDIVIDUALS.
BOB ALSO WHETHER IT'S RISK TO
UNDERMINING THE VERY CLIMATE
GOALS THAT CALIFORNIA LEADS ON
THAT ARE WE HOPE.
GOING TO EVENTUALLY MINIMIZE OUR
FIRE RISK IF WE CAN BRING
EMISSIONS DOWN.
WE'RE THE AREA IN WHICH WE ARE
INCREASING EMISSIONS MOST EVERY
DAY IN THE STATE IS IN
TRANSPORTATION AND LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES PEOPLE TRAVELING.
FARTHER AND FARTHER TO GET FROM
HOME TO WORK TO GET FROM HOME TO
SCHOOL THESE ARE INTER RELATED
ISSUES AND WE CAN'T RISK OUR
CLIMATE GOALS.
BY NOT ADDRESSING THIS LARGER
CRISIS OF HOUSING AND LONG TERM
DEVELOPMENT.
SO ALL OF THESE KIND OF ISSUES
CAN TO GOD CAME TOGETHER IN --
THE REPORT THAT RECENTLY CAME
OUT FROM THE WILD FIRE STRIKE
FORCE OF THE ENERGY STRIKE FORCE
TEAM OF THE GOVERNOR WHICH BOTH
CHIEF PORTER.
AND I WERE PART OF ANY IN THAT
REPORT -- ONE SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE ACTUALLY ON
LAND USE THE REPORT DID SURFACE
SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND MAKE
THE FOLLOWING RECOMMENDATIONS --
FIRST OF THAT STATE AND REGIONAL
GOVERNMENTS IN PLAINER SHOULD
INCORPORATE CAL FIRES RISK
PROJECTIONS AS WELL AS FIRE
PROJECTIONS IN CLIMATE
PROJECTIONS FROM THE ADAPTATION
CLEARING HOUSE AND FOR CLIMATE
ASSESSMENT.
INTO SHORT AND LONG TERM
PLANNING THAT WE ACTUALLY CAN'T
THINK OF THIS AS A LUXURY.
OR A SIDE ISSUE TO INCORPORATE
THESE CLIMATE PROJECTIONS BUT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY
CRITICAL IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING THE REST TO
DEVELOPMENT PATTERNS IN
COMMUNITIES.
BOB WE I IN THAT REPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE MADE THE CASE
THAT WE SHOULD BE.
DE PRIORITIZE A NEW DEVELOPMENT
IN VERY HIGH RISK EXTREME VIRUS
CARRIES OF THE STATE.
AND SIMULTANEOUSLY ENCOURAGING
DEVELOPMENT AS THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IS DOING AND MANY OF YOU
LEGISLATURE DOING.
PRIORITIZING I'M DEVELOPMENT AND
I EXISTING URBAN AREAS THAT ARE
LOWER.
IN ORDER TO TRY TO ALLEVIATE THE
HOUSING CRISIS WITHOUT PUTTING.
MORE AND MORE PRESSURE ON THESE
HIGH RISK SOUNDS.
WE ALSO -- OR THE REPORT ALSO
DIRECTED MY OFFICE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH TO PRIORITIZE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SUPPORT TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HIGH
FIRE RISK AND YOU IN TURN I
THINK WE'LL TALK A BIT ABOUT HOW
WE'RE DOING THAT WE'RE DOING A
FAIR AMOUNT OF WORK IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW.
ON THE GROUND.
I'M MANY OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
ARE RURAL AND UNDER RESOURCE TO
AND LACKING IN THE KIND OF
PLANNING CAPACITY THAT SOME OF
THE MORE URBAN AREAS OF THE
STATE HOUSE.
AND SO THERE'S A BIT WE FEEL IN
OUR OFFICE THAT WE'VE A
PARTICULAR RESPONSIBILITY. TO
REACH OUT TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN THOSE AREAS.
ULTIMATELY WE ARE GRAPPLING WITH
THESE FIRES -- WHICH OF A FACT
EVERYONE'S ABILITY TO LIVE AND
THRIVE IN THE STATE.
WE NEED TO BE PROACTIVELY
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO REDUCE
THESE RISKS AND JUST TO MY
COLLEAGUES POINT A PARTICULAR
DIRECTOR GIL REACHES POINT.
WE NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT
THAT NOT JUST IN THE IN THE
CONTEXT OF FIRES FIRES ARE
TODAY'S ISSUE TO MARS ISSUE WILL
BE FLOODING AND THEN THE NEXT
ISSUE WILL BE EXTREME HEAT AND
PASS AND THEN THE NEXT ISSUE
WILL BE.
SEA LEVEL RISE IMPACTS ON OUR
WATER SUPPLY AND THEY'RE KIND OF
CALIFORNIA IS A BEAUTIFUL
BEAUTIFUL STATE WITH THE
UNFORTUNATE REALITY OF HAVING
EVERY CLIMATE IMPACT THAT EXIST
EXIST SOMEWHERE IN IT.
SO WE ARE GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT THIS THROUGHOUT OUR LONG
TERM PLANNING AND AND GROWTH
CONVERSATIONS AND IT REALLY IS A
MOMENT I THINK THIS.
GIVES US A MOMENT TO REALLY TAKE
A STEP BACK AND THINK
STRATEGICALLY ABOUT WHAT THAT
MEANS.
AT THE STATE LEVEL AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL AND HOW WE CAN
REALLY PLAN.
MORE -- MORE ADEQUATELY FOR THE
FUTURE IN A WAY THAT THAT THAT
DOESN'T THAT PUT OUR OUR PEOPLE
AND OUR COMMUNITIES AT RISK.
I'M TO TURN THINGS OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE RETARDED TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT BOTH THE CLIMATE
IMPACT SIDE OF THIS ISSUE AND
THE COMMUNITY SIDE THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- THANK YOU TO THE CHAIRS
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES --
FOR INVITING ME HERE TO JOIN
THIS PANEL TODAY I'M NEW IN TARA
KEY I AM ARE CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR IN THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
I ALSO CHAIR OUR ADAPTATION
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COUNCIL AS
WELL WHICH I'LL DESCRIBE HERE IN
A MINUTE.
A BUILDING OFF OF MUCH OF WHAT
THE REST OF THE PANEL HERE AND
AND DIRECTOR GORDON HAS -- LAID
OUT I'M GONNA BRIEFLY HIGHLIGHT
HOW WE WORK TO SUPPORT LOCAL
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE
EFFORTS THROUGH THE INTEGRATED
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCY PROGRAM OR R.
ADAPTATION PROGRAM AND PR.
I CARP IS THE ACRONYM SO IF I
USE THAT THAT'S WHAT I'M
REFERRING TO IS OUR ADAPTATION
PROGRAM -- SO SENATE BILL TWO
FORTY SIX ESTABLISHED I CARP IN
OUR OFFICE AND THERE ARE TWO
COMPONENTS PER THE ENABLING
LEGISLATION.
THE CREATION OF A TECHNICAL
ADVISORY COUNCIL WHICH I'LL
DESCRIBE IN A MINUTE AS WELL AS
OUR ADAPTATION CLEARING HOUSE
WHICH ALSO DESCRIBE.
BUT OUR CHARGE PER THE ENABLING
LEGISLATION IS REALLY TO WORK TO
BETTER ONLINE STATE AND LOCAL
EFFORTS ON ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE BUT REALLY WITH AN
EYE TOWARD SUPPORTING LOCAL
IMPLEMENTATION.
SO GIVEN THE POINTS THAT
DIRECTOR GORDAN LAID OUT IN OUR
ROLE IN -- PR WE REALLY HAVE
THIS GREAT OPPORTUNITY AT OPR TO
HELP WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- PARTNERS
AROUND THE STATE AND TRYING TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT OF THEIR
NEEDS AND AND WHAT ARE THE
CHALLENGES AND ALSO
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET WORK
IMPLEMENTED ON THE GROUNDS THAT
BUILDS OUR RESILIENCE.
SO WE TAKE A BROAD VIEW AS IN
MANY OF THE MY COLLEAGUES HERE
HAVE ALSO MENTIONED IN TERMS OF
HOW WE THINK ABOUT RESILIENCE
AND WE THINK ABOUT RESILIENCE IN.
THE TERMS OF INVESTMENTS IN OUR
BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE WHETHER
THAT'S HOUSING OR ROADWAYS OR
YOU KNOW OTHER BUILD ASSETS BUT
WE'RE ALSO THINKING ABOUT
RESILIENCE AND HOW WE'RE
MANAGING OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
AND NATURAL ASSETS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THEN
EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT THINKING
ABOUT HOW WE'RE SUPPORTING
COMMUNITIES AND MAKING SURE THAT
COMMUNITIES.
ALL MEMBERS OF COMMUNITIES HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO RESPOND TO AND
THRIVE IN SPITE OF THE IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
SO GOING BACK TO OUR PROGRAM
QUICKLY JUST TO GIVE A HIGHLIGHT
ON THOSE TWO COMPONENTS OF OUR
WORK -- WE HAVE THE ADAPTATION
CLEARING HOUSE WHICH IS REALLY
INTENDED TO SERVE OF A COMMUNITY
OF PRACTICE AROUND THE STATE AND
REALLY TRYING TO HELP SUPPORT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
PRACTITIONERS BUILD THEIR
CAPACITY IN BRINGING CLIMB IT
INTO THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING
ON THE LONG RANGE PLANNING INTO
ALSO AND ALSO PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION AND EFFORTS IN
THE NEAR TERM.
SO WE YOU SEE THE CLEARING HOUSE
AS OF GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
MANY OF THE RESOURCES THAT WERE
DESCRIBED HERE THAT OUR SISTER
AGENCIES DEVELOP AND THOSE TOOLS
TOGETHER IN ONE PLACE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO AXIS.
WE DEFINITELY HIGHLIGHTS STATE
RESOURCES LIKE CALIDAD UP AS
WELL AS THE STATE HAZARD
MITIGATION PLAN AND GUIDANCE
FROM CALLOW YES AS WELL AS MANY
OF THE OTHER RESOURCES YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT HERE.
THE OTHER COMPONENT OF THE
PROGRAM IS OUR TECHNICAL
ADVISORY COUNCIL AND THE COUNCIL
REALLY IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION ACROSS
STATE AGENCIES WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER CRITICAL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
NON PROFITS AS WELL AS BUSINESS
AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AS WELL
IN THIS SPACE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WATER THE CHALLENGES
AND BEAR YEARS THAT COMMUNITIES
ON THE GROUND ARE FACING AND HOW
DO WE AS STATE AGENCIES AND AS
PARTNERS IN THIS HELP TO ALIGN
OUR EFFORTS.
AND MANY OF THOSE EFFORTS WERE
TALKED ABOUT HERE BUT ALL HIGH
LIKE A COUPLE OF THOSE THAT
WE'VE BEEN IN YOU KNOW IN
PARTNERSHIP SPECIFICALLY WITH
CALLOW YES FOR EXAMPLE ON A
LINING GENERAL PLANTS AND LOCAL
HAZARD MITIGATION PLANS.
BUT THE COUNCIL IS A REALLY A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO HAVE
THAT DIALOGUE WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS TO INFORM THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING ITS STATE AGENCIES.
SO OUR COUNCIL PROVIDES GUIDANCE
TO OPR INTO OUR ADAPTATION
PROGRAM ON A BROAD ARRAY OF
RESILIENCE TOPICS AS WAS
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WILD FIRES
ONE OF MANY MANY CLIMATE IMPACTS
HERE -- BUT WHAT KEY AREA
ESPECIALLY FOR THE OVER THE LAST
YEAR OR SO HAS BEEN OUR TOPIC
HAS BEEN AROUND SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE AND HOW LOCALS ARE ACTUALLY
MOVING FORWARD IN IMPLEMENTING.
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR IN THEIR
GENERAL PLAN AND TRYING TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE
IN ACTUALLY BEING ABLE TO
INCORPORATE CLIMB INTO THEIR
GENERAL PLANS.
AND THE THE ISSUE OF PRE AND
POST WILD FIRE PLANNING HAVE
BEEN TWO VERY IMPORTANT TOPICS
THAT HAVE COME UP THROUGH THE
COURSE OF OUR CONVERSATION WITH
OUR COUNCIL AND THE WORK FOR
DOING IT -- PR.
SO ONE AREA THAT I WANT TO TOUCH
ON THAT -- WAS MENTIONED HERE --
BUT EARLIER IS THAT WE'VE DONE A
FAIR AMOUNT OF WORK TO TRY TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE THE
FACTORS AND CONDITIONS THAT ARE
DRIVING VULNERABILITY WITHIN
COMMUNITIES RECOGNIZING THAT
UNDERLYING SOCIOECONOMIC FACTORS
AS WELL AS YOU KNOW ACCESS IN
OUR BUILT INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND OTHER UNDERLYING CONDITIONS
ARE JUST EXACERBATED BY CLIMATE
IMPACTS SO WE GO THROUGH OUR
COUNCIL HAVE DEVELOPED A
DEFINITION FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS GUIDANCE
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
IN THEIR PLANNING PROCESS SEES
ON HOW TO MAKE THAT DEFINITION
ACTIONABLE IN THEIR WORK.
AND WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
CAL FIRE IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE FORTY FIVE DAY REPORT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WORK AND THE
INPUT THAT CAME THROUGH THAT
PROCESS FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WAS REFLECTED IN THAT STATE
EFFORT.
SO RETURNING BACK TO SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE AND THE GENERAL
PLAN WE KNOW THATFOR MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THREE SEVENTY NINE
AND MEETING THAT REQUIREMENT
WILL REALLY BE THE FIRST TIME
THAT THEY ARE INCORPORATING.
CLIMATE INTO THEIR COMIC
ADAPTATION INTO THEIR GENERAL
PLAN.
SO WE ARE VERY INTERESTED GIVEN
THAT THIS IS A RELATIVELY NEW
REQUIREMENT IN BETTER
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE LOCAL
CHALLENGES BARRIERS AND ALSO
INNOVATIONS THAT LOCALS ARE
TAKING IN BRINGING THIS
INFORMATION IN.
SO WE ARE EMBARKING ON DOING
KIND OF A LANDSCAPE ASSESSMENT
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND AND TO
ENGAGE WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
GET THAT INFORMATION. TO HELP
INFORM OUR WORK AS WELL AS THAT
OF OUR STATE PARTNERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING THE
RIGHT TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO
ENABLE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MEET
THOSE REQUIREMENTS --
ANECDOTALLY WE'VE HEARD THAT YOU
KNOW MANY OF A LOCAL PARTNERS
ARE AND YOU KNOW RUNNING INTO
STICKING POINTS WITH SOME OF THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS AND
PARTICULARLY RUNNING INTO SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES OF HOW TO
INCORPORATE CLIMATE PROJECTIONS.
INTO PLANNING GIVEN THE LEVEL OF
UNCERTAINTY AND ALSO COMPOUNDING
ISSUES BETWEEN CLIMATE BUILT
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU KNOW AND ALSO --
YOU KNOW CASCADING IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE LIKE WILDFIRE AND
FLOODING AND LANDSLIDES -- AND
HOW THAT HOW DO YOU INCORPORATE
THAT INTO YOUR PLANNING EFFORTS.
SO ONE OTHER AREA THAT ALL
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON IS WE'VE DONE A
FAIR AMOUNT OF WORK WITH OUR
FEDERAL AND STATE PARTNERS TO
ALSO THINK ABOUT HOW WE SUPPORT
PLAN ALIGNMENT.
AND THIS IS WHERE THROUGH A
GREAT PARTNERSHIP WITH CALLAWAY
YES WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK VERY
CLOSELY AROUND HOW WE SUPPORT
ALIGNMENT BETWEEN GUIDANCE WE'RE
GIVING ON THE GENERAL PLANS --
YES IS GIVING ON LOCAL HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS AND REALLY
WORKING TO IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEVERAGE THESE
LOCAL PLANS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE SUPPORTIVE OF BOTH NEAR
TERM AND LONG TERM CLIMATE AND
PLANNING GOALS -- WE ALSO --
THIS BRINGS ME TO MY AS A SORRY
THIS POINT ON PLAN ALIGNMENT
ALSO BRINGS ME NOW THE LAST
POINT ABOUT OUR WORK THROUGH I
CARP WHICH IS.
REALLY WORKING TO COORDINATE
STATE EFFORTS SO MANY STATE
AGENCIES ISSUE A LOT OF GUIDANCE
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THERE
ARE A LOT OF REQUIREMENTS THERE
I'M ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
REALLY BEEN FOCUSING ON IS HOW
WE BRING.
OUR STATE PARTNERS TOGETHER SO
THAT IN WHEN WE'RE ISSUING
GUIDANCE AND RESOURCES TO LOCALS
WHERE ALIGNED AND SUPPORTIVE OF
THEIR NEEDS.
SO THE LAST POINT -- BEFORE I
CONCLUDE HERE IS THAT I WANT TO
JUST MENTION THAT OPR IS WORKING
AS PART OF THE STATE RECOVERY
SUPPORT FUNCTIONS AND RECOVERY
EFFORTS IN BUTTE AND PARADISE.
AND WE ARE WORKING HAND IN HAND
WITH CALLAWAY YES AND MANY OF
OUR OTHER STATE PARTNERS. TO
REALLY PROVIDE THE RECOVERY
SUPPORT NEEDS FOR COMMUNITIES --
FRONT THAT WERE AFFECTED BY THE
CAMPFIRE AND IN REAL TIME WE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITIES HOW
WE HAVE NEAR TERM RECOVERY
EFFORTS AND PROJECTS.
HELP SUPPORT LONG TERM
RESILIENCE AND AND COMMUNITY
PLANNING EFFORTS -- SO YOU KNOW
WE THINK WE'RE ALL WORKING HERE
TOGETHER AS OUR STATE PARTNERS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
REALLY SUPPORT LOCAL
IMPLEMENTATION AND BUILDING
RESILIENCE ACROSS THAT WITH OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONAL PARTNERS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
YOUR INFORMATIONS OVERWHELMING
AND I MUST ADMIT A LITTLE BIT OF
DEPRESSING.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
WE'RE GONNA GO MY GOSH AGO THE
RUPIAH HEAD OF US -- I'D LIKE TO
OPEN UP QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIRS FOR LETTING ME CRASH
ON THE HEARING TODAY --I ALSO
WANT TO THANK ALL THE PANELISTS
FOR BEING HERE AND GIVING US
SUCH COMPREHENSIVE --
PRESENTATIONS I THINK THAT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
ARE VERY WELL SERVED BY ALL OF
YOU AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL TAKE
SOME COMFORT IN KNOWING THAT WE
HAVE -- EXPERTS LIKE YOURSELF
DEVOTING ALL OF YOUR TIME TO I
TRYING TO KEEP US SAFE AND MAKE
A SAFER SO THANK YOU -- I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS MY FIRST IS --
YOU KNOW I'VE NEVER BEEN TO
JAPAN BUT I'M TOLD THAT THEY
HAVE EXTREMELY COMPREHENSIVE
PUBLIC TRAINING ABOUT EMERGENCY
PREPARATION AND HAVE EXTREMELY
ORGANIZED.
BLOCK CAPTAINS AND EVERYBODY
KNOWS WHAT TO DO AN EMERGENCY
KIND OF LIKE WHAT WE DO WITH
KINDERGARTEN KIDS BUT YOU KNOW
FOR ADULTS AND FOR ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES.
AND WE HAVE OUR SEARCH PROGRAM
WHICH SOME PEOPLE DO AND WHICH
IS GREAT BUT TENDS TO BE KIND OF
FUNDED THE NOT FUNDED AN ACTIVE
NOT ACTIVE IN ITS VOLUNTARY AND
YOU MAY HAVE ONE PERSON ONE AREA
THAT'S DONE IT BUT THE REST OF
PEOPLE ON THE BLOCK DON'T.
EVEN KNOW SO IS A TIME FOR US TO
THINK ABOUT IN SOME AREAS A MORE.
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE PROGRAM
THAT IS NOT VOLUNTARY FOR PEOPLE
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE TO HAVE DRILLS
AND HAVE TO LEARN WHAT TO DO IN
AN EMERGENCY AND WHAT THEIR ROLE
IS AND WHAT EVERYBODY ELSE'S
ROLE.
I PROBABLY FALLS WITH ME ON THAT --
ONE SO I'VE ACTUALLY WORKED UP
QUITE A BIT IN JAPAN AND AND AND
WORK WITH THE JAPANESE
GOVERNMENT -- AND WE'VE GOT
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE JAPANESE --
EIGHT FIRST OF ALL -- THEY THEY
DO HAVE -- A VERY EXTENSIVE.
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS PROGRAM --
BUT THEY ALSO HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT CULTURE THAN WE DO --
AND AND THEIR THEIR CULTURE IS
IS ONE OF OF BATES -- YOU KNOW I
DON'T WANT BANKS HAVE TRIED MY
BEST WORDS BUT YOU KNOW THEY
IT'S A COMPLIANCE.
MORE COMPLIANT CULTURE -- THEY
START AT A VERY YOUNG AGE
PRESCHOOL AND AND AND START
START TRAINING.
ALL ON THE FACT PREDOMINANTLY
EARTHQUAKE RELATED BECAUSE THEY
HAVE HUGE EARTHQUAKES IN JAPAN
AND SO -- EARTHQUAKE
PREPAREDNESS IS ONE OF THEIR
HUGE -- FOCUS POINTS -- THEY
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF OTHER KINDS
DESPERATE TSUNAMI IS ANOTHER ONE
THAT THEY FOCUS IN ON AND THEIR
THEIR CENTRAL GOVERNMENT.
DOES -- FIND A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF OF EFFORT TO PROVIDE
TRAININGS AND IT BECOMES A THEIR
CULTURE A SENSE OF COMMUNITY
PRIDE. TO BE ABLE TO BUILD BLOCK.
CAPTAINS IN BLOCK TEAMS -- AND
THEY ACTUALLY ACT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE -- COMPETITIONS.
THAT MOVE FORWARD -- HERE
CALIFORNIA AND YOU KNOW -- I I
THINK THAT -- ONE OF THE
GREATEST THINGS THAT WE CAN --
ENCOURAGE IS BUILDING A CULTURE
PREPAREDNESS -- WE DO.
IT IN A DIFFERENT WAY -- AND NOT
AS A COMPLETE A COMPLIANT -- AS
THE JAPANESE ARE BUT YOU LOOK AT
FIRE SAFETY AND AND YOU KNOW NOW
CAN ACTIVE SHOOTER AND OTHER
KINDS OF THINK EARTHQUAKE
PREPAREDNESS DOC -- DROP COVER
AND HOLD SCHOOL KIDS START TO DO
THAT THEY THEY LEARNED THAT
THROUGH THEIR WHOLE LIVES IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE EARTHQUAKE
RISK -- WILDFIRE DROP -- AND
ROLL THAT'S RIGHT.
I MAKE SURE I GOT IT STOP DROP
AND ROLL -- I I I I THINK
THERE'S A BENEFIT THOUGH FOR US
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR YOU
KNOW DEPARTMENT OF ADS.
ONCE YOU BUILD THAT INTO THE
YOUTH AND IT STARTS TO COME
FORWARD AND IF IT GETS
REINFORCED OVER AND ALL AND THEN
IT'S PRACTICED.
AS THEY GET OLDER -- IN
BUSINESSES EXCEPT -- FOR AND I
THOUGHT I WOULD JUST SAY THAT WE
PROBABLY HAD THE BEST COMPLIANCE
FOR THIS IN THE AREA OF
EARTHQUAKE AS WELL SO WE HAVE
THAT.
THE THE THE THE SHAKE OUT EVERY
YEAR -- WE'VE GOT MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE PARTICIPATE IN THAT --
SCHOOLS BUSINESSES EXCEPT.
FOR AND AND IN YOU A STRESS
AGENTS IN YOUR COMMUNITY REALLY
ARE GREAT REPRESENTATION TO GET
COMMUNITIES TO FOCUS IN ON
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS.
OF FUNDING MICE YOU KNOW IT HAS
BEEN HIT AND MESSES UP AND DOWN
DEPENDS ON WHERE WE CAN GET THE
FUNDING -- TO BE ABLE TO DO IT --
IT IS I WOULD JUST SAY NOT
CONSISTENT ACROSS THE BOARD BUT
YOU KNOW BETWEEN OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS IN WHAT WE GET FROM FOR
STATE TAB PROGRAMS AND WHAT
LOCALS THEMSELVES PUT INTO IT --
YOU KNOW WE TRY TO GET THE JOB
DONE.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT -- WHAT WORKS IN
ONE COUNTRY WOULD HAVE TO BE
ALTERED? FOR THE CULTURE OF OUR
STATE -- AND WE DO OFFER
TRAINING IN THERE OR SOMETHING
SO PEOPLE KNOW -- BUT I HAVING
BEEN THROUGH SOME EARTHQUAKES
AND OTHER DISASTERS MYSELF -- A
LOT OF PEOPLE KIND OF KNOWING
HOW TO DO SOME THINGS BUT THEN
FEELING COMPLETELY ON THEIR OWN
AND NOT HAVING ANY ORGANIZED
STRUCTURE -- AFTER EMERGENCY
HITS AND SORT OF WAITING FOR
PEOPLE TO RESCUE THEM -- I THINK
WE NEED TO I PERSONALLY THINK WE
HAVE TO RETHINK THAT STRATEGY --
YOU KNOW I REMEMBERED IN THE IN
THE NORTHRIDGE QUAKE AND I HAD
JUST MOVED OUT.
RECENTLY WITH WATCHING PEOPLE
DRIVE.
LIKE MANIACS UP AND DOWN DEAD
END STREETS TRYING TO FIND A WAY
OUT OF LOS ANGELES AND PEOPLE
AND FEELING MYSELF COMPLETELY
ISOLATED.
AND ALONE AND HAVING NO IDEA.
WHAT TO DO IF YOU KNOW SORT OF
THINGS HAD GONE ON LONGER IN
TERMS OF POWER BEING OUT THAT
KIND OF THING SO?
I THINK THAT THERE'S A ROLE FOR
NO MORE ORGANIZATION OF
COMMUNITIES -- ON THE GROUND I
DON'T KNOW HOW WE DO THAT OR
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE BUT I THINK
pBUILDING OFF OF I'M NOT TO
SWITCH TO HOUSING I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE THIS TENSION
NOW BETWEEN OUR DESIRE TO BUILD
THE HOUSING THAT WE NEED.
AND FIGURING OUT WHERE TO BUILD
IT AND YOU EVERYBODY LOVES TO
TALK ABOUT DOING MORE BUILDING
BUT WHEN IT WHEN IT COMES TO
INDIVIDUAL CITIES ENTITLING
PROJECTS IN OUR URBAN AREAS WE
SEE AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
RESISTANCE FROM PEOPLE.
I JUST TODAY IN THE LA TIMES
THERE WAS PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
HOW SOME OF WHAT SOMEHOW
BUILDING TALLER BUILDINGS IT'S
GOING TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
SKATEBOARDING ON SIDEWALKS AND
PLAYING BALL IN THE STREET AND
JUST YOU YOU HEARD HEARING CRAZY
ARGUMENTS AGAINST BUILDING
HOUSING SO PEOPLE ARE BEING
FORCED.
FURTHER AND FURTHER OUT.
BUT HOW DO WE YOU KNOW DON'T WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO TO JUST
SORT OF STOP BUILDING IF IT'S
GOING TO BE IN AREAS THAT ARE
NOT DEFENSIBLE I MEAN IS A COME
IS IT JUST THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE.
WHATEVER BUILDINGS
MUNICIPALITIES WANT TO DO -- AS
DEFENSIBLE AS POSSIBLE OR IS
THERE A POINT AT WHICH WE SAY
YOU KNOW WHAT THESE AREAS ARE
JUST GOING TO BE OFF LIMITS TO
DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE IT'S JUST
GOING TO BE TOO DANGEROUS DO YOU
HAVE ANY.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THAT.
THANK -- NO I THINK IT'S IT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT POINT IN AND
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WITH THIS
ISSUE OF COURSE IS THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE ALREADY LIVE IN THESE
AREAS I THINK -- AND AND I YOU
ALL CAN CORRECT ME IF THIS IS
WRONG BUT I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT
THE VERY HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS
IT'S ABOUT TWO POINT. FOUR OR
SOMETHING MILLION PEOPLE AND IF
YOU LOOK AT JUST THE WE WE
GENERALLY IT'S LIKE ELEVEN
MILLION PEOPLE SO IT'S A VERY
LARGE POPULATION OF OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S ALREADY IN
THESE AREAS.
SO WE'RE NOT OBVIOUSLY IN A
POSITION I KNOW ONE WOULD SAY
THAT WERE IN A POSITION TO SAY.
YOU KNOW WE SHOULD BE RETREATING
IN SOMEWHERE RIGHT -- THE
QUESTION BECOMES.
HOW MUCH OF THAT IS DEFENSIBLE
AND DEFENSIBLE WITH THE RIGHT
KINDS OF STRATEGIES THAT YOU ALL
HAVE TALKED ABOUT AND AND WITH I
THINK MUCH STRONGER?
YOU KNOW FRANKLY MUCH STRONGER
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNER
RESPONSIBILITY FOR TAKING ON
SOME OF THE DEFENSE OF SPACE
WITH HELP SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCES SPACE WHICH IS ALSO.
IN OUR OPEN SPACE AREAS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE BUILT IN SO IT'S NOT
YES SO THIS IS NOT YOUR LOOK OUT
AND FILL IN ALREADY DEVELOPED
AREAS RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT AND SO
GOING TO THE OTHER PART IS SORT
OF LIKE WHAT WE DO WITH PLACES
THAT HAVE NOT.
YET BEEN DEVELOPED SLASH --
PLACES THAT ARE -- OR ARE REALLY
REALLY HIGH RISK AND I THINK
IT'S A REALLY.
GOOD QUESTION I MEAN AGAIN THE
THE THE GOVERNOR STRIPPERS
REPORT I THINK WENT.
FURTHER THAN MANY THINGS HAVE
GONE IN THE PAST BY EVEN SAYING
WE SHOULD DISCOURAGE DEVELOPMENT.
IN SOME OF THESE HIGH RISK AREAS --
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE TO
DISCOURAGE I THINK PART OF WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE IS INCREASE IS
ENCOURAGING IT ELSEWHERE?
SO ONE THING WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT
AT OPR IS BARRIERS TO DEVELOPING
THE KIND OF INFILL HOUSING THAT
WE ALL TALK ABOUT ALL THE TIME
AND I THINK THIS STATE I THINK
WE ALL KNOW THE STATE IS IN A
POSITION TO LOOK AT LOWERING
SOME OF THOSE BARRIERS.
ON TO THAT KIND OF DEVELOPMENT
SO THAT YOU'RE NOT PUTTING
DEVELOPERS IN A POSITION WHERE
IT'S JUST CHEAPER AND EASIER.
FRANKLY TO BE IN A GREEN FIELD --
OPEN SPACE AREA ONE OTHER THING
THAT THAT FEEDS IN AND I DIDN'T
SAID EARLIER BUT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT POINT TO FEES IN THIS
CONVERSATION WE KNOW FROM SOME
OF THE FIRES THAT IT JUST
HAPPENED THAT ACTUALLY
AGRICULTURE LAND.
WAS A BUFFER -- THAT STOP FIRE
FROM SPREADING IN SOME PARTS OF
THE STATE AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION IS HOW
DO WE PROTECT.
AGRICULTURE LAND THAT'S A BUFFER
IN THESE HIGH RISK SITUATIONS AS
WELL AS BEING PART OF THAT THE
ECONOMY SO I THINK.
IT'S SORT OF WHAT THIS DOES IS
OPEN THE DOOR TO KIND OF JUST
TAKING A LITTLE BIT OF A STEP
BACK AND HAVING THIS LARGER
CONVERSATION ABOUT [inaudible]
WHERE IS?
WHERE IS DEVELOPMENT MAKE THE
MOST SENSE -- AND WHERE DO WE AS
A STATE WANT TO THINK ABOUT
WHERE ARE RISKS AND LIABILITIES
ARE AS WELL AS RECENT
LIABILITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS I
DON'T HAVE THE PERFECT ANSWER ON
THAT BUT IT'S DEFINITELY NOT
IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTION.
AND I JUST HAVE TWO MORE
QUESTIONS IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME
JUST TWO MORE QUICK ONES THANK
YOU -- BUT SO WE DON'T PROHIBIT
DEVELOPMENT IN THESE AREAS WE
SORT OF WE DO LEAVE IT UP TO
DISABILITIES AND COMING FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT I'VE NEVER SEEN
A PROJECT IS APPROVED FROM
BECAUSE OF FIRE RESCUE NO NO
MATTER HOW REMOTE.
IT SEEMED -- EVEN VERY LARGE
DEVELOPMENTS WE DECIDED TO
TWENTY THOUSAND UNIT DEVELOPMENT
APPROVED AND MARK YOU KNOW
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES -- AND WE
DO RECOVER.
BETTER BUILDING REQUIREMENTS NOW
WE HAVE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS WE HAVE A LOT OF OF
THE STANDARDS BUT WHAT IS THE
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM I MEAN WHO ACTUALLY
GOES OUT AND DECIDES WHETHER AND
NEW DEVELOPMENT.
IS UP TO THOSE STANDARDS AND IF
THEY'RE NOT WHAT HAPPENS AND WHO
WOULD ENFORCE THAT. FOR FIRED
FOR ALL OF OUR FIRE WITH FIRE.
WELL. FOR CAL FIRE ALL WE DO IS
IS WE PRIDE PROVIDE INFORMATION
CONSOLE -- WE DON'T WE DON'T
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION WE DON'T
DECIDE FOR THEM -- YOU KNOW WE
CAN PROVIDE THEM WITH A FIRE
HISTORY.
WE CAN PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
FIRE WEATHER -- WE CAN PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE ELEMENTS THAT THAT
LEAD TO THE TO THE HAZARD.
AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
MITIGATING RISK BUT THE DECISION
TO BUILD IS A IS A LOCAL
DECISION.
IT JUST ADDED THAT I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
IN AND THERE IS OBVIOUSLY A VERY
STRONG INTEREST IN CONTINUING
WITH LOCAL KIND OF VERY LOCALLY
SPECIFIC.
APPROACHES TO LONG RANGE
PLANNING THAT ARE THAT ARE.
RELEVANT TO LOCAL AREAS.
I WILL SAY THAT PLACES THAT HAVE
BEEN THROUGH THIS IT'S
INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
IN A ROSE IS A REALLY
INTERESTING EXAMPLE ALSO CENTER
IS OBVIOUSLY.
WENT THROUGH A VERY.
STRESSFUL AND TRAGIC FIRE
SITUATION IN A WHAT THEY WOULD
NOT HAVE THOUGHT OF AS A FIRE
AREA RIGHT I MEAN THOSE THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS WERE NOT FORESTED.
COMMUNITY -- BUT WHAT SANTA ROSA
HAS DONE AND I THINK IT'S
INSTRUCTIVE JUST FROM A LOCAL
LEVEL WHAT THEY'VE DONE IN TERMS
OF REBUILDING.
THEY FIRST OF ALL -- HAVE REALLY
REDUCE BARRIERS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST BARRIERS THAT WE SEE IN
A LOT OF STUDIES HAVE BEEN DONE
ON THIS.
LOCAL LOCAL ZONING AND PLANNING
IS PROBABLY THE LARGEST BARRIER
TO HOUSING DEVELOPMENT A LOT OF
PEOPLE LIKE TO SAY IT SEEK WELL
BUT MOST OF THE MOST THE THE DAY
EVIDENCE IS NOT BEAR THAT OUT
ITS LOCAL ZONING PLANNING.
CENTER IS A REDUCED THEIR PERMIT.
DAYS FROM BIG FINALLY PERMIT TO
A PERMIT -- APPLICATION TO FIVE
DAYS.
BUT MY QUESTION WAS NOT ABOUT.
ROSS IS MY QUESTION WAS IF A
LOCAL COMMUNITY IS RIGHT IT IS
NOT FIRE FOLLOWING THE FIRE
REGULATIONS THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE.
WHO ENFORCES WHO MODULE?
OVER WHO WHO'S OVER WHO IS
OVERSIGHT OF THAT AND WHO IN
FORCES -- WHEN IT COMES TO FIRE
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS AND WHAT IS
THE MECHANISM?
THE GOVERNING BODY WOULD BE THE
ENTITY THAT ENFORCES. TO ENSURE
THAT THE FIRE AGENCIES ENFORCING
AND IF A COMMUNITY IS NOT HAVING
THAT OVERSIGHT.
I'M SELF IF FOR WHATEVER REASON
THEY'RE NOT DOING IT DON'T HAVE
THE FUNDING TO DO IT DON'T HAVE
THE WHERE WITH ALL WE JUST
CHOOSE NOT TO IS THERE ANY OTHER
OVERSIGHT THAT CAN COME IN.
AND SAY YOU ARE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH EITHER BUILDING
A A IN FORCING BUILDING CODES OR
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENTS.
NOT FROM STATE OKAY.
GREAT LAST QUESTION I'M SB ONE
EIGHTY TWO DIED ON SENATOR
JACKSON REQUIRES THAT ALL --
PARCELS WITHIN A DEVELOPMENT ARE
SUBJECT TO AN ONGOING AND
PERMITTED FEE TAX OR ASSESSMENT.
OR SOME SOMETHING SIMILAR TO
ENSURE THAT DEFENSIBLE SPACE
MAINTENANCE A CURSE AND IS
FUNDED -- SHOULD DEFENSIBLE
SPACE COMPLIANCE -- SHOULD
COMMUNITY REQUIRED TO ENSURE
THAT THAT WORK HAPPENS UP FRONT.
DO YOU THINK.
OR IS IT OKAY FOR TO JUST KIND
OF GO ON FOR YOU KNOW -- INDEX
BE PUSHED OFF SORT OF INTO THE
FUTURE.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE FUNDING
MECHANISM TO THINK THAT THAT
SHOULD BE.
PAID UP FRONT CORD IS OVER THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE OF A COMMUNITY
OR DEFENSE YEAH FUNDING RECORD
FOR THAT -- RELATED TO
DEVELOPMENT SPECIFICALLY -- THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT THAT -- AGAIN
IS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL -- AND WE
DON'T HAVE -- A ROLE IN
DIFFERENT AND DEFINING THAT OR
HOW THAT WOULD BE -- IMPLEMENTED
AHEAD OF DURING AFTER -- AND
WHEN WE GET -- TO DEVELOPMENT IN
THE S. R. A. ONCE IT IS
DEVELOPED THEN -- DEFENSIBLE
SPACE AROUND INDIVIDUAL
STRUCTURES -- IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE OWNER OF
THAT STRUCTURE -- BUT BEYOND
THAT THERE IS THERE ISN'T A
MECHANISM AND THAT'S WHERE WHERE
THE TEETH OF OF OUR COMPLIANCE
INSPECTION PROGRAM -- COME IN
AND THEY COME INTO THE
INDIVIDUAL LANDOWNER IN THAT
STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA -- AND
THERE ARE AREAS AS YOU'RE WELL
AWARE THAT ARE THAT ARE IN LIEU
LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY AREA
THEY'RE STILL IN A VERY HIGH --
FIRE SEVERITY ZONE -- AND
THEY'RE NOT PART OF OF THE
STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY AT ALL IN
THOSE CASES.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
THIS IS GOING TO BE A A HUGE
ISSUE AND WE HAVE MILLIONS OF
STRUCTURES AND A HAVE TO BE
RETROFITTED AND MILLIONS OF
LANDSCAPES.
THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
LOOKED AT AND I THINK WE YOU
HAVE A BODY OF REPRESENTATIVES
IN SACRAMENTO THAT ARE YOU KNOW
VERY ANXIOUS TO WORK WITH YOU
AND ALL THE SOLUTION SO THANKS
AGAIN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OUT FOR
SO LET ME ALSO REITERATE MY
THANKS TO YOU IN YOUR EXPERTISE
AND WOULD LOVE SOME IF IT'S
POSSIBLE TO PROVIDE US WITH THE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY SO WE CAN --
ABSORB AGAIN ALL THE ACRONYMS
AND AND AND FAX YOU PROVIDED TO
US SO AS SOON AS WE THINK ABOUT
THIS FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
AND HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH
COLLEAGUES I WANNA TRY TO BREAK
IT DOWN.
MORE SIMPLY IF WHAT.
I'LL JUST THROW OUT TO
PRINCIPLES OF I THINK WHAT WE
SHOULD DO WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
IT SEEMS THAT WE SHOULD BE -- WE
SHOULD BE BUILDING IN CERTAIN
AREAS I THINK WE ALL.
COULD AGREE WITH THAT AND WE
SHOULD BE BUILDING MORE QUICKLY
IN AREAS THAT WE CAN AGREE WE
SHOULD BE BUILDING.
BUT THE CHALLENGES AS MISS
FREEMAN I THINK.
PUT A GOOD POINT TO WE HAVEN'T
REALLY BEEN DOING EITHER I LIKE
TO JUST EXPLORE BOTH FOR A
MOMENT -- I'VE HEARD I THINK MS
GORDON TALK ABOUT THE NEED TO DE
PRIORITIZE DEVELOPMENTS IN HIGH
RISK AREAS I HEARD THE TWO
CHIEFS TALK ABOUT -- HAZARD
SCORES AND THE AN ANALYSIS THAT
YOU'VE DONE ON THIS BUT THE
REALLY.
ISN'T WE HAVEN'T MADE A DECISION
AS A STATE THAT THERE ARE PARTS
OF THE STATE THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER NOT.
DEVELOPING -- AND IT THIS IS A
VERY DIFFICULT CONVERSATION FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES -- BUT I THINK
IT MIGHT BE A ROLE FOR STATE
GOVERNMENT TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION AND I DO THINK.
I'M GONNA PUT THIS DIFFICULT
TOPIC OUT THERE BECAUSE I'D.
I'D I'D LIKE YOUR FEEDBACK ON ON
HOW WE WE DO THIS -- THERE'S NOT
A SINGLE LEGISLATOR WHO WILL NOT
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF LOCAL
CONTROL -- BUT WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE THERE HAVE TO BE SOME
NATURAL IMITATIONS TO LOCAL
CONTROL AND INTERESTINGLY.
WE ALL BELIEVE IN LOCAL CONTROL
WHEN IT COMES TO LAND USE
DEVELOPMENT AND HOUSING -- BUT
WE HAVE STATEWIDE RULES AROUND
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE CALIFORNIA --
CRIMINAL LAW WE HAVE STATE WHAT
RULES AROUND PUBLIC HEALTH
AROUND PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR POPULATION.
AND THE TOPIC WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY INTERSECTS THOSE TWO
THINGS AND SO.
AGAIN I I GUESS I WOULD POSE THE
QUESTION A LITTLE MORE INTENSELY
THAN MS FREEMAN TO YOU.
DO YOU THINK THERE ARE.
PARTS OF THE STATE OR
COMMUNITIES WHICH HAVE BEEN
RAVAGED BY WILDFIRES.
THAT WE REALLY SHOULDN'T
DEVELOPMENT AND IF THAT'S THE
CASE IN AT THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT UNDERSTANDABLY
WANT TO REBUILD WHERE THEY LIVED
BEFORE WHAT IS THE ROLE OF THE
STATE AND SAME WITH WE WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENTLY.
I KNOW IT'S A HARD QUESTION BUT
THIS THIS IS THE QUESTION THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO GRAPPLE WITH
HERE.
GO AHEAD I MEAN.
YEAH I I THINK YOU'RE KIND OF
TOUCHING ON A LOT OF OUR AREAS
AYE YOU KNOW IT IT IS -- LOOK.
WE COULD BE HAVING THIS SAME
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
THE EAST BAY.
HEY WOULD FALL RUNS RIGHT DOWN
THE MIDDLE OF THE EAST BAY.
EVERY MAJOR HOSPITAL EVERY MAN
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA ACCEPT
ALL THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LIVE ON
THE EARTHQUAKE FAULT.
THAT'S A BAD THING IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IT'S A GOOD COULD PRODUCE
OF A SEVEN POINT EIGHT
EARTHQUAKE YET WE BUILD AND LIVE.
ON THIS FALL.
OKAY THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
MANY IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO.
KNOWING THAT WE'VE GOT SOME
LIMITATIONS BECAUSE OF RISK OF
SO MANY DIFFERENT KINDS OF RISK
THE NEXT STEP IS.
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU BUILD YOU
BUILD? TO MAKE MORE RESILIENCY
YOU INCREASED.
BUILDING CODES.
YOU YOU YOU MAKE MORE RESILIENT
STRUCTURES IN THE CASE OF
EARTHQUAKE THAT'S RETROFITTING
ITS BUILDING TO HIRE BUILDING
CODES.
IN THE CASE A WHILE I FIRE TO
CHIEF REPRISE POINT IT'S IT'S
IT'S LOOKING OUT OUR EXISTING
CODES.
AND INCREASING THE COACH TO TRY
TO MAKE.
HOMES THAT ARE GOING TO BE BUILT
IN THE WE WE MORE RESILIENT BUT
IT'S ALSO LOOKING AT THE FIRE
CORRIDOR AREA AND DETERMINE YOU
MAYBE NOT EVERY PART OF THAT
COMMUNITY.
IS BUILDABLE MAYBE SOME OF IT
HAS TO HAVE GREEN SPACE IN IT TO
BUILD THESE FIRE BUFFERS THE QUE
TALKED ABOUT.
SO SO SO THAT SO THAT THERE'S
THE ABILITY -- TO SLOWER
DEFERRED FIRE SHOULD HAPPEN
RIGHT THAT HAS TO BE BUILT INTO
ALSO.
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT A
DEFENSIBLE SPACE PLANNING.
SO IT'S SORT OF LIKE THE CHIEF'S
QUARTERS.
POINT NOT A SILVER BULLET IT'S A
COMPENDIUM OF OF EFFORTS -- BUT
WE NEED TO GET OVER THAT HURDLE
FIRST.
BIT THAT SAYS.
BOOK.
I JUST THINK THE TAX BASE AND I
NEED TO BUILD.
AND YOUR REGARDLESS OF THOSE
RISKS.
WAR.
WE'RE GONNA PROVE DEVELOPMENT
AND WE'LL WORRY ABOUT THE RISK
LATER.
OR TEN INSURANCE PROBLEM OR THE
FEDERAL OR STATE GOVERNMENT WILL
COME IN THE DISASTER RECOVERY.
WHAT I THINK WE NEED TO DO IS
TAKE THE WHOLE ISSUE OF SAFETY
AND SECURITY AND PUT IT ON THE
FRONT END OF OUR?
GENERAL PLANNING FOR COMMUNITY
AND BASED UPON THAT ASSESSMENT
THEN BUILD YOUR MOVE FORWARD
WITH YOUR WITH YOUR BILL THAT
MATCHES MY POINT CAN'T BE THAT.
HARD.
YEAH A AGAIN TOM BORDER -- CAL
FIRE I I I I I AGREE WITH --
DIRECTOR GIL DO CHEESE --
COMMENTS A IT REALLY IS --
CALIFORNIA AS WE'VE BEEN TALKING --
ALL AFTERNOON IS A DISASTER
PRONE -- LANDSCAPE IN THERE ARE
VERY FEW AREAS OF THE STATE THAT
YOU COULD SAY ARE TRULY NOT.
IN PERIL BY SOME NATURAL OR
HUMAN CAUSED DISASTERS.
AND SO -- WELL THAT -- KIND OF
FIT IS A BIT OF A DEFEATIST --
STATEMENT -- WE DO NEED TO DO
WHAT WE CAN TO BUY DOWN THE RISK
AND SO -- WELL WE DO HAVE TWO
MILLION PLUS -- HOMES IN VERY
HIGH FIRE SEVERITY ZONE MAP
AREAS ALREADY -- AND THERE ARE
LOCAL A LAND USE PLANS THAT HAVE
PLANS TO DEVELOP MORE IN THOSE
SAME AREAS -- PART OF THE
EQUATION HERE IS REALLY THAT.
ALL OF THE ABOVE APPROACH AND
BUYING DOWN THE RISK BY DOING
FUELS MANAGEMENT THAT IS.
DISTANT TWO ADJACENT TO AND
WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES AS WELL
AS HARDENING THE STRUCTURES OR
ENSURING THAT FUTURE STRUCTURES
ARE HARDENED TO THE POINT WHERE.
THEY CAN -- THE COMMUNITY CAN BE
RESILIENT THROUGH THE NEXT FIRE
THAT COMES WHEN TALKING ABOUT
FIRES OF COURSE WE HAVE --
MULTIPLE TYPES OF OF RISKS THAT
ARE KIND OF OVERLAPPING WHETHER
IT'S EARTHQUAKE AND FIRE
EARTHQUAKE FIRE FLOOD -- SETO
WAS A WAS A COMMUNITY THAT WAS
REALLY HIT HARD BY FLOODS THAT.
THAT WE PROBABLY COULD HAVE SEEN
COMING BUT THEY ALSO WERE MUCH
MORE EXTREME THAN WE EXPECTED
EVER TO SEE.
SO IT ALL OF THESE THINGS I I
BELIEVE -- MEMBER CHIU THIS IS
THIS IS AYE AYE AYE UP APPLAUD
THIS DIFFICULT DECISION A
DECISION COVER CONVERSATION THAT
WE'RE HAVING BUT IT REALLY IS.
THERE THERE'S WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
IT FROM A VERY HOLISTIC APPROACH.
JUST BRIEFLY TO ADD TO BOTH MY
COLLEAGUES VERY GOOD COMMENTS ON
THIS I I WOULD SAY THAT -- ONE
OF THE CLASSIC TENSIONS THAT WE
HAVE WHICH YOU BOTH REFER TO IS
THIS SORT OF ECONOMIC TENSION
PEOPLE WANT TO BUILD IN ORDER TO
GET THEY THEY THE TAX BASE.
BOB AND IT'S HARD TO LOOK OUT
FOR IF YOU'RE AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL ESPECIALLY WHO IS ON A
SHORTER TIME HORIZON. ONE THING
THAT I DO THINK THOUGH IS REALLY
BECOMING MORE CLEAR AND
UNFORTUNATELY THIS PAST FEW
MONTHS HAVE MADE IT MORE CLEAR.
IS THAT CLIMATE IMPACTS ARE NOT
A FAR OFF THING ANYMORE THE AND
THAT NOT ONLY THAT.
BUT THEY ARE HAVING A DIRECT
IMPACT ON THE ECONOMICS OF THESE
DECISIONS SO THE FACT THAT OUR
MAJOR UTILITIES WERE DOWNGRADED.
RATINGS WERE DOWNGRADED IN PART
BECAUSE OF AN ABILITY TO REACT
TO SOME OF THE INCREASED FIRE
RISK IN STATE.
IS AN IMPORTANT TOUCHSTONE
BECAUSE IT IT IT IT IS AN
EXAMPLE IS NOT THE ONLY ONE OF
RAIDER BOND RATERS INSURERS
ISSUERS STARTING TO ACTUALLY
INCORPORATE SOME OF THESE RISKS
INTO THEIR DECISION MAKING IN
AND FINANCES.
WE ARE A FEW YEARS AGO STATE
FARM ACTUALLY SUED THE CITY OF
CHICAGO FOR NOT BEING
APPROPRIATELY RESPONSIVE TO
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND IT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING.
MANY PEOPLE EXPECT MORE OF THOSE
TYPES OF LAWSUITS GOING FORWARD
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS THAT
AND I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT.
CLIMATE RISKS ARE DIFFERENT THAN
EARTHQUAKES IN THAT THEY ARE
MUCH MORE PREDICTABLE.
SO THE THE WORLD OF INVESTORS
LONG TERM INVESTORS IS ACTUALLY
STARTING TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THAT PREDICT RISK.
I THINK WE WILL SEE MORE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS FROM THOSE
PREDICTIONS IN THESE PROJECTS
THAT'S NOT AN ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION OF WHAT THE STATE
SHOULD BE DOING.
BUT IT IS AN IMPORTANT POINT
ABOUT I THINK WHERE SOME OF
THESE DECISIONS ARE GONNA START
BEING MADE POTENTIALLY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WE DO FEEL LIKE OUR
ROLE AT THE STATE IS TO MAKE
THOSE DATA AS AVAILABLE AS
POSSIBLE.
SO THAT WHEN COMMUNITIES ARE
LOOKING AT THE PREDICTIVE REST
WE CAN GIVE THEM AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE TO BE
ABLE TO SAY.
THIS IS WHERE WE SEE A HUNDRED
YEAR FLOOD BECOMING A TEN YEAR
FLOOD THIS IS WHERE WE SEE
SEVERITY AND AND AND FREQUENCY
INCREASING.
AT SORT OF STAGGERING RATES THIS
IS WHERE WE SEE THE IMPACTS
HITTING SOONER AND THEN LATER WE
DO HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY WE
THINK TO PROVIDE THAT.
BECAUSE THAT FEEDS INTO THESE
DECISIONS.
APPRECIATE THAT.
I HAD A NUMBER OF OTHER
QUESTIONS BUT IN RESPECT TO
OTHER COLLEAGUES LET ME JUST
MAKE TWO COMMENTS SO ON THE ONE
HAND -- IT IT'S MY PERSPECTIVE
WE'VE GOT TO THINK ABOUT WHERE
WE DON'T BUILD BUT ON THE FLIP
SIDE.
OF WE ARE CLEARLY NOT DOING A
GOOD JOB OF BUILDING WHERE THERE
IS LESS RISK -- TO CHECK POOREST
POINT ASSUMING EVERY AREA HAS
SOME REST I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE THERE ARE PARTS OF THE
STATE MANY PARTS OF THE STATE
THAT ARE LESS RISKY FOR US TO DO
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT AS I'M.
LISTENING TO THE TESTIMONIES YOU
LATER ON ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
ANALYSES AND HAZARD MITIGATION
FEES AND SEQUEL AND AND IT ADDS
TIME.
AND AND MONEY TO ACTUALLY
BUILDING HOUSING SO SO I THINK
THE IRONY HERE IS -- THERE'S A
NATURAL DESIRES FOR COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAVAGED AND
DESTROYED TO REBUILD THEMSELVES
AND THEIR ISSUES WITH THAT.
AND THEN BECAUSE OF THE CLIMATE
CHANGE IN THE CHALLENGES WERE
LAYERING ON AND ACTUALLY
POTENTIALLY MAKING IT SLOWER TO
BUILD WHERE WE SHOULD.
AND THAT'S JUST A COMMENT AND
AND I WOULD SAY COLLEAGUES I
HOPE WE CAN ENGAGE IN THIS AND
THINK OF WHAT CAN WE DO TO SPEED
UP PRODUCTION WE ARE IT IS LESS
RISK IN THE LAST THING I WANT TO
JUST.
ASK FOR SUGGEST IS I KNOW
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HIS PROPOSED.
NEW PLENTY DOLLARS THIS YEAR UP
WHEN IT COMES TO THINK ABOUT
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT BUT IT'S
OCCURRED TO ME THAT THIS PLANE
DOLLARS ARE REALLY FOCUSED AS
MUCH AS THEY COULD BE ON
COMMUNITIES.
LIKE THE ONES WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY THAT REALLY NEED TO
DO AN AWFUL LOT OF PLANNING TO
FIGURE THIS OUT AND AND I WOULD
SUPPORT THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
CAN HELP.
THOSE COMMUNITIES DO THIS
PLANNING FASTER SO THEY CAN TAKE
THE DATA THAT YOU HAVE AND TAKE
THE BEST THINKING THAT WE GOT IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TO EITHER
REBUILD OR NOT.
AND THEN TO MAKE SURE OTHER
COMMUNITIES ARE BUILDING EVEN
FASTER TO DEAL WITH THE THE THE
THE THE THE STRIKE THAT THE
CRISIS.
AND STRESS SO.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION TO LOOK FOR TO
OTHERS -- WITH -- WITH HER
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU US A MEMORABLE FELL.
MADAM CHAIR IN MY COLLEAGUES --
I HAVE DEFINITION QUESTION AND
DIRECTION HERE POSSIBLE
DIRECTION THAT THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE MAY
POSSIBLY TAKE.
SO FOR DEFINITION -- JUST TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME
PAGE -- TAKE JUST A FEW SECONDS.
INSURANCE SERVICE.
OFFICE.
STARTED SEVENTY YEARS AGO
BASICALLY AS AN INSURANCE
PAPERWORK FACTORY OKAY.
NOW THOUGH IN CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES THE
I. S. O. INSURED SERVICE OFFICE.
DOES FIRE -- ASSESSMENT
DISTRICTS.
SO THE FIRE ASSESSMENT DISTRICT
FOR INSURANCE PREMIUM PURPOSES
GOES FROM.
AYE SO ONE THROUGH I. S. O.
[inaudible]
TEN NOW -- WITH THAT ESTABLISHED
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK CAL FIRE.
HOW MANY I SO NINE AND I. S. O.?
TEN DISTRICTS ARE THERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER I WOULD
SPECULATE THAT MANY OF THE RURAL
VOLUNTEER DEPARTMENTS.
ARE PROBABLY IN THOSE CATEGORIES
IN THE CLASS ONES ARE PROBABLY
MORE THAN LARGER METRO
DEPARTMENTS OKAY NOW THESE ARE
FRIENDLY QUESTIONS OKAY.
I'M.
I'M NOT GOING DOWN THE PLACE
YOU'RE NOT GONNA OF LIKE TO GO
TO RIGHT.
SO THE REASON I SET THAT UP FOR
I SO NINE AND I ALSO TEN IS.
I ALSO TEN AND NINE IS VERY HIGH
INSURANCE PREMIUMS AND MANY
TIMES THE HOMEOWNERS IN THOSE
AREAS THAT WE REALLY DON'T WANT
THEM TO BUILD AND BUT THERE
THERE.
OKAY MANY TIMES THEY DO NOT BUY
INSURANCE BECAUSE EITHER IT'S
NOT OFFERED ON THE COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE MARKETS. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE FAIR PLAN.
WHICH MEANS IF YOU CAN'T GET
INSURANCE YOU BUY IT FROM THE
FAIR PLAN.
WELL THE FAIR PLAN HOUSE DID NOT
GO BROKE SO THOSE PREMIUMS ARE
VERY HIGH.
NOW.
WHERE THAT BREEZES IS?
YOU ALL HAVE A DATABASE.
YOU KNOW THAT IN CERTAIN AYE SO
AREAS OF DEVASTATING FIRES GOING
TO BLOW THROUGH THERE EVERY
TWENTY TWO YEARS I'M JUST MAKING
THAT UP FOR ILLUSTRATION.
BUT YOU KNOW I SO KNOWS SO THIS
COMMITTEE NEEDS TO GET.
THE I SO.
IS FOR NINE AND TEN WE NEED TO
GET THE DATABASE FOR YOU ALL.
COMPARE OKAY HERE'S WHERE I'M
GOING WITH THIS AND YOU'LL LIKE
WHERE I'M GOING TO WRITE
[inaudible]
SO.
ACCORDING -- TO ONE OF MY BILLS
YOU CANNOT PRECLUDE AND CAN
COOLEY WILL.
EITHER CONFIRM IZZARD DENY IT
BECAUSE HE IS OF SMART ATTORNEY.
YOU CANNOT PRECLUDE ANYONE FROM
SUING.
SO ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE
THAT'S MACRO IN CALIFORNIA IS.
THESE FIRES BLOW THROUGH AND NOW
EVERYONE SUES PGN THE S. D. G.
IN THE EDISON WHATEVER. FOR A
GAZILLION DOLLARS AND I JUST
MADE THAT NUMBER UP -- WHICH
MEANS THAT BY DEFAULT THE
ELECTRIC COMPANIES OR WHOEVER
ELSE CAN BE A DEEP POCKET IS THE
INSURER FOR PEOPLE THAT REFUSE
TO GET THE INSURANCE.
SO. ONE OF MY POSSIBLE
DIRECTIONS TO GO IN.
IS.
YOU CANNOT PRECLUDE ANYONE FROM
SUING.
BUT I BELIEVE THERE IS PRESIDENT
SO WE NEED TO RESEARCH THIS IS A
COMMITTEE. TO LIMIT HOW MUCH YOU
CONSUME FAR IN I SO NINE AND ISO.
TEN THAT COULD BE A POSSIBLE WAY
OF GOING -- BUT WE NEED TO KNOW
WHERE THOSE DISTRICTS ARE.
AND THE I SO PEOPLE WON'T.
RELEASE IT LETS YOU PAY MONEY OR
YOU'RE A GOVERNMENT BODY.
NOW I DID NOT TRY TO GET THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE I WANTED TO
DEFER. TO THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
SO THAT IS A POSSIBLE WAY OF
GOING. TO MITIGATE.
YOUR PROBLEMS AND THE MACRO
PROBLEMS ESPECIALLY.
FOR THE ELECTRIC COMPANIES.
NOW.
IF.
YOU ONLY HAVE SO MUCH MONEY
YOU'LL GET PAID FOR A LAWSUIT
pWHEN YOU BUILD YOUR GIANT CABIN
UP IN THE MOUNTAINS.
AND MAYBE GROW SOME TO YOU KNOW
I DON'T KNOW -- YOU'LL THINK
TWICE ABOUT BUILDING THE OR
DOING WHATEVER YOU'RE DOING UP
IN THE MOUNTAINS ESPECIALLY.
IF WE ALSO WITHIN A POSSIBLE
BILL IN THE FUTURE PUT IN THAT
YOU HAVE THAT WHOEVER IS SELLING
THAT PROPERTY HAS TO DO A FULL
DISCLOSURE.
ON THE FIRE RISK IN HOW MANY HOW
OFTEN THE FIRE BLOWS THROUGH
THERE.
SO YOU CAN DO SOME INTERESTING
NEAT THINGS FROM AN INSURANCE
VIEWPOINT.
AND THAT'S MY COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONLY
KNOWN.
THANK YOU I THINK YOU OFFER YOUR
PRESENTATION AND I AM WANT TO
KIND OF FOLLOW UP AND TRY TO DIG
JUST A LITTLE BIT DEEPER AND
WHAT SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES UPSET --
YOU MENTION MONEY CO I REPRESENT
WANT TO CO AND CERTAINLY AND
THAT'S BEEN HARD AND A LOT OF
EXAMPLES HAVE BEEN GIVEN OF
THINGS I THINK THAT BEEN TURNED
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY HAVE
EXPERIENCE INCLUDING THE AD
BUFFER -- FOR THE CITY OF SANTA
PAULA AND YOU KNOW THINKING
ABOUT WANT TO SEE YOU AS AN
EXAMPLE AS IT RELATES TO
BUILDING HOUSING WE KNOW SYMBOL
I KNOW SO MUCH MORE ABOUT A
ALLUVIAL FANS NOW.
THAN I DID BEFORE BUT I ALSO
WITHIN READ THAT OTHER
COMMUNITIES ARE BUILDING.
ON THE SAME ALLUVIAL FANS THAT
BECAUSE THE PROBLEMS THAT THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO SEE.
AND SO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE.
IN ANY THINK MY COLLEAGUES WRITE
WERE TRYING TO GET AT THIS TOO
BUT WHERE'S THE NEXUS BETWEEN
WHAT WE'RE HEARING TODAY AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE THOUGHTS
AND THE FEEDBACK YOU'VE SHARED
WITH US WITH HOW IT BECOMES.
REAL IN COMMUNITIES IN MODESTY
DO THERE WERE AREAS THAT THE
COUNTY BOUGHT OUT -- BECAUSE
THERE WERE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
REBUILD BUT I MEAN I READ IN
PAPERS OF OTHER COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE THAT ARE THINKING
ABOUT BUILDING MAJOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE SAME AREA.
WE HAVE -- IN NEED -- ADDED
DESIRE TO BUILD MORE HOUSING IN
THIS STATE BUT I MEAN WHERE IS
THE NEXUS BETWEEN WHAT WE'RE
HEARING TODAY AND WHAT IS REALLY
HAPPENING IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES
RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF HOUSING --
I THINK IT'S PLAYED ITSELF OUT
IN A VERY COMPARABLE COMPLICATED
WAY IN THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT -- AND I KNOW WE WILL
HAVE ANOTHER NATURAL DISASTER --
INVENTOR IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
WE'VE HAD -- REGRETTABLY MANY
BUT I MEAN WE ARE GRAPPLING WITH
THIS HOUSING SITUATION AWAY WE
HADN'T -- IN ADDITION TO WE HAVE
THE HIGH FIRE AREAS -- AND THEN
WE HAVE A ONE A ONE AND THAT
BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE -- IS
ERODING SO I'M THINKING
EVACUATION PLANS I MEAN THIS IS
I'M LIKE HOW. ONE NIGHT I HAD A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT EVACUATED SO I'M
THINKING HOW DOES THIS ALL COME
TO ONE TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
POLICIES WERE ALSO SEEN.
ARE REALLY -- I DON'T THINK THEY
DIG DEEP IN THIS AREA AND I AND
I FIND MYSELF STRUGGLING WHAT DO
WE REQUIRE.
CITIES COUNTIES -- TO DO THAT
CHANGES THE WAY OUR LOCAL COULD
THE TOOLS THAT OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE AND USED TO
MAKE THESE VERY VERY.
DIFFICULT DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE
HOUSING IS BUILT AND WHERE IT IS
NOT BUILT.
THAT'S A TOUGH -- ONE NO YOU'RE
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND AND
I THINK ONE OF THE CHALLENGING
THINGS ABOUT THIS ISSUE IS THAT
AND A AND THE FIRES REALLY
UNDERSCORED THAT IS THAT HE DOES
BRING ALL THESE THINGS TOGETHER
WERE USED TO BEING ABLE TO THINK
ABOUT.
OUR CLIMATE MITIGATION AND WE
HAVE SOME OF OUR CLEAN ENERGY
GOES OVER HERE AND THEN WE HAVE
SOME BRAZILIAN STUFF OVER HERE
AND THEN WE HAVE ALL THIS LIKE.
EVERY DAY FOCUS ON PLANNING RATE
AND AND ON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND ALL THIS AND ALL THOSE
THINGS ARE THE SAME THING.
AND IT -- AND AND I JUST WANT TO
GREW WITH WITH WITH WHOEVER WAS
YOU SAID -- ADDING ON MORE AND
MORE AND MORE AND MORE PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IS NOT A GREAT
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION BECAUSE
ESPECIALLY IN MANY OF THESE
PLACES WERE TALK ABOUT SMALL
COMMUNITIES WITH.
VERY FEW PLANNING RESOURCES
THAT'S ANOTHER THINGTHAT WE
HEAR EVERY SINGLE TIME WE GO TO
ANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CONVERSATION AS WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CAPACITY TO BE PLANNING --
AND SO.
YOU KNOW ONE THING THAT THAT --
YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT IT -- PR I I THINK IT'S
IT'S REFLECTED IN THE WORK SOME
BUSTED ON THE STRIKE FORCE IS
THE NEED TO START REMAIN
STREAMING THIS A LITTLE BIT TO
INCORPORATING SOME OF THESE
ISSUES WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT
ALL OF OUR AGENTS HE'S BEEN A
LOT OF TIME THINKING ABOUT.
INTO THAT MAINSTREAM THINKING
AND THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
MEAN ADDING ANOTHER LAYER TO A
GENERAL PLAN IT CAN MEAN.
YOU DON'T ACTUALLY INCORPORATING
THESE ISSUES INTO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCE INTO HOW WE
THINK ABOUT HOW BUDGETS ARE
CONSTRUCTED HOW WE THINK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT HOW WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING BOND MONEY AND IT WE DO
KNOW AND AGAIN JUST GOING BACK
TO THE MARKETS WE DO KNOW THAT
BOND.
ISSUERS AND BOND RATERS ARE
PAYING MORE AND MORE ATTENTION
TO THIS SET OF ISSUES BECAUSE
THE IT IS.
GONE FROM A LONG TERM RISK TO AN
IMMEDIATE RISK FINANCIALLY.
AND SO I THINK WILL WILL BE
FORCED I THINK THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND STATE LEVEL FRANKLY TO TO BE
INCORPORATING THAT MORE INTO
THINKING.
HOW DOES THAT ACTUALLY PLAY OUT
ON THE GROUND THAT'S THE WORRY
RIGHT IT'S LIKE THAT DOESN'T
HELP US WITH SOMETHING THAT THE
PRODUCT PROPOSED TODAY?
BUT AT LEAST WE SHOULD I THINK
ALL IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
START THINKING ABOUT.
HOW TO DO THAT HOW TO HOW TO HOW
TO MODEL THAT IS A STATE
HONESTLY AND THEN HOW TO THINK
ABOUT KIND OF INCORPORATING SOME
OF THOSE CONSIDERATIONS INTO?
INTO LOCAL PLAN IT DOES MAKE ME
NERVOUS TO THINK I WILL ADMIT TO
THINK ABOUT ADDING ANOTHER LAYER.
TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES -- BUT THIS IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT LAYER SO
MAYBE THERE'S A WAY WE CAN TRY
TO GET MORE EFFICIENCY BY BUT
ALSO BRING IN THIS.
THIS SET OF ISSUES BECAUSE
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT MEAN
ARTWORK CONSTRAINED AS A STATE
BECAUSE ALL THIS IS A LOCAL.
THIS IS ALL LOCAL CONTROL
EVERYTHING WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW -- AND WE HAVE.
VERY VERY IMPORTANT CLIMATE
GOALS AT THE STATE LEVEL WE HAVE
VERY IMPORTANT FISCAL GOALS AT
THE STATE LEVEL WE HAVE AN OVER
ARCHING GOAL THE GOVERNOR'S
NUMBER CAN CALL OF OF YOU KNOW
INCLUSION AND ADDRESSING
INEQUALITIES ARE ALL RELATED.
BUT ULTIMATELY THESE PLANNING
ISSUES YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE.
HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
AND AND SO.
I THINK AT LEAST TODAY OUR
ABILITY TO AS THE STATE TO CAN
AFFECT THAT IS FAIRLY LIMITED.
ON I THIS IS VERY COMPLEX BUT I
HAVE TO TELL YOU I I THINK IT
STARTS BACK WITH.
A CULTURE ISSUE RIGHT WE AS A
CULTURE.
NEED TO RETHINK THE WAY WE ARE
DOING THIS RIGHT.
WHEN WHEN I LOOK AT SO LIST
TRAVEL AROUND THE WORLD RIGHT
THERE ARE COUNTRIES I'VE BEEN TO
HOLLAND FOR EXAMPLE WE HAD A
MASSIVE FLOODING PROBLEM FOR THE
LONGEST TIME?
WE DID THEIR THEIR WHOLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND THE FACT
THAT THEY PUT MITIGATION EFFORTS
FIRST BEFORE THEY BUILT.
THEIR COMMUNITIES UP THEY WERE
GETTING REPETITIVE LOS
REPETITIVE LOSS RIGHT -- IT WAS
HARD BECAUSE IT MOVE BUSINESSES
THAT PRECLUDED WITH BUILDING WAS
GOING TO GO.
BUT BUT THEY DID IT AND NOW THEY
HAVE A BASICALLY ZERO AMOUNT OF
FLOODING THAT HAPPENS IN THEIR
MAJOR MAJOR CAPITAL.
I'VE BEEN TO OTHER PARTS OF THE
WORLD INDONESIA WHICH HAS
TSUNAMIS IN CHINA -- THERE ARE
PLACES WHERE WHERE THE CULTURE.
DICTATES THE FACT THAT
[inaudible]
LOOK.
MAKE ME FEEL WE'RE GOING TO DO
THAT FIRST AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO BUILD AROUND THAT IDEA.
BEFORE WE JUST GO.
BILL FIRST AND THEN BUILD IN A
SAFETY AND SECURITY OR JUST DO
THE MINIMUM.
BUILDING CODE OR TO THE MINIMUM --
THAT'S REQUIRED -- THIS IS
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST CHANGE AND
ASK HAVE BECAUSE FROM A DISASTER
STANDPOINT.
THE COST OF THESE FAR OUT TO SEA --
EXCEEDED.
AFTERWARDS IN ECONOMIC LOSSES IN
LIFE LOSSES IN PROPERTY
INFRASTRUCTURE THEN WHAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE DOING ON THE FRONT END
BEFORE YOU REPAIR.
SO EGYPT WE JUST NEED TO THINK
THROUGH IT DIFFERENTLY AND THE
MARKETS WILL PROBABLY END UP.
DRIVING IN THE LONG RUN BECAUSE
YOU KNOW YOU MAY NOT GET -- BE
ABLE TO GET LOANS OR WHATEVER TO
DO THIS BUT WE ALSO AT THE STATE
CONTROL THE PURSE TO SOME DEGREE
AND WE SHOULD BE.
DRIVING SOME REQUIREMENTS I KNOW
THIS BY.
LOCAL GOVERNING OTHER REALLY MAD
AT ME BUT YOU KNOW I THINK WE'D
HAVE THAT THE TOP DISCUSSION
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE REALLY DOING
IT.
RIGHT RIGHT NOW.
FROM WHAT I'VE BEEN ABLE TO SEE
IT IS GETTING YOU KNOW THERE'S
JUST TOO MANY REST THE REST.
AS THE INCREASE IN POPULATION.
FOR THE MOST POPULOUS STATE --
COURSE WE GET MORE PEOPLE
IMPACTED BECAUSE WE ARE THE MOST
POPULOUS STATE -- BUT IT'S NOT
JUST HERE VIEW LOOKING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY IN CLIMATE RELATED
DISASTER IMPACTS.
ARE SEVERE THERE REALLY
SIGNIFICANT AND THERE ARE
COMMUNITIES GETTING WIPED OUT
TIME AND TIME LICENSE LIVES LOST --
WHERE THEY COULD HAVE MITIGATED
SOME OF THAT IN IN IN -- NOT
BUILDING IN CERTAIN AREAS OR
DIFFERENT KINDS OF THINGS SO I
MEAN I THINK THIS IS A WHOLE
NOTHER EFFORT JUST TO SIT AND
TALK ABOUT THAT BUT IT IS A IT
IS A VERY IMPORTANT.
THING WILL WE CHANGE OUR THOUGHT
PROCESS
CAN I CHIME IN ON THAT JUST.
MAKE IT VERY QUICK.
RELATED TO WILDFIRE SPECIFICALLY --
WE DO HAVE -- A MODEL THAT WE'RE
UTILIZING THROUGH OUR LAND USE
PLANNING -- GROUP THAT THAT IS
WORKING WITH -- LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BOTH CITIES AND
COUNTIES PARTICULARLY COUNTIES --
TO WHEN THEY OPEN THEIR THEIR
SAFETY ELEMENT OF THEIR GENERAL
GENERAL PLAN INCORPORATE MANY OF
THE CONCEPTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY
PARTICULARLY WHAT.
WHAT CHIEF RICH ONE WAS TALKING
ABOUT BUT ALSO THE HOUSING
ELEMENT WE CAN ALSO GET IN THERE
AND AT THAT TIME AS WELL I THINK
THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY -- TO SPREAD THE
CULTURAL ELEMENT THAT ANYTHING
DIRECTOR GIL GIGI.
AND GORDON HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT WE REALLY NEED TO CHANGE
THE MINDSET OF THOSE THAT ARE
DOING THE PLANNING AND APPROVING
THE PLANS.
THAT ARE COMING THROUGH AND
MODELS TO LOOK AT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL -- THAT HAS BEEN VERY --
PROGRESSIVE IS IN SAN DIEGO --
THEY HAVE A VERY LONG TERM --
PLANNING PROCESS THAT HAS HAS
REALLY TIGHTENED -- AND
ENCOURAGED.
THIS INCENTIVIZE THE THE
DEVELOPMENT IN THE BACK COUNTRY
AND INCENTIVIZE THE DEVELOPMENT
IN THE CORRIDOR AREAS WHERE
THERE'S MORE INFRASTRUCTURE --
AND THERE'S ALSO AN EXAMPLE --
TO PREVIOUS POINT.
THAT OF OF DEVELOPMENT THAT HAS
BEEN HELD UP FOR YEARS BECAUSE
IT CAN'T MEET FIRE SAFETY
ELEMENT OF THAT AND IT IS IN THE
GROWTH SO SO.
WE DO HAVE THESE AREAS THAT ARE
KIND OF OUT THERE THAT THAT
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH AND AND
THERE ARE EXAMPLES OF WE CAN
LOOK AT THAT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THAT MIGHT HAVE.
KIND OF THAT -- STATE -- FLAVOR
TO THEM THAT WE'RE LOOKING.
FOR THANK YOU RAIN RUN WE'RE
RUNNING A LITTLE BIT BEHIND BUT
WE'RE GOING TO LET ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY SPEAK IF YOU COULD
KEEP IT.
SHORT WE HAVE -- WE'RE RUNNING
BEHIND WE HAVE ANOTHER PANEL
STILL TO SEE OKAY I WILL TRY TO
BE AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE -- LET
OUT I THINK A LOT OF LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS BROUGHT UP BY DIFFERENT
COLLEAGUES TODAY -- BUT I THINK
DIRECTOR GEAR Là DUDE SHE IS ON
THE RIGHT TRACK AND WHAT HE SAME
WHICH IS.
I THINK IT'S LESS ABOUT WHERE WE
SHOULD BUILD OR NOT BUILD.
AND MORE ABOUT HOW DO YOU PLAN
FOR AND PAY THE COST OF
MITIGATING THE RISK THAT EVERY
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA.
HAS -- INSURANCE CAN ALSO PLAY A
ROLE -- AT THE PLAYS A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE I MEAN IF YOU
CAN'T GET INSURANCE [inaudible]
DESPITE.
YOUR DOING MITIGATION THE MAYBE
THAT ISN'T A PLACE. TO BUILD BUT
I THINK IF WE TRY TO OVER
SIMPLIFY THIS.
AND START SAYING WELL HERE'S THE
PLACES IN CALIFORNIA WE SHOULD
BUILD AND NOT BUILD I THINK
WE'RE MISSING A MAJOR POINT
THERE -- AND AND A GREAT PLAN
MEAN SHOULD WE DO PRIORITIZE
PLACE THE I. D. PRIORITIZE
PLACES THAT HAVE EARTHQUAKE RISK.
AS SHE WE DO PRIORITIZE PLACES
THAT HAVE FLOOD RISK -- WE'RE
GONNA START RUNNING OUT OF
PLACES THAT WE CAN BUILD AND WE
KNOW WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNITS. FOR EXAMPLE THAT
WE NEED TO BUILD TO CATCH UP. TO
WHERE WE NEED FOR A HOUSING
DEMAND.
IN THIS STATE -- I WANT TO
CONTEXTUALIZE A LITTLE BIT --
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN MY
DISTRICT.
NUMBER ONE I MEAN THIS WAS A ONE
IN A MILLION FIRE.
EVERY FIREFIGHTER THAT I'VE
TALKED TO SAID YOU KNOW.
WHERE THIS FIRE STARTED IN A
VERY REMOTE LOCATION HARD TO GET
TO MADE IT HARD TO GET TO THE
FIRE EARLY?
BUT EVEN WITH THAT FIFTY MILE AN
HOUR WINDS WERE BLOWING EXACTLY
RIGHT AT COM CAL.
AND ULTIMATELY PARADISE IN THIS
FIRE JUMPED TO CANYONS. TWO OF A
IN A MATTER OF IT IN A MATTER OF
HOURS IN THE STARTING SPOT FIRES
IN PARADISE BEFORE ANYBODY.
WOULD HAVE EVER EXPECTED EVERY
FIREFIGHTER SAID THIS QUICKLY
BECAME NOT A FIRE FIGHT BUT A
LIFESAVING MISSION.
IMMEDIATELY IT WAS A NATURAL
DISASTER -- AND YOU KNOW MAYBE
TO PUT IN AN URBAN CONTENTS AND
IMAGINE IF WE DID HAVE.
A LARGE SCALE EARTHQUAKE IN SAN
FRANCISCO OR THE BAY AREA AND IT
WAS LOCAL FIND SOIL IN THERE WAS
BUILDINGS FALLING DOWN ALL OVER
THE PLACE -- YOU KNOW AND PEOPLE
WERE TRYING TO GET OUT AND
THERE'S ONLY SO MANY PLACES TO
GET OUT AND YOU'RE TRYING TO
EVACUATE.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
FROM AN AREA AND YOU ONLY GOT SO
MANY BRIDGES IN.
THE SAME EXACT THING COULD
HAPPEN YOU KNOW.
SO LET'S CONTEXTUALIZE A LITTLE
BIT YOU KNOW BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE SOME OF THE COMMENTS LIKE
WELL WE SHOULD ONLY BIRD BUILD
IN OUR YOU KNOW MAYBE ALREADY
URBANIZED AREAS AND BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THERE.
AND THAT AND EVEN THE THE
CONTENTION THAT THAT'S WHERE THE
HIGH PERFORMING SCHOOLS ARE --
AND REALLY -- IS WE HAVE HIGH
PERFORMING SCHOOLS TO AND WE
HAVE ACCESS TO JOBS.
IN ON ALL OF THAT -- BUT IMAGINE
THOSE URBAN AREAS HAVE SOME SOME
HIGH RISK TO UNDER THE RIGHT
I THINK JUST FOCUSING ON HEY
THIS IS WHERE WE'RE SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO BUILD THIS IS.
IS KIND OF THE WRONG WAY TO LOOK
AT IT.
UNDERSTAND THIS ABOUT PARADISE.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE MOVE THERE BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO NOT BECAUSE THEY HAD.
TO YES THERE WAS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UP THERE AND FOR SOME
THAT WAS THE THING.
BUT IF YOU KNOW THIS COMMUNITY
PEOPLE WANTED TO LIVE THERE.
IT WAS WHERE THEY IT HAS A VERY
STRONG PLATE SENSE OF PLACE AND
COMMUNITY AND IT'S BEEN THERE
FOR OVER A HUNDRED YEARS THIS
WASN'T A COMMUNITY THAT JUST.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF GROWTH
PATTERNS ALL THE SUDDEN APPEARED.
YOU KNOW HERE IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS IT'S IT'S BEEN THERE FOR A
VERY LONG TIME -- CLIMB IT MEANS
WE HAVE MANY AREAS OF RISK FOR
EXAMPLE RISING SEA LEVEL. FOR
EXAMPLE AFFECTS COASTAL
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE HAVE MOSTLY
URBAN.
COMMUNITIES RIGHT -- AND YOU
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO JUST
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
URBAN PARTS.
OF THE STATE.
IT WITH THE MARKET FORCES ARE
THE HIGH COST.
OF THAT THE KOREAN LAND AND ALL
THE REGULATIONS AND RULES YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO DO A HUGE TAX
SUBSIDY -- TO GET PEOPLE DOWN TO
RENTS THAT ARE AFFORDABLE AND
PRICES ARE AFFORDABLE.
SO LOOK YOU DO HAVE TO LOOK AT
RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE. TO
MEET OUR AFFORDABILITY AND
HOUSING DEMANDS AND UNDERSTAND
IS THIS IS WHERE I THINK I PLAY
A ROLE.
IS THAT I OFTEN DO THIS IS I'M
TRYING TO BRING. TO EXPLAIN WHAT
RURAL CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY
LIFE BECAUSE I DON'T THINK A LOT
OF PEOPLE ACTUALLY BEEN THERE
AND THAT'S WHY DO SO MANY TOURS.
UP INTO MY DISTRICT IN AND
ASSEMBLYMAN DOLLY DOES THE SAME
THING -- NOT ALL OF RURAL
CALIFORNIA IS THE SAME THERE'S A
PRETTY BIG DIVERSITY OF
GEOGRAPHY.
UP THERE AND OUT THERE IN.
YOU KNOW IN THE HINTERLANDS IF
YOU WILL -- SO FOR EXAMPLE BUTTE
COUNTY PARADISE YES IS IN A
MOUNTAINOUS WOODED AREA.
BUT THERE'S A LARGE PORTION OF
BUTTE COUNTY THIS DOWN IN THE
VALLEY.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DON'T HAVE FIRE
RISK SO CAN KIND OF LOOKING AT
BUTTE COUNTY AS THE WHOLE AREA
IS A YOU KNOW A LOUIS.
IS NOT ACCURATE IT'S WRONG --
AND THERE IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO BUILD TRULY AFFORDABLE MARKET
RATE HOUSING IMMORAL PARTS OF
THE STATE IF WE LOOK AT EXISTING
COMMUNITIES SO EXAMPLE IN BUTTE
COUNTY WE HAVE.
THE CITIES OF CHICO AND BILL
BIGGS AND GRIDLEY THEIR EXISTING
COMMUNITIES.
WHERE LAND ACQUISITION AND OTHER
COSTS ARE MUCH CHEAPER WE COULD
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT'S
NOT IN THE HI FIRE HAZARDS --
THESE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO SO
JUST.
I WANT TO REALLY PUSH BACK
AGAINST MAYBE A LITTLE BIT OF A
BIAS TOWARDS A WE CAN OF WE GOT
A STANDARD BEEN AREAS WE CAN'T
GO OUT AND RURAL AREAS.
THAT'S DANGEROUS.
THAT'S NOT TRUE I MEAN IF YOU
REALLY LOOK AT YOU KNOW THE
CHARACTER IN THE DIVERSITY OF
THESE REGIONS -- RURAL
DEVELOPMENT -- YOU KNOW CAN BE
DONE YOU KNOW AS I SAID AROUND
THESE EXISTING COMMUNITIES.
THAT REBUILDING IN A PLACE LIKE
PARADISE.
I THINK CAN BE DONE.
YOU KNOW IT'S A MATTER OF
MITIGATING THAT RISK AND I THINK
WE SHOULD LOOK AT HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT HIS BILL BETTER AND
MORE RESILIENT -- AND GETTING
BACK TO PLANNING.
THANKS THIS YEAR IN ABOUT A
BREWING COMPANY WHO MADE A LARGE
DONATION TO THIS THEY HAVE A
PLANNER RIGHT NOW IN THE IN THE
TOWN OF PARADISE IN A CHURCH
THAT STILL STANDING UP THERE --
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE ARE GATHERING
AND THEY'RE HAVING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT HOW DO WE BUILD SMARTER.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
SAFER HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT
ROADWAYS CONNECTED DON'T DEAD
END -- AND THEY'RE HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW THEY
TRULY MITIGATE.
THE RISK FOR THIS COMMUNITY AND
AND AND I THINK IT CAN BE DONE
THIS CAN BE A MUCH SAFER
RESILIENT.
COMMUNITY IN THE LONG TERM THAT
SHOULD BE OUR GOAL -- NOT TO SAY
OH NO YOU NEVER YOU KNOW --
YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO BUILD
AND AND AND A PLACE AGAIN -- AND
A AND M. AND NOBODY IS IGNORING
THAT RISK [inaudible]
WHATSOEVER -- IT'S SOMETHING I
THINK PEOPLE ARE VERY COGNIZANT
OF BUT YOU KNOW THE ISSUE SHOULD
REALLY BE HEY HOW DO WE REALLY
MAKE SURE THAT'S BETTER IN FOR
AN AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
BROUGHT UP I THINK WE DO NEED.
A MUCH BETTER ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM. FOR ENSURING THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ACTUALLY
HAPPENS AND YOU CAN BE ENFORCED
AND AND THAT THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES FOR NOT DOING IT --
BECAUSE THAT WAS A HUGE ISSUE --
FOR EXAMPLE IN PARADISE.
BUILDING HOUSING SO THAT THE
EMBERS CAN'T GET UNDERNEATH THE
EASE MANY OF THE HOUSES IN
PARADISE BURNED DOWN FROM THE
INSIDE OUT.
BECAUSE EMBERS GOT INSIDE TO THE
EAVES.
IT WASN'T AND AND IT WAS A VERY
QUICK BURNING FIERY IT WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TAKEN OUT AS
MANY HOUSING.
AS MUCH HOUSING HAD IT BEEN
BUILT TO BETTER STANDARDS -- IN
THE FIRST PLACE AND THE COST
ACTUALLY FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION.
TO BUILD A MORE FIRE RESILIENT
HOUSE VERSUS THE OLDER STANDARDS
THE COST IS VERY NEGLIGIBLE
THERE'S NOT MUCH DIFFERENCE.
SO WE CAN DO THAT AND STILL DO
IT IN A COST EFFECTIVE WAY --
AND THEN IN THE LONG TERM.
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF COMMUNITIES
ARE FIRE RESILIENT RATE THAT
RIGHT NOW TODAY NEED TO BE
RETROFITTED.
THAT'S WHERE THE EXPENSES IS
PRETTY TOUGH TO GET THERE RIGHT
AND SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HEY
HOW CAN WE DO AS IT LOW COST
LOANS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
HAS LEGISLATION THAT HE'S
WORKING ON RIGHT NOW THE MAYBE
CAN ASSIST PEOPLE AND MAKING
SURE THEIR HOMES ARE RETROFITTED
TO BECOME -- MORE FIRE RESILIENT --
AND THAT WOULD BE A GETS
EXPENDITURE OF MONEY THAT WOULD
BE A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY THAT WE
COULD.
NOT IT WOULD BE LITTLE IS GOING
TO BE SIGNIFICANT BUT ID BE
MONEY.
WELL SPENT BECAUSE WHAT'S THE
COST OF A DISASTER AND I THINK
THAT WAS A GREAT POINT THE CASA
DISASTERS.
MY IS EXPONENTIAL SO IF WE CAN
IF WE CAN DO SOME OF THESE
THINGS AND REALLY THINK ABOUT
HEY HOW DO WE REALLY.
PAY THE COST OF AND MITIGATE
RISK -- WE CAN MEET OUR HOUSING
GOALS.
AND WE CAN  WE CAN
SAFER AND MORE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES LONG TERM -- AND I
AND I IN A AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE THE AGREEMENT NEEDS TO
COME AROUND AS IS FIGURE OUT HOW
WE DO THAT.
RATHER THAN GETTING INTO A WILL
HATE THIS PLACE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BUILD WE'RE ONLY GOING TO
BUILD HERE AND I JUST THINK
THAT'S THE WRONG WAY TO
CONCEPTUALIZE IT THAT'S ALL.
THANK YOU SO REMEMBER GALLAGHER
AND OUR FINALS A QUESTION SOME
REMEMBER COOLEY.
WELL I HAVE MORE COMMENTS I WANT
TO SAY ACTUALLY I AGREE WITH MR
GALLAGHER'S POINT.
I THINK WOULD BE AS SERIOUS
FAILURE THE INSTITUTION. TO NOT
BE HAVING A STATEWIDE SOLUTION.
RURAL VERSUS URBAN.
I JUST THINK WE CAN'T SOLVE A
PROBLEM THAT WAY.
RURAL AREAS YOU TEND TO HAVE
LARGER LOT SIZES AND FRANKLY I
THINK YOU COULD ROUND REVERT
RURAL AREAS.
YOU REALIZE.
ON OFF A LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH
THOSE LARGER LOT SIZES.
THEY'VE TAKEN CARE OF THEIR
PROPERTY BECAUSE THEY DON'T
EXPECT THAT IF THERE'S A FIRE
THAT THE FIRE SERVICE TO GET
THERE SOONER UP TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM.
SO MUCH MORE THAN OUR SERBAN
DWELLERS IT'S A MATTER OF SELF
PRESERVATION TO TRY TO CREATE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE IF YOU HAVE.
URBAN OR RURAL PROPERTY.
I THINK AS YOU MOVE FORWARD I
THINK THIS.
TIME IS TO IDEAS OF HOW DO WE
MEET OUR HOUSING NEEDS HOW TO
ADDRESS OUR OUR FIRE RISK OR
DISASTER RISK.
I ACTUALLY THINK COLLEAGUES WERE
SORT OF IN AN ERA OF NEEDING A
CALIFORNIA TYPE OF MARSHALL PLAN.
WE NEED TO SCALE UP OUR
SOLUTIONS TO DO WITH THESE TWO
GREAT CHALLENGES.
THAT BIND THE FUTURE STATE
TOGETHER.
IN A CONCERTED WAY.
AND AND I JUST WANT TO OFFER THE
OBSERVATION THAT WHEN USED AS
LAWMAKERS.
SAY WHAT THE HECK OF THE TOOLS
ARE TOOL KIT.
THEY ARE MORE THAN MONEY.
THERE ARE MORE THAN PROGRAMMATIC
I THINK AS LAWMAKERS.
ARE JOB REALLY IS TO ASK HOW DO
WE RELEASE ENERGY ON THIS
PROBLEM.
MONEY MAY BE A WAY A NEW PROGRAM
MAY BE AWAY WE KNEW IT REALLY
DOES HELP WHAT OTHER DYNAMICS
WHERE YOU CAN AFFECT THE
CHEMISTRY OF WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IN PEOPLE'S HEADS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL COURSE I WAS FIRST B. P.
OF THE LEAGUE OF CITIES SO
ALMOST PRESENT LEICA COME TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
I SEE MY COLLEAGUES WHY SO SHE
WITH THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IN THE ROOM.
I THINK I WOULD SAY WE OUGHT TO
BE GOING TO THE CIVIL CODE WHICH
I HAD MY STAFF BRING TO ME. TO
JUST SPEND A LITTLE TIME
THINKING ABOUT THIS PROBLEM IN
LIGHT OF CIVIL CODE PROVISIONS.
ELEVEN OH TWO THE TRANSFER
DISCLOSURE STATEMENT THAT AROSE
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE TRYING TO
PROVE DISCLOSURES ON PROPERTY --
THE NATURAL DISASTER DISCLOSURE
STATEMENT ELEVEN OH THREE THE
CIVIL CODE.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE LOOKING AT
FIRE FLOOD.
EARTHQUAKE.
BECAUSE ACTION WHEN YOU READ
THOSE TO JUST THOSE TWO
PROVISIONS.
YOU'LL START REALIZING OLDER'S
MAPS OUT THERE THE PEOPLE OF
CREATED TO GET FILED THE LOCAL
LEVEL PUT PEOPLE ON NOTICE THEY
MAKE INDIVIDUAL PROPERTY OWNERS
ON NOTICE.
THAT SENDS A HEIGHTENED LEVEL
RESPONSIBLE TO THE SYSTEM.
I WOULD SAY.
THAT WE MAY NEED OTHER SOLUTIONS
BUT HONESTLY I THINK WE WOULD
ENLARGE OUR FRAME OF REFERENCE
ON THIS CONVERSATION. TO LOOK AT
HOW THE TRANSFER DISCLOSURE
STATEMENT THE TDS OF LUBBOCK
[inaudible]
TO AFFECTED.
REAL ESTATE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE NATURAL HAZARD DISCLOSURE
STATEMENT.
THE STRUCTURES ARE OUT THERE THE
WAY INFORMATION GETS ON MAPS
RATED INUNDATION EXPOSURE AND
HOW THAT WORKS ITS WAY THROUGH
THE THE HOUSING SYSTEM.
AND NOW YOU'RE STARTING TO A
CONVERSATION WHERE I THINK IT'S
MORE OF THE RELEASE OF ENERGY
CATEGORY.
WHAT CAN YOU DO IN A NEW WANTS
WAY THIS STARTS GIVING PEOPLE
MORE OF A STAKE IN THE SOLUTION?
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT I
DEFINITELY AGREE -- RURAL FOLKS
THEY REPRESENT A DIFFERENT
ASPECT OF THE PROBLEM BUT
ACTUALLY THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT OF
SELF HELP INTEGRAL TO WHAT IS
DONE.
I DO THINK THE PARADISE FIRE WAS
VERY UNIQUE EVENT -- AND THAT'S
NOT TO SAY THAT WE THEREFORE.
DON'T TREAT IS A DATA SET WHAT
HAPPENED SANTA ROSA AS WAS
POINTED OUT VERY UNIQUE EVENT.
WE SORT OF NEED TO LOOK AT HOW
THESE DIFFERENT FACT THINGS
FACTORED SOLUTION.
BUT ULTIMATELY I THINK THIS IS A
PLACE FOR THE STATE THESE
LEADERSHIP I THINK IT NEEDS A
MARSHALL PLAN.
THE GOVERNOR USE OUT ON AN
OPERATION EXPECTED HOMELESS.
I THINK I AGREE WITH THATBUT I
THINK WE NEED THE SAME SORT OF
EMPHASIS ON THE FIRE ISSUE.
THAT IS WHERE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA COULD ORCHESTRATE
SOLUTIONS FOR FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS BUT I THINK IT'S
MORE THAN MONEY AND MORE THAN
PROGRAMS WE NEED TO LOOK AT HOW
DO YORKERS AFFECT PEOPLE'S
MOTIVATION.
THIS RELEASE OF ENERGY CONCEPT
WHICH I THINK.
AS LAWMAKERS AND PARTNERS A
SECOND BRANCH WE CAN WORK ON
THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I KNOW
THERE'S PLENTY MORE QUESTIONS ON
THIS COMMITTEE BETTER -- BECAUSE
OF TIMING -- WE WOULD LIKE -- TO
BRING UP FOR SECOND -- PANEL BUT
WE WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH I I
THINK THEY WERE OVERWHELMED OF
HOW WELL THIS WENT TODAY AND HOW
MANY QUESTIONS AND IT'S PROMPTED
ADDITIONAL -- FOUGHT FOR ALL OF
US AND I REALLY -- BUT I THINK
ALL OF YOU FOR COMING TODAY --
EXPECT TO GET EMAILS AND OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM US IN THE WEEKS
TO COME SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT WILL NOW I INVITE OUR
SECOND PANEL UP WHILE FILED THE
BE THE WILDFIRE PLANNING
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND HOUSING
DELIVERY SOME LOCAL PERSPECTIVES.
A PEEP PARKINSON OF A. I. C. P.
PAST PRESENT AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
FORMER CINEMA COUNTY PLANNING
DIRECTOR.
DANA CAREY EMERGENCY SERVICES
MANAGER FROM THE YELLOW OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
KEITH WOODS CEO NORTH COAST
BUILDERS EXCHANGE AND BRIAN RING
ASSISTANT CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICER FROM BUTTE COUNTY.
WE WELCOME YOU ALL.
AND ONCE YOU GET -- COMFORTABLE
MISTER PARKINSON PLEASE START.
I'M READY. FOR YOUR PATIENCE
OBVIOUSLY THIS WAS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CO CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES -- YOU
SAID MY NAME IS PETE PARKINSON
AND I'M HERE TODAY WITH THE
PERSPECTIVE BOTH OF A WILDFIRE
SURVIVOR.
AND OF A PROFESSIONAL PLANNER
WITH OVER THREE DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE IN THREE CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES ALL OF WHICH HAVE.
EXPERIENCED DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES AT ONE TIME OR ANOTHER --
I WAS THE DO PLANNING DIRECTOR
FOR THE COUNTY OF CINEMA UNTIL
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND MY
FAMILY LOST OUR HOME IN THE SNOW
BUT COUNTY WILDFIRES OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND AS YOU
NOTED.
I WAS THE PRESIDENT OF APA
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I WANT
TAKE JUST A MINUTE TO START WITH
MY OWN -- FIRE STORY IF I CAN.
MY WIFE AND I IN OUR THEN NINE
YEAR OLD SON WERE SLEEP THE
NIGHT OF OCTOBER EIGHTH.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE WOKE
TO THE SMELL OF SMOKE IN THE
GLOW FIRE IN THE DISTANCE.
WE INITIALLY EVACUATED TO MY
WIFE'S MOTHER'S HOUSE IN A
MOBILE HOME PARK IN SANTA ROSA.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ENDED UP
EVACUATING GRANDMA IS WELL IN
HER PARK WAS LARGELY DESTROYED
BY EIGHT IN ENTIRELY SEPARATE
FAR THE ROAD INTO SANTA ROSA
FROM THE NORTHEAST THAT NIGHT.
DESPITE OUR EXPERIENCE LOSING A
HOME THAT WE DEARLY LOVED JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT WE OWNED
AND ONE OF OUR TWO DOGS.
I CONSIDER OUR FAMILY TO HAVE
BEEN INCREDIBLY FORTUNATE WE
WERE SPARED THE HORRIFYING
EXPERIENCES THAT MANY OF MY
NEIGHBORS WENT THROUGH.
RUSHING OUT OF THEIR HOMES WITH
THEIR YARDS ALREADY ON FIRE
ABANDONING BURNING CARS AND
STRIKING OUT ON FOOT.
CUTTING THROUGH BARBED WIRE
FENCE AND DRIVING OVER LAND WITH
A CAR FULL OF KIDS WHEN THE
ROADS WERE BLOCKED BY FIRE AND
FALLEN TREES.
SHELTERING IN PLACE WHILE THE
HOMES AROUND THEM BURNED IN
LARGE NEIGHBOR ACROSS THE STREET
WHO PASSED AWAY IN HIS HOME.
BECAUSE HE COULDN'T GET OUT.
OVER 70% OF THE HOMES IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD WERE DESTROYED IN
JUST UNDER HALF OF THESE.
OUR UNDER ALL ARE NOW BEING
REBUILT ALMOST TWO YEARS AFTER
THE EVENT.
BUT THAT MEANS THAT MORE THAN
HALF OF OUR NEIGHBORS HAVE NOT
YET STARTED REBUILDING.
SOME CAN'T AFFORD IT TOO
PERVASIVE OVER UNDER INSURANCE A
HIGH BUILDING COSTS.
BUT IS ALSO A TRAUMA THAT IS
THAT VISITS PEOPLE IN THIS KIND
OF SITUATION.
AND THEY REMAIN TRAUMATIZED BY
WITH THE EXPERIENCE THAT NIGHT
AND THEN IN THE MONTHS THAT
FOLLOWED THAT IT'S PALPABLE WHEN
YOU TALK TO THEM.
IT REALLY IS SOMETHING THAT
INTERFERES WITH THE FOCUS AND
DECISIVENESS THAT'S NECESSARY TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH A A REBUILDING
PROJECT SO MY GUESS IS AROUND
25% OF OUR NEIGHBORS WILL NEVER
REBUILD.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T FACE THE
ADDITIONAL STRESSES AND DELAY
THE LIKE THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION PROCESS ENTAILS.
IN MY POINT IN RAISING THESE
ISSUES IS TO EMPHASIZE THE HUMAN
TOLL THAT THESE WILDFIRES TAKE I
KNOW THE THE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER IS VERY VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THIS I'M SURE -- BUT IT'S
MORE THAN STRUCTURES IT'S MORE
THAN DOLLARS IT'S MORE THAN
MATERIAL THINGS AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY DO NEED
TO KEEP IN THE FOREFRONT OF OUR
MINDS.
AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO REDUCE THESE HAZARDS
AND REDUCE RISK IN THE FUTURE.
IN WITH THIS IN MIND I'M OUT OF
TOUCH ON AN ISSUE THAT YOU'VE
ALREADY TOUCHED ON HERE.
BUT IT'S REALLY A SHIFT THAT I
BELIEVE IS NEEDED AND HOW WE
PLAN FOR WILD FIRE HAZARDS.
IN THE NEAR OUR COMMUNITIES IN
ABOUT PLANNING FOR DEVELOPMENT
GENERALLY IN WHILE FAR AREAS.
SO IT'S A AS THE FOLKS FROM CAL
FIRE INDICATED IT SHOULD BE
PAINFULLY OBVIOUS TO ALL OF US
NOW THAT WE LIVE.
IN AN ENVIRONMENT MORE FOR FIRES
AN ONION UNAVOIDABLE PART OF OUR
LANDSCAPE.
EVEN WITHOUT A SINGLE HUMAN
STRUCTURED OUR STATE CALIFORNIA
WOULD STILL HAVE WILDFIRES SOME
OF THOSE FIRES WOULD BE VERY
LARGE.
IN THIS NATURAL PLANT LANDSCAPES
DO.
THE WILD LANDS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE ADAPTED TO THIS WILDFIRE
REGIME AND NOW WE HAVE SCIENCE
CALLED FIRE ECOLOGY.
THE TELLS US THAT MANY OF CAL
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL COMMUNITIES
ACTUALLY RELY ON REGULAR FIRES.
TO MAINTAIN THEIR ECOLOGICAL
HEALTH AND DIVERSITY.
BUT OF COURSE WE DON'T LIVE IN A
PRISTINE STATE OF NATURE ALREADY
ABOUT A THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS.
LIVE AND WORK IN THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE AREAS AND MORE
PEOPLE ARE COMING ALL THE TIME.
AND AS YOU KNOW FOR THE PAST
CENTURY OR SO WHILE FAR
MANAGEMENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HAS BEEN BASED ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND SUPPRESSION.
AND WE NOW KNOW AS THE AGAINST
THE FOLKS FROM CAL FIRE TOLD YOU.
THE ONE RESULT OF THAT APPROACH
IS A HUGE BUILD UP OF WILD LAND
FUELS THE CONCERT CONTRIBUTES
CONSIDERABLY TO THE DRAMATIC AND
CATASTROPHIC FIRES.
THAT WE HAVE SEEN RECENTLY.
WE'VE GOTTEN SO GOOD AT FIRE
SUPPRESSION THOUGH THAT WE HAVE
IT'S LED TO A CERTAIN HUBRIS ON
THE DEVELOPMENT SIDE OF THINGS
IN MY VIEW.
THE SHARE OF OUR STATE'S
POPULATION IN WE AREAS -- IT
CONTINUES TO GROW EVEN NOW.
AND HERE'S THE IS HERE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
INCLUDES FAR MORE THAN JUST THE
VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES.
MY OWN HOME FOR EXAMPLE WAS IN
AN AREA THAT WAS MAPPED BY CAL
FIRE IS ONLY MODERATE -- FIRE
HAZARD SECURITY.
WE'VE DEVELOPED FIRE SAFE
STANDARDS AND WE BUILDING CODES
THAT ESSENTIALLY SAY GO AHEAD
AND BUILD IN THESE AREAS WE CAN
PROTECT YOU.
AND I THINK THAT THE THE THE
PUTTING THE LIE TO THAT IF YOU
WILL IS SOMETHING THAT ALL OF US
ARE REALIZING COLLECTIVELY HERE
THE PAST COUPLE YEARS.
AND AS WE'VE DONE THIS THOUGH AS
THIS DEVELOPMENT HAS INCREASED
OUT IN THESE WE WE AREAS.
WE'VE ADDED LITERALLY ANOTHER
MAJOR SOURCE OF FUEL TO THE FIRE.
THE FIRE STORMS WE EXPERIENCE IN
CINEMA COUNTY BUTTE COUNTY WERE
EVERY BIT AS MUCH STRUCTURE
FIRES AS THEY WERE WILD LAND
FIRES.
MEANING THAT THE STRUCTURES THAT
WE HAD PUT IN THE PATH OF WILD
LAND FIRES.
ESSENTIALLY BECAME THE FUEL THAT
RESULTED IN EVEN LARGER AND MORE
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES. TO THE POINT
THAT -- IN OUR AREA FOR EXAMPLE.
FIRE SAFE STANDARDS AND WE
BUILDING CODES OFFERED ONLY
LIMITED PROTECTION FROM WIND
DRIVEN FIRE STORMS THAT -- IN
AREAS THAT WERE DEVELOPED AT
SUBURBAN DENSITIES.
SO THE SHIFT I'M TALKING ABOUT
MEANS THAT INSTEAD OF PRETENDING
THAT WE CAN KEEP BUILDING IN
HAZARDOUS AREAS.
AND ACTUALLY PROTECT OUR HOMES
AND BUSINESSES AGAINST LITERAL
FIRE STORMS.
DRIVEN BY HIGH WINDS AND
EXACERBATED BY CLIMATE CHANGE WE
NEED TO STOP MAKING THINGS WORSE
BY REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF NEW
DEVELOPMENT.
THAT OCCURS IN THESE AREAS THIS
STARTS WITH GOOD LAND USE
PLANNING.
THE REDUCES DENSITIES IN
OUTLYING AREAS AND STRONGLY
DISCOURAGES UP ZONING AND
SUBDIVISIONS AND FIRE HAZARD
AREAS.
AND FOR THIS REASON APA
CALIFORNIA'S VERY HAPPY TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS YEAR -- EIGHT SB
EIGHT ONE EIGHTY TWO WHICH I
KNOW YOU YOUR COMMITTEES WILL BE
HEARING AT SOME POINT IN THE
NEAR FUTURE.
THE OTHER REASON THE GOOD
PLANNING IS NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE IS NEEDED IS TO ADDRESS THE
OTHER SUBJECT OF YOUR HEARING
TODAY HOUSING DELIVERY. FOR THE
PAST COUPLE OF DECADES THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IS TAKEN
A NUMBER OF STEPS. TO GUIDE LAND
USE DEVELOPMENT IN WAYS THAT
MAKE OUR STATE MORE SUSTAINABLE
I TALKING HERE ABOUT LAWS LIKE.
THE SMART GROWTH PRINCIPLES OF
AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN AND THE
LINK BETWEEN THE LOCATION OF NEW
LAND USES.
AND GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS
UNDER SB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE ALL THESE
BILLS ALIGNED WITH THE COMMON
THEME THAT IF CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO GROW MORE SUSTAINABLY
WE NEED TO ACTIVELY DISCOURAGE
INCREASE ENCOURAGE DEVELOPMENT
IN SOME AREAS AND DISCOURAGED IN
OTHERS.
IN MY HOME REGION THE BAY AREA
GROWTH IN HOUSING ALLOCATIONS
ARE ALREADY FOCUSED AS THEY
SHOULD BE IN URBAN CORE AND JOB
RICH AREAS AND AWAY FROM GREEN
FIELD DEVELOPMENT IN
AGRICULTURAL IN OUTLYING AREAS.
SO WHAT IS THIS MEETING WILD
FIRE HAZARD AREAS IT MEANS QUITE
SIMPLY.
THAT ADDING MORE FAR FLUNG RURAL
SUBDIVISIONS IN OUTLYING WILD
FIRE HAZARD AREAS IS NOT A
SUSTAINABLE LAND USE PRACTICE.
IT MEANS THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES WITH WE WE ARE IS THE
TO FOCUS HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IN
THE LEASE HAZARDOUS AREAS.
EVEN IF IT MEANS INCREASING
DENSITIES IN THOSE AREAS.
AND THEY NEED TO INCLUDE ROBERT
ROBUST FIRE PROTECTION IN
MITIGATION MEASURES.
IN APPROVING THOSE TWO
DEVELOPMENTS AND ALL OF THAT
TAKES GOOD PLANNING.
EVERY COMMUNITY WHETHER IT'S
URBAN OR RURAL NEEDS TO MEET
THEIR AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS
AT STATE ROUTE LAW REQUIRES AND
AS OUR COMMUNITY SO DESPERATELY
NEEDS.
BUT THEY NEED TO DO IT IN A
SUSTAINABLE WAY.
BUT COMMUNITIES DON'T HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO APPROVE NEW
UPSCALE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS OR
RECREATION.
OR RECREATIONAL OR SECOND HOMES
SUBDIVISIONS IN HIGH FIRE HAZARD
AREAS DEVELOPMENT THAT ONLY
INCREASES HAZARDS FOR ALL OF US.
THANK YOU A CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME IS
SCARY.
BEST TO SEE YOU.
THANK YEAR CHAIRS -- AND MEMBERS
OF TAKE COMMITTEES -- FOR ASKING
ME HERE TO KIND OF SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT HAS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL I HAVE.
YOU HEARD THE PREVIOUS PANEL
TALK ABOUT.
ACRONYMS THAT NOBODY REMEMBERS --
MAYBE EVEN ASKED FOR SOME OF
THAT TESTIMONY IN WRITING SO
THAT YOU CAN SEE SOME OF THAT.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WITH THE
CHALLENGE OF TAKING EVERYTHING
THAT COMES DOWN FROM THE FEDERAL
OR STATE LEVEL AS EITHER A
MANDATE OR A BEST PRACTICE OR
TIED TO FUNDING AND MOST OF US
WANT THAT FUNDING.
WE NEED THAT MONEY TO DO THE
WORK THAT WE HAVE THAT.
GIVEN MY CHOICE. 1100% OF THE
TIME I'LL TAKE ANY MONEY THAT
COMES MY WAY AND PUT IT TO
STAFFING BECAUSE WE ALWAYS HAVE.
A LACK OF PERSONNEL SHE JUST
SURELY TO GET THIS INFORMATION
ACROSS TO THE PUBLIC.
THE THINGS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE PROGRAMS THE PLANS HOW
EVERYTHING INTERACTS WHAT WE
NEED THEM TO KNOW IS SO COMPLEX.
THAT SOMETIMES WE JUST HAVE TO
KEEP GOING OVER.
BASS LINE AFTER AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND AGAIN IT'S VERY CHALLENGING
FOR US AND REALLY THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO DO THAT IS IN
PERSON -- I CAN SHARE THINGS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA I CAN PUSH OUT
WEBSITE INFORMATION BUT NOTHING
HEADS HOME MORE THAN STANDING IN
FRONT OF THAT RESIDENT.
AND THAT TAKES A LOT OF TIME.
SO I JUST KIND OF WANTED TO AND
I'VE GIVEN YOU AN INFOGRAPHIC
ABOUT THREE MAIN PLANNING --
KIND OF OUR PLANS IF YOU WILL.
AND PLANNING EFFORTS THAT WE
PARTICIPATE IN THE FIRST ONE
BEING THE GENERAL PLAN NOW
OBVIOUSLY UNDER GOVERNMENT CODE
AS SIX FIVE THREE HUNDRED AND WE
HAVE A MANDATE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO ADOPT A GENERAL
PLAN.
BUT IN MANY JURISDICTION GENERAL
PLANS ARE NOT FREQUENTLY TOUCH
OR REVISIONS.
IN A WHOLE SOMETIMES ONLY PARTS
IT'S BECAUSE OF ONE SPECIFIC
MANDATE.
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT DOESN'T
TYPICALLY CONTROL THE TIMELINE
OR THE STATUS OF GENERAL PLAN
UPDATE SO IT MAKES IT VERY
CHALLENGING TO PUT SOMETHING IN
THAT AT THAT LEVEL OF PLAN IN
OUR RESPECTIVE JURISDICTIONS.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT -- THE HAZARD
MITIGATION PLAN THAT'S ONE BIT
MY JURISDICTIONS SPECIFICALLY IS
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WE JUST
WENT THROUGH OUR FIVE YEAR FEMA
PLANNING REVISION CYCLE THAT IS
A FIVE YEAR CYCLE.
WHEN WE TIE THINGS TO THAT PLAN
YOU HAVE THE PROPENSITY TO ONLY
SEE THAT DONE IN FIVE YEARS TIME
FROM TODAY IF THEY GET APPROVED
BY SCHEME OF THIS YEAR?
SO AGAIN ANOTHER LINK THE
STANDARD IF YOU'RE TRYING TO GET
SOMETHING INTEGRATED BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO HAVE ALL FIVE YEARS OF
THAT TIME INCLUDES PUBLIC
MEETINGS.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT IT'S IN
200-017-2000 EIGHTEEN WE HAD
ABOUT FOUR PUBLIC MEETING IS
WHERE WE MESSAGED OUT TO
EVERYBODY IN THE COUNTY. TO COME
AND SHARE THEIR PERSPECTIVE WITH
US.
ABOUT MITIGATION WHAT PROJECTS
WE SHOULD BE IT -- TACKING WITH
THESE FUNDS YOU HEARD SOME
PHENOMENAL.
FUNDING AMOUNTS KIND OF THROWN
OUT WITH THE LAST PANEL AND
TELLING YOU THEY'RE SMALL WHEN
THEY GET TO MY LEVEL THEY'RE
HIGHLY COMPETITIVE WHEN THEY GET
TO MY LEVEL.
THEY'RE VERY HARD TO GET.
SO IT'S NOT AN END ALL BE ALL
SOLUTION FOR EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT WE'RE WE'RE VERY
PROGRESSIVE ANY OTHER WE HAVE
CLIMATE CHANGE IN OUR MITIGATION
PLAN NOW THE ONLY.
LEGAL STANDARD IN THERE IS TO
HAVE THE NATURAL HAZARDS.
NOT ANY OF THE TECHNOLOGICAL ARE
MANMADE HAZARDS WHICH INCLUDES
WILD FIRE.
SO THAT MAKES IT SO THAT IN A
LOCAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY HAS TO BE PROGRESSIVE
HOUSE TO GO OUT HAS TO TALK
PEOPLE INTO INCLUDING MORE THAN
WHAT'S MANDATED AN ALREADY VERY
LONG TRYING CYCLE.
THAT REQUIRES A LOT OF HANDS ON
AND TOUCHING OF OUR COMMUNITY I
CAN TELL YOU THIS PUBLIC
MEETINGS WE HAD AN AVERAGE OF
THREE PEOPLE SHOW UP TO EACH OF
THEM. THREE OUT OF A COUNTY OF
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
OKAY AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AT
THE CITY OF DAVIS CITY COUNCIL
CHAMBERS.
AT THE WINTERS PUBLIC SAFETY
BUILDING THESE ARE NOT SMALL
VENUES WERE PLANNING FOR MANY
MANY PEOPLE TO COME WE WANT TO
QUESTIONS.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE UP AGAINST
IN EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
WHEN WE WE HAVE EIGHTEEN PAGES
OF MITIGATION PROJECTS IN THE
NEW YOLO COUNTY HAZARD
MITIGATION PLAN?
WE HAVE SOME THAT WE'VE ALREADY
ACTUALLY APPLIED NOTICE OF
INTENSE TO APPLY FOR MITIGATION
FUNDS OUT OF MULTIPLE MEDICATION
PATHWAYS PRE DISASTER MITIGATION --
MITIGATION MONIES THAT OPEN UP
AFTER A DISASTER HAPPENS ALL OF
THOSE WE TRY TO MAKE USE OF ALL
OF THEM.
SOME OF THEM WE'VE BEEN TURNED
DOWN FOUR AND FIVE TIMES IN JUST
RECENTLY ON THIS.
THE SIX APPLICATION DID IT GET
AWARDED.
SO IT'S REALLY CHALLENGING TO
GET THOSE GRANTS EVEN THE MONEY
IS THERE AND IT'S THERE FOR VERY
GOOD REASON AND WE ALL WANTED IT
IS HIGHLY COMPETITIVE YOU'RE
COMPETING AGAINST.
EVERYONE OF THE OTHER FIFTY
SEVEN COUNTIES HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CITIES SPECIAL
DISTRICTS LARGE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES -- ELECT UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY ALL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO FOR THESE
GRANTS.
AND IF THEY HAVE THE FINANCIAL
BASES TO OUTSOURCE THEIR GRANT
WRITING AND THINGS LIKE THAT
QUITE FREQUENTLY THEY WILL BEAT
US OUT IF WE DO IT IN HOUSE.
AND IT'S JUST A MATTER OF FACT
WE REALLY REALLY WANT TO THAT
MONEY WHEN WE TRAVEL TO THE VERY
BOTTOM THIRD SECTION THAT
INFOGRAPHIC WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE EMERGENCY OPERATIONS PLAN.
THAT'S ONE OF MY INDUSTRY
FREQUENTLY TOUCHES ALL THE TIME --
IF WE'RE FOLLOWING THE
COMPREHENSIVE PREPAREDNESS GUIDE
AND SET FORTH BY FEMA WE'RE
UPDATING THAT PLAN EVERY YEAR OR
TWO YEARS THE MAIN BASE PLAN.
AND THEN WHAT A COMPANIES THAT
BASS PLAN IS ANY NUMBER OF
ANNEXES INYO COUNTY WE HAVE OVER
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
INDEPENDENT PLANS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS PLAN.
ANYTHING FROM HOW TO ISSUE
EMERGENCY CAL FRESH CARDS TO
PEOPLE WHO NEED THOSE FOOD
STAMPS AFTER EVERYTHING THEY
HAVE WAS LOST BY A WILD FIRE OR
FLOOD.
BECAUSE ALL OF OUR PLANS ARE ALL
HAZARDS WE'RE ROLLING OUT BRAND
NEW EVACUATIONS OWNING WE HAVE A
COMMUNITY MEETING TONIGHT IN
WINTERS.
SHAMELESS PLUG -- YOU KNOW WE'VE
BEEN TRYING FOR FOUR YEARS TO
GET THE COMMUNITY TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY NEED TO SIGN UP FOR
OUR MASS NOTIFICATION SYSTEM
WITH ON THE SYSTEM FOR FOUR
YEARS.
OUT OF THE ESTIMATED TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN POPULATION FOR
YOLO COUNTY WHICH IS OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE CAN ESTIMATED NOT CENSUS
DATA.
NOW WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND DATA POINTS IN OUR MASS
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM IN IT OUR
CULMINATED FROM WHITE PAGES DATA
YELLOW PAGES STATUS IS NOT IN
REVERSE NINE ONE ONE DATA THAT
WE PAY.
FOR BUT OUT OF THE CITIZEN
OPTIONS WE HAVE SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
NINE LESS THAN 10% OF THE COUNTY.
AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO IN MANY CASES IT'S
BECAUSE OUT OF FOUR YEARS THEY
HAVEN'T HEARD IT UP OF IT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW MANY SIGNS
WE PUT INSIDE YOLO BUS WHICH IS
RUNNING RIGHT NOW IN EVERY
SINGLE BUS IT DOESN'T MATTER
THAT I WAS ON DAVIS -- MEDIA
BROADCAST VIDEO TAPES THE OTHER
DAY WITH THAT SAME MESSAGE SO
NOW THAT'S UP ON THEIR WEBSITE
AND ON THE PUBLIC ACCESS CHANNEL
WE'VE DONE KCRA RADIO SPOTS.
OUR OUR KTLA THINK IT WHATEVER
IT WAS IN SACRAMENTO.
THAT WAS THREE YEARS AGO EITHER
WAY WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR A
VERY LONG TIME WE RUN ANNUAL
TESTS OF THAT SYSTEM.
WE ASK FOR PEOPLE TO FOLLOW OUR
INSTRUCTIONS WE'RE GETTING LOTS
OF COMMUNITY FEEDBACK WHICH IS
REALLY GREAT ON THE EVACUATION
PLANNING THAT WERE ROLLING OUT
RIGHT NOW.
LOTS OF THINGS WE'VE NEVER EVEN
THOUGHT OF AND SOME OF THEM ARE
SO SIMPLE THAT WE WONDER WHY WE
DIDN'T THINK OF THEM I DON'T
KNOW START A COMMUNITY MEETING
THE OTHER NIGHT.
A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC CAME UP
TO ME AND SAID.
WELL I HAVE LARGE ANIMALS OUR
FORCES AND THINGS LIKE THAT I
NEED A PHONE NUMBER TO CALL TO
KNOW WHERE TO TAKE THEM AND WHEN
WE SAY WE PUT IT OUT ON THE
SOCIAL MEDIA CHANNEL WE PUT IT
ON THIS WEBSITE WE BLASTED OUT
THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
HE SAYS I DON'T DO SOCIAL MEDIA
I WANT A PHONE AND YOUR PHONE
NUMBER TO CALL WHEN WE WERE UP
IN THE CAPE PAY VALLEY.
I NEED A PRINT VERSION OF THIS
MAP I DON'T USE A COMPUTER
THERE'S NO CELL SIGNAL UP HERE.
I CAN'T USE MASS NOTIFICATION IN
SYSTEM IN THE CAPE PAY VALLEY.
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT LOCAL EMERGENCY
MANAGERS HAVE CONNECTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY WILD LAND.
PLANNING PROCESS TO THE URBAN
FORESTRY.
PLANS THAT ARE NOW INCLUDING
WILDFIRE INFORMATION IN THEM.
COURTESY OF OTHER CAL FIRE
GRANTS ARE ALL GREAT PLANNING
PROCESS SEES.
IF WE HAVE THREE TO FOUR URBAN
FORESTRY PLANS AND THEN FOR
COMMUNITY WHILE FIRE PROTECTION
PLANS.
MY INDUSTRY HAS TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE ALL THOSE PLANS WORK
TOGETHER AND LET THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY KNOW WHERE THE
CROSSOVERS ARE.
IS WE'RE NOT JUST PLANNING FOR
ONE TINY LITTLE CIRCLE OF OUR
JURISDICTIONS THOSE HAZARDS.
IF IT'S WATER IT FLOWS OUTSIDE
OF THE AREA IF IT'S FIRE IT
BURNS WE'VE HAD HISTORICAL FIRES
INYO COUNTY.
THAT OUTPACE THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE VEHICLES ON I FIVE
BECAUSE OF THE WINDS BLOWING
THEM THAT FAST. FOUR OUT OF FOUR
YEARS AND I'VE BEEN EMERGENCY
MANAGER -- WE'VE HAD OUR ANNUAL
FIRE OUTSIDE OF WINTERS MOST
PEOPLE DON'T REMEMBER OUR FIRE
OUR NINETY THOUSAND SQUARE ACRE
FIRE LAST YEAR.
BECAUSE BECAUSE NOBODY DIED AND
NOBODY REALLY LOST A PRIMARY
RESIDENCE BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD A WHAT THEY
CALL A TYPE ONE LEVEL INCIDENT
FOUR OUT OF FOUR YEARS IN YOLO
COUNTY AND IT CROSSED.
INTO NAPA AND SOLANO COUNTIES IN
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
SO EMERGENCY MANAGERS FROM THREE
COUNTIES HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER.
TO MAKE SURE OUR PLANS TO JIVE
LOCKED TOGETHER AND WILL WORK
TOGETHER ESPECIALLY FOR PUSHING
OUR POPULATION INTO.
THE NEIGHBORING COUNTY.
SO THERE THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES I CAN LIST THEM
FOR DAYS IT'S REALLY THAT
INHERENT.
THERE'S SO MUCH GOING ON WE HAVE
DIFFICULTY GETTING THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND IT BECAUSE IT'S VERY
CHALLENGING -- PLANNING.
LANDSCAPE AT THIS POINT THERE'S
LOTS OF THINGS WE NEED THEM TO
DO LOTS OF THINGS WE NEED THEM
TO AND TO SIGN UP FOR MANUALLY --
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE A KIT.
THAT THEY ARE INFORMED THAT THEY
KNOW THEIR PRIMARY EVACUATION
ROUTE AND I CAN GUARANTEE YOU
THAT TONIGHT IN THE CITY OF
WINTERS.
IF THE CHOICE IS TO GO TO MY
CHILD SOCCER GAME FOR MY GRAND
CHILD'S PLAY.
OR COME LISTEN TO THE EMERGENCY
MANAGER OF THE COUNTY TELL ME
WHAT MY PRIORITIZE EVACUATION
ROUTE IS.
THE CHILD AND GRANDCHILD THEY'RE
GOING TO WIN.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S
HEARTFELT AND I'LL TALK TO FOLKS
MORE LATER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR WITH.
SO A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
HI MY NAME'S KEITH WOODS ON THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED THE NORTH
COAST BUILDERS EXCHANGE IF YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT A BUILDER SIX
CHANGES YOUR IN THE MAJORITY OF
MONTHS MOST PEOPLE.
SIMPLY PUT WE'RE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION OF THE ONE I WORK
FOR FOR THE PAST NINETEEN YEARS
REPRESENT SO ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CONTRACTORS
AND PEOPLE ASSOCIATED
CONSTRUCTION.
IN CINEMA MENDOCINO LAKE AND
NAPA FIRESTONE SO WE'VE BEEN
VERY BUSY FOR THE PAST --
EIGHTEEN MONTHS -- THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING -- SHOW YOU
HOW IT TO UNDERSCORE HOW
IMPORTANT I THINK THIS IS THE
CHIU HEAR FROM A REPRESENTATIVE
OF BUILDERS I DO WITH HOME
BUILDERS AND OTHERS.
EVERY DAY OF MY LIFE TO
UNDERSCORE HOW IMPORTANT IT IS I
GAVE AWAY MY WARRIORS ROCKETS
TICKETS TO THE PLAYOFF GAME
TONIGHT -- THERE BY MAKING YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF THE ONLY CURRY
THAT ALL BE IN THE SAME ROOM
WITH -- FOR THE AFTERNOON BUT
IT'S WORTH IT IT'S A PLEASURE TO
TO BE HERE LET ME GET RIGHT TO
THE POINT IN MY LIMITED TIME I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU NOT THE THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT LOOKING DOWN --
THE VISION OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN A REBUILD -- I'M GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
POURING -- FOUNDATIONS AND
HAMMERING NAILS AND GETTING
PEOPLE BACK INTO THEIR HOMES
I'LL MAKE SOME OBSERVATIONS AND
A COUPLE OF SUGGESTIONS ON IF
YOU WANT SOME SPECIFICS ON WHAT.
THOSE OF US THAT ARE IN AND
AROUND THE INDUSTRY THING HOW --
WAITS AT THE STATE COULD HELP
ALL OF BRING THOSE TO YOU --
IT'S BEEN A DICKENSIAN PASSED --
EIGHTEEN MONTHS IT'S BEEN THE
BEST OF TIMES AND THE WORST OF
TIMES THE WORST OF TIMES IS VERY
CLEAR WE HAD -- IN FOR COUNTY
AREA SEVEN THOUSAND PLUS HOMES
DESTROYED ANOTHER COUPLE
THOUSAND BILL OF BUSINESSES AND
OTHER BUILDINGS AND IT'S JUST
BEEN LIKE NOTHING I COULD HAVE
EVER IMAGINED HAPPENING.
AND I COULDN'T IMAGINE ANYTHING
WORSE UNTIL OUR FRIENDS IN
PARADISE I WENT THROUGH WHAT
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH DOT
ALLOWING EVERY OUT A PROBLEM
THAT WE HAD IT ALMOST
UNIMAGINABLE NUMBER OF US FROM
THE NORTH BAY BEEN OVER -- TO
CHICO IN PARADISE TO TRY AND
HELP OUT AN ADVISE WHAT WE
LEARNED AND I GO BACK BOTH
HARDENED AND DISHEARTENED THE
WORST OF IT IS SPEND THE
DEVASTATION THE PERSONAL TOLD
IT'S TAKEN.
ON US SO MANY FAMILIES IN CENTER --
SO WE'RE WE'RE HEADQUARTERED NOW
CENTER ROSE ALONE WE LOST AROUND
FIFTY THREE HUNDRED MAKE THAT
CINEMA COUNTY THREE THOUSAND
PLUS IN SANTA ROSA DEVASTATION
LIKE YOU CAN IMAGINE TO YOU'VE
DRIVEN THROUGH IT.
FLOWN OVER OR SEEN EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENED -- AS A SIDE
NOTE OF IN THE GOOD THINGS THAT
HAVE COME OUT OF IT IS THE UNITY
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
OUR COMMUNITY CAN COME TOGETHER
NEIGHBORS HELPING NEIGHBORS WHO.
EITHER LOST OR DID LOSE THEIR
HOME -- PUBLIC OFFICIALS THE
MEDIA BUILDING COMMUNITY THE
BEST OF ALL OF THIS IS BEEN THE
THE UNITY AND I I COULDN'T.
I COULDN'T BE HERE WITHOUT
SINGLING OUT A SENATORS MCGUIRE
AND DODD AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM
WOOD FOR THE YEOMAN WORK IF THEY
DID -- TIRELESSLY IN TRYING TO
HELP COORDINATE -- EFFORTS TO
REBUILD AND BRING -- THE POWER
OF THE STATE TO THE LOCAL LEVER
TO HELP US OUT SO I I WANTED TO
SINGLE THEM OUT -- YOU KNOW --
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU A FEW POINTS ON
AND WHAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING THAT
MIGHT GIVE YOU THE FLAVOR OF IT
FROM WORKERS AND SOMEWHAT
STACCATO FASHION HERE -- NO
POINTS I WANT TO MAKE -- ONE THE
MAGNITUDE OF THIS DISASTER IS AT
THE ROOT OF EVERYONE OF OUR
REBUILDING PROBLEMS OR EIGHTEEN
MONTHS INTO THIS SO WE'RE LESS
THAN 20% FAR LESS THAN 20%
REBUILD WITH PEOPLE IN.
A BY THE TIME WE GET TO THE FIVE
YEAR MARK WILL PROBABLY HAVE 60%
PLUS OF HOMES TO REBUILD OR
BUILT FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT.
TO FEMA TOLD ME WHEN I WAS
WORKING AT THE FEMA CENTER RIGHT
AFTER THE FIRES ON A STE
NATIONWIDE ON ANY A NATIONAL
DISASTER MAJOR DISASTER. 435% OF
PEOPLE DON'T REBUILD FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS WELL I'VE
TALKED TO HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF BUILDERS AND LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF FIRE VICTIMS IN
MEETINGS AT NIGHTS AND ON
WEEKENDS.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
HELP THEM AND I'M GOING TO GUESS
THAT 40% OF OUR PEOPLE PROBABLY
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS ARE NOT
GOING TO REBUILD.
AND THE STATE REALLY NEED
UNDERSTAND OF HOUSEHOLDS SERIES
OF AN ISSUE THIS IS FOR A
COMMUNITY TO LOSE THAT MANY
PEOPLE -- THE SANTA ROSA JUNIOR
COLLEGE A CLOSE FOR TWO WEEKS
AFTER THE FIRES -- IN OCTOBER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHEN THEY OPEN
THEY WERE A THOUSAND STUDENT
SHORT WHO WOULD DISAPPEAR -- THE
CENTER OF THE CITY SCHOOLS LAW
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY STUDENTS
WHO DID NOT COME BACK TO CLASS
AND THE TOLL THAT TAKES ON THE
COMMUNITY IS STANDING.
UP FOR BUILDERS OF THE MAGNITUDE
OF THIS PROBLEM -- I NEED TO
GIVE YOU A FACTOID THERE WERE
MORE IN IN THE FIRE IF WE
EXPERIENCE THERE WERE MORE HOMES
AND BUSINESSES DESTROYED THEN
THERE ARE LICENSED CONTRACTORS.
SO IF YOU WONDER WHY WILL ALWAYS
TAKE OR IN MY MIND HALF A DECADE
TO A DECADE FOR US TO LOOK
ANYWHERE NEAR WHAT WE LOOK LIKE
BEFORE IT'S BECAUSE IT'S SIMPLY
NOT THE CONTRACTORS AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE WORKERS.
THE THE IT'S CALLED GREAT
PROBLEMS I WILL GIVE A ALSO
CREDIT TO THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD -- THEY HAVE BEEN
VERY HELPFUL IN ACCELERATING
TRAINING FOR NEW CONTRACTORS THE
LICENSING OF NEW CONTRACTOR TO
GET THEM -- ELIGIBLE TO BE DOING
THE WORK BECAUSE WE NEED THEM --
ON A REALLY BADLY AND THEY
THEY'VE BEEN A GREAT HELP ON THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY WAS BUSY
BEFORE THE FIRE SO THEIR BODY
UNDERSTANDS EVERYONE WAS BUSY.
DURING A RECESSION WELL
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY LOST HALF
OF ITS PAYROLL HALF OF
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WERE NO
LONGER CONSTRUCTION WORKERS AT
THE END OF THE RECESSION THEY
WENT ON TO DO OTHER THINGS SO WE
WERE STRAPPED.
AND IT HAS CAUSED GREAT DELAYS
ON OUR PART NOT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO BUILD BUT THEY
CONTRACTORS HAVE PEOPLE LINED UP
WHO WANT TO GET THEIR HOMES
BUILT.
AND WE DON'T HAVE THE WORKERS TO
ACCOMMODATE THEM POINT NUMBER
TWO BESIDES A SHORTAGE OF
CONTRACTORS BUT GENERAL AND SUBS --
I MENTIONED THERE ARE NO WHERE
NEAR ENOUGH WORKERS THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKER YOU SHORTAGE
THAT YOU HEAR ABOUT IS VERY
RELIGIOUS NON MANUFACTURED AT
ALL WE LOST SO MANY OF THEM
DURING THE RECESSION.
WE'RE TRYING TO REGENERATE
OURSELVES HOW CAN STATE
GOVERNMENT HELP -- I I CAN
ADVISE YOU ANYTHING YOU CAN DO
WITH CP PROGRAMS CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION CONSTRUCTION
PROGRAMS STATE A APPRENTICESHIPS
PROGRAM THROUGH THE UNIONS FOR
THE GREAT TRAINING THAT THEY DO
ANYTHING THAT YOU CAN -- SUPPORT
THAT -- LEADS TO MORE WORKERS
WILL ACCELERATE NOT ONLY IN
PARADISE BUT IN MENDOCINO CINEMA
LAKE AND NAPA COUNTY AS WELL
WE'RE GROWING OUR OWN THAT ARE
BUILDERS EXCHANGE WE GOT A GRANT --
FOR TO EXPAND WHAT WE HAVE IS A
PROGRAM ON NORTH BAY
CONSTRUCTION CORPS WHERE A
TAKING HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS SO
WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
CONSTRUCTION THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH A FOURTEEN WEEK PROGRAM
ONE NIGHT A WEEK ONE SATURDAY.
AND THEN A TWO WEEK BOOT CAMP
WHETHER OUT ON A PROJECT AND WE
FIGURED OUT AS I INTERVIEW --
BUILDERS HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF THEM THE ONLY WAY WE CAN GET
NEW WORKERS WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO
MOVE INTO THE AREA IS GROW OUR
OWN SO WE'RE GONNA PUT OUT ON
THE MARKET PLACE.
UNDER THAN FIFTY POTENTIALLY
SHARP YOUNG NEW WORKERS WHO ARE
PHENOMENAL A READY TO GO SO WE
CAN DO THOSE SORTS OF THINGS I
CAN TELL YOU IS A BY ANOTHER
POINT.
WHAT WE LEARNED IS A PROJECT OF
A BUILDING PROJECT LIKE IS
HAPPENING IN THE NORTH BAY
DOESN'T FIT A BUILDER'S NORMAL
MODEL?
YET LET ME EXPLAIN THAT A
BUILDER'S HIRED BY A DEVELOPER
THE DEVELOPER HAS TEN ACRES --
TWENTY ACRES THEY WANNA BUILD A
DEVELOPMENT OF A HUNDRED FIFTY
HOMES SO THEY CONTROLLED
ENVIRONMENT THEY THEY BY THE
LAND THEY PUT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILDERS BUILD A
HOMES THEY MARKET THEM THEY SELL
WOMAN THEY LEAVE.
THIS DOESN'T FIT IN PARADISE OR
IN OUR AREA ANY BUILDING PROJECT
MODEL THAT ANY OF THE PEOPLE I
REPRESENT WORK WITH HAS EVER
EXPERIENCED THEY NOW HAVE FIVE
THOUSAND DIFFERENT DEVELOPERS.
AND THEY'RE NOT USED TO BUILDING
A HOME OVER THERE THEN MOVE
THEIR CREW BILL HOME OVER THERE
THERE THERE AND THERE IT IS
THROWN US FOR A LOOP.
AND COFFEE PARK THIRTEEN HUNDRED
HOMES WERE LOST THESE ARE THE
EASY BUILD SIX THOUSAND SQUARE
FOOT LOTS OF WITH -- THAT ARE
FLAT EASIER TO BUILD ON AND
THERE AREN'T ANY GIVEN TIME A
HUNDRED OR MORE DIFFERENT
CONTRACTORS AND WORKERS ROAMING
AROUND THE STREETS AND AND
TRAFFIC CLOGGING UP WITH TRUCKS.
THE COORDINATION ANYTHING THE
STATE CAN DO TO HELP A
COORDINATE THINGS LIKE HIS AND
IT'S PROBABLY MORE LOCAL BUT BE
AWARE OF THE SERIOUS PROBLEM
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO DEVELOP IN
AN AREA THAT'S ENTIRELY.
DIFFERENT THAN A MAJOR PROJECT
MY LAST COUPLE POINTS BEST THING
FOR HOME BUILDERS IN THE
FAMILIES ARE HELPING IS OF FAST
TRACKING -- I GIVE SUCH CREDIT
TO OUR CITY OF SANTA ROSA IN
PARTICULAR COUNTY OF CINNAMON
PERMITS CINEMA THEY UP TO THEIR
GAME.
THEY STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE
INSTEAD OF THE SIX OR NINE
MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS TO GET A
PERMIT FOR SOME STRUCTURES AND
HOMES.
IT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER I BY
KATE GORDON I THINK FIVE DAYS IS
THEIR GOAL THEY'VE BEEN
INUNDATED IN THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS SINCE THAT TWO YEAR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE FROM INSURANCE
COMPANIES.
RUNS OUT IN OCTOBER SO THERE'S A
TSUNAMI OF PERMIT APPLICATIONS
THAT'S BEEN COMING IN THE
REBUILD LOOKS LIKE A HOCKEY
STICK IT WAS FLAT FOR SIX MONTHS
AND FOR LAST SIX MONTHS TWO
YEARS JUST SPIKED UP.
AND THE CITY AND THE COUNTY HAVE
DONE WONDERFUL WORK AND I GIVE
THEM A FULL CREDIT BOTTOM LINE --
THE BUILDERS ARE THERE AND READY
TO GO IT'S THE WORKERS --
SHORTAGE THAT'S HOLDING THINGS
UP AND NOT THE PERMITTING IT'S
AROUND TEN TO TWELVE DAYS NOW TO
GET A PERMIT AND BUILDERS AND
FAMILIES ARE JUST ECSTATIC AT
THE AT THE CHANGE THE PROBLEM
FOR US CITY IN A COUNTY IS --
THE BUILDING DEPARTMENTS WHICH
MISTER -- MY FRIEND PETE
PARKINSON USED TO HAD NOW WE
KNOW THEY CAN ACTUALLY DO THAT
YEAH YOU KNOW AND SO NOW WE I'VE
TALKED TO TENNIS WHERE IN.
THE BUILDING OFFICIALS GENERAL'S
WE WANT THEM TO LIFT UP THEIR
BEST PRACTICES DURING THE
REBUILD AND MAKE IT AVAILABLE
FOR THE OTHER HOUSING THAT WE DO
NEED.
A WRAP UP AND LET ME STRING TAKE
OVER HERE IN A MOMENT WHAT I'D
LIKE OUT OF YOU I HOPE YOU WILL
PROVIDE FUNDING TO THESE CASH
STRAPPED GOVERNMENTS. TO HELP
THEM ADD STAFFING FOR PERMITTING.
THE THEY GET YEAH THEY'RE
STRETCHED THIN AND THE BEST
THING YOU COULD DO IS SAY WE'VE
GOT A LITTLE -- STASH HERE THE
WERE WILLING TO GIVE YOU TO HIRE
MORE PEOPLE OR OUT SOURCE THE
PERMITTING SO THAT WE CAN GET
THIS MOVING ISN'T JUST FOR THE
BUILDER SYSTEMS FOR THE FIRE
VICTIMS. TO HAVE EMERGENCY
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR SPECIAL
PROGRAMS THAT YOU MIGHT NOT EVEN
THINK OF WE REALIZE RIGHT AWAY
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF A
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS LOST EVERY
TOOL THEY'VE GOT -- CONTRACTORS
DID SO -- OUR ORGANIZATION TO
BUILDERS EXCHANGE -- WE CREATED
A TOOL REPLACEMENT PROGRAM WE
GOT A QUARTER MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF DONATIONS AND OF TOOLS
HELD OPEN HOUSE AND TRIED TO GET
THEM BACK TO WITH THE TOOLS OF
THEIR TRADE.
SOMETIMES WE COULD HAVE DONE
MORE IF WE HAD A LITTLE BIT MORE
FUNDING TO LEVERAGE THAT FUNDING
TO BUY MORE TOOLS TO PROVIDE
PEOPLE -- THREE CAREFULLY REVIEW
IT WAS BROUGHT UP EARLIER PLEASE
CAREFULLY REVIEW ALL THE CODES
CHANGES AND UPGRADES THAT ARE
BROUGHT TO YOU -- THEY'RE ALL
GREAT A BY ENERGY EFFICIENCY
FIRE RESISTANT MATERIALS --
DEFENSIBLE SPACE THIS IS ALL
GREAT BUT THERE'S A REAL PRICE
TAG THAT GOES WITH THIS AND WE
MAY NOT HAVE IT BOTH WAYS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND ALL THE CODE CHANGES THAT
I'M NOT ARGUING AGAINST BUT
PLEASE CAREFULLY REVIEW THEM ONE
OF OUR BUILDERS TOOK THE SAME
HOME BE BUILT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX IN COFFEE PART FIFTEEN
HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT THREE
BEDROOM TWO BATH.
AND HE PRICED OUT WHAT IT WOULD
BE IF HE REFILL TODAY WITHOUT
ALL OF CODE CHANGES AND IT ADDED
ONE HUNDRED AND TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO THE COST OF
REBUILDING THAT HOME.
AGAIN I'M NOT ARGUING ABOUT
THOUGH AND AND NECESSITY OF
THESE CODES BUT PLEASE BE VERY
VERY HELPFUL OF FINALLY IN PROSE
OF THE POST A DISASTER --
PROVIDE ALL OF FUNDING THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
NEEDS FOR INSPECTORS BEEN
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS BECAUSE WE
HELD A MEETING THE OTHER NIGHT
FOR A BUYER'S REMORSE FOR PEOPLE
IT GOT SCREWED BY UNSCRUPULOUS
UNLICENSED CONTRACTORS.
WHO THE CSO BE HAS BEEN A GREAT
AT FERRETING THEM OUT BUT ANY
MONEY THEY NEED TO GET --
ENFORCEMENT IN THERE IT'LL SAVE
PEOPLE ALL WHOLE LOT OF TROUBLE
AND A LOT OF MONEY IN THE LONG
TERM.
FINALLY I GUESS THE STATE.
COULD GENERATE A LOT OF GOOD
WILL WITH A SIZEABLE
CONTRIBUTION TO THE KEITH WOODS
RETIREMENT FUND I THINK THIS IS
A WORTHY CAUSE SAID YOU MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER THANK YOU FOR
LET ME HAVE MY TIME HERE TODAY
IT'S THAT IMPORTANT TO ME TO BE
HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER WOODS.
I WELCOME MR RING.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN
MY NAME'S BRIAN REGAN THIS ISN'T
CHAU WITH THAT YOU COUNTY SO THE
MUCH CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME HERE I
THOUGHT I WOULD FIRST.
JUST GIVE YOU ALL A BRIEF UPDATE
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN UP TO TO THE TOWN AND
THAT THE COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY
THE FIRE AND I TAX OR ONE OF THE
SUSPECTS EXPRESS MY THANKS.
TO SOME GALLAGHER IS BEEN UP
THERE AND HOW MANY BUT BY EVERY
DAY JUST ABOUT -- IN -- FOR ALL
THE EFFORTS HE'S PUT IN --
HELPING TO REBUILD OUR COMMUNITY
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THIS
QUICK AT THIS IT'S HARDLY IT'S
BEEN SIX MONTHS TODAY IT'S AFTER
UNBELIEVABLE BUT A LITTLE BIT OF
GOOD NEWS ABOUT IT START OUT
WITH IS THERE ARE THE DEBRIS
MISSION IS IN FULL SWING THERE'S
OVER A HUNDRED FORTY CRUISE UP
THERE.
WITH OUR STATE -- THE STATE
CONTRACTORS CALLAWAY -- YES
PROGRAM AND THEY'RE DOING SOME
TREMENDOUS WORK -- AT AS OF THIS
MORNING THERE WAS OVER TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED LOTS THAT HAVE BEEN
NOW CLEANED.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED WHICH IS A
PRETTY PRESS OF OF OF THERE'S
OVER THIRTEEN THOUSAND LOTS THAT
WERE DESTROYED -- WITH THAT OVER
FIVE HUNDRED PROPERTIES HAVE
BEEN [inaudible]
CLEARED SO.
IT'S TECHNICAL IS CLEAN AND IT'S
CLEAR THESE FOR OVER FIVE
HUNDRED PROPERTIES CAN ACTUALLY
NOW START TO REBUILD PROCESS OF
THAT SO I THINK IT IT'S SOME
POSITIVE NEWS FOR THE COMMUNITY --
STILL LOTS OF WORK TO DO
TRANSBAIKALIA NEXT TOUCH ON A
LITTLE BIT IS SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN AS FAR AS
CHALLENGES GO TO HAVEN'T
DISCUSSED YET HERE TODAY THAT I
KNOW SOMEONE GALLAGHER IS VERY
VERY WELL AWARE OF BUT I THINK
IT SHOULD BE ON EVERYONE'S.
MIND -- FOR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
IMPACTED IN A WAY SIMILAR TO THE
WAY THAT -- YOU COUNTY WAS
IMPACTED.
THERE'S THREE OR FOUR
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES.
BEYOND HOUSING HOUSING CERTAINLY
IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE BOTH
INFORMALITY IN IN PERMANENT
HOUSING.
COUPLE OF THINGS RIGHT NOW THAT
WE REALLY ARE DOING WITH THIS IS
A TREES.
NO WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN YOU HAVE
A COMMUNITY THAT IS NOW --
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY THAT NEED
TO NEED SOME PROCESS A MECHANISM
TO BE REMOVED.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES THE TREES WE HAVE
TREES THAT ARE ON PUBLIC RIGHT
AWAY WE HAVE A GOOD PROCESS TO
DEAL WITH THOSE PUBLIC TRIP
PUBLICLY OWNED MAINTAIN TREES
BUT HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND TREES
ON PRIVATE PROPERTY THE IMPACT
RIGHT AWAY.
COULD POSSIBLY IMPEDE AND FALL
ON A NEIGHBOR'S PROPERTY --
SOLUTIONS JUST OUR WORD THERE'S
NOT A CLEAR SOLUTION FOR THAT
RIGHT NOW AND WE'RE WORKING
DILIGENTLY ON THAT TRYING TO
TRYING TO RESOLVE THAT SO THAT'S
THAT'S ONE ISSUE I THINK SHOULD
BE ON EVERYONE'S MIND. FOR FOR
FUTURE POTENTIAL DISASTERS.
ALSO ROADS -- WHEN YOU HAVE SO
MUCH?
CONSTRUCTION AND HEAVY TRUCKS
GOING ON ROADS MANY OF OUR ROADS
ARE JUST SIMPLY DETERIORATING ON
THEIRS AND IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
KEEP UP THEY WEREN'T -- I WANTED
WERE DESIGNED TO HAVE HAVE YOU
THOUGHT THEY WERE DESIGNED HAVE
HEAVY TRUCK ON THEM BUT PROBABLY
NOT HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
TRUCKS A DAY -- THE WEAR AND
TEAR INTO THESE ROADS ARE IS
TREMENDOUS AND ON I KNOW WE'VE
WRITTEN SOME LETTERS AND WE
NEEDS WE NEED SOME SUPPORT HERE
BECAUSE ONE ACCESS ROAD WHERE
ARE LANDFILLS AT RIGHT NOW IS
LITERALLY -- ITS NEW ROAD GOING
UP BUT FROM NINETY NINE UP TO
PARADISE IT IS THERE'S SPOTS
WHERE IT'S ALMOST TRINITY GRAVEL
SO IT'S IT'S PRETTY BAD.
THE WATER SITUATION I KNOW IS
VERY WELL KNOWN BOTH IN PARADISE
IN IN THE IN A CORPORATE AREA --
CERTAINLY THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
ISSUE THAT IS HIGH ON OUR
PRIORITY LIST TO MAKE SURE WE
CAN -- HAVE WATER SYSTEMS
PROVIDING CLEAN WATER TO OUR
RESIDENTS BECAUSE TO BE A KEY
AND CRITICAL COMPONENT BEFORE
THE COMMUNITIES TRULY BEGAN. TO
REBUILD SO THOSE ARE A FEW
THINGS BEYOND JUST THE THE
ENTRANT HOUSING IN THE IN THE
PERMANENT HOUSING THAT I WANTED
AT LEAST HIGHLIGHT AND PUT ON
THE RECORD FOR FOR FUTURE --
GENERATIONS.
AS FAR AS PLANNING GOES YOU KNOW
I THINK.
I THOUGHT I'D LIKE TO THINK YOU
COUNTY WAS PRETTY PREPARED -- I
THINK THE TEN A PARADISE TODAY I
HAD A VERY ACTIVE FIRE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND THEY HAD
EVACUATION ROUTES IN THE AND IS
THAT A LOT OF WORK.
AND FORTUNATE WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF FIRE SMALL MUCH SMALLER FIRES
OVER THE YEARS WHERE WE'VE HAD A
PRETTY EFFECTIVE LEADERSHIP TEAM
AND MERGE OPERATIONS CENTER AND
WERE PRETTY PREPARED BUT TO SO
MANY DOLLARS POINT THIS IS.
PROBABLY A ONCE IN A LIFETIME
FIRE ALL THE THE PERFECT
CONDITIONS FOR A CRITICAL FIRE
LINED UP IN IN IT HAPPENED --
BUT WITH THAT SAID SOME THINGS
THAT THAT I LIKE TO RECOMMEND
FOR OTHER ENTITIES TO THINK
ABOUT IN THE FUTURE.
IF YOU'RE IN A BIT HIGH HAZARD
AREA OR JUST ANY YEARS IS I
THINK.
THINKING AHEAD AND KNOWING WHAT
YOUR INVENTORY IS LIFE AS FAR AS
HOUSING GOES -- WHAT KIND OF
PROPERTIES DO YOU HAVE WITH THE
PRIVATELY OWNED OR PUBLICLY
OWNED WHAT TYPE OF PROPERTIES AT
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THEM?
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY IF YOU IF YOU
ENCOUNTER DISASTER SUCH AS THIS
FINDING.
AVAILABLE PROPERTY TO PUT
MANUFACTURED HOMES TEMPORARY
HOUSING ON IT'S BEEN A
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE WE'RE SIX
MONTHS INTO THIS AND WE'RE STILL
I THINK WE'RE GONNA GET OUR
FIRST MH YOU ON SITE I BELIEVE
MANUFACTURED HOUSING UNIT FROM
FEMA.
TOMORROW OR LATER THIS WEEK SO.
SIX MONTHS AND WHEN WE'RE STILL
STRUGGLING WITH THAT AND YOU
KNOW IT.
I CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH FEMA AND
YES HAVE BEEN GREAT PARTNERS BUT
THERE'S JUST CHALLENGES.
THAT IF YOU CAN DO SOME FORWARD
THINKING PLAN AHEAD I THINK
WOULD HELP US IN A HELP INTO
THESE IN THE FUTURE SO.
AGAIN IDENTIFY PROPERTIES
POTENTIAL RENTAL CAPACITY AGAIN
WE ARE IN A COMMUNITY WITHIN
THAT HAD NEXT AND WE WERE PRETTY
FULL CAPACITIES OF ALL THIS AND
YOU HAVE. FIFTY THOUSAND FOLKS
EVACUATED YET FOURTEEN HOME
THOUSAND HOMES LOST -- WHERE
PEOPLE GO IT'S IT'S IT'S A
CHALLENGE -- SO IDENTIFIED ANY.
ALTERNATIVE -- LOCATIONS WITHIN
YOUR COMMUNITY OR YOUR
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY A LOT OF
OUR FOLKS WANT TO STAY WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITY WANT TO STAY THERE
THEIR KIDS ARE IN SCHOOL THEY'RE
INVESTED IN THE COMMUNITY LEVEL
LIVING UP THERE THEY HAVE JOBS
UP THERE SO.
ANYTHING WITHIN THE COMMUTER
WILL DISTANCE I WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT ENTITIES LOOK AT TRY TO
IDENTIFY OPTIONS WORK IF YOU
HAVE A DISASTER EVEN A SMALLER
SCALE WORKING PEOPLE.
TEMPORARILY RESIDES HE CAN.
KIND OF GET THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
IN THOSE MAYBE PUT IN PLACE IN
ADVANCE.
THE BIG THING I THINK WOULD BE --
AT THE VERY BEGINNING OF HIS
AFTER SITTING DOWN WITH MORE
WITH FEMA AND CAL WE **** AND
TALK ABOUT LAND USE.
RULES REGULATIONS THE POLITICAL
CLIMATE THE APTITUDE THIS DISC
ALL THE THINGS THAT ARE UNIQUE
TO YEARS PARTICULAR JURISDICTION
AS WELL I THINK WOULD GO A LONG
WAYS -- AGAIN EVERYONE IS TRYING
TO DO THEIR BEST BUT WHEN YOU'RE
IN A MESS THE THE SITUATION THAT
YOU'RE IN -- GET WAS ONE THING I
THINK WE COULD HAVE DONE A
LITTLE BETTER IS SET DOWN WITH
EVERYBODY IS ABLE ONE TIME AND
IDENTIFY.
YOU KNOW JUST WHAT SOME OF THE
THE ROAD BLOCKS MIGHT BE WITH
WITH REGARDS -- TO HEALTHY
OBVIOUS IF YOU COUNTY
AGRICULTURE IS A VERY VERY VERY
BIG.
A COMPONENT OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
AND THAT'S IT IT'S REALLY
PROTECTED LAND THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE WE WOULD WANT TO
BUT HOUSING ON AND CERTAINLY
THERE'S ENOUGH JEN AT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE SO IT'S YOU
KNOW YOU GOT AND YOU HAVE TO
KNOW THESE THINGS WHEN YOU'RE
COMING INTO COMMUNITY.
OKAY WORK WE PUT UP ALL THESE
PEOPLE ARE REPURPOSE HOW'S IT
THERE'S THERE'S CERTAIN THINGS
THAT ARE JUST UNIQUE TO EACH
COMMUNITY -- AND I THINK ALSO
EDUCATING YEAR.
YOUR GOVERNING BODIES IN YOUR
RESIDENCE YOU KNOW WE'VE SIX
MONTHS INTO THIS SOME PEOPLE YOU
KNOW ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
IMPACTED NOT ONLY JUST A TOWN OF
PARADISE AND COUNTY IN OR BILL
AND ALL THE BIG GREATLY -- CHICO
WE HAVE A LOT WE HAVE CHICO
HADLEY FIFTEEN TO NINETEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE COME TO THEIR
COMMUNITY OVERNIGHT SO.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT ABOUT
OBVIOUSLY SERVICE LEVELS GO UP
THERE'S THERE'S MUCH MORE
TRAFFIC -- AND YOU KNOW WHAT WE
NEED TO LIVE WITH THAT IT'S IT'S
GOING TO BE THAT WAY WE WE HAVE
TO SUPPORT OUR OUR SURVIVORS UP
THERE AND WE HAVE TO REALIZE
THAT IT JUST.
BUT THERE ARE TRAFFIC ISSUES OR
SEWER ISSUES JUST WHEN IT WHEN
IT TOWN ABSORBS SO MANY PEOPLE
SO QUICKLY THAT YOU HAVE.
TO YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT --
ANY ZONING ISSUES I THINK IT
WOULD RECOMMEND ENTITIES LOOK AT
YOU KNOW AGAIN WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT HOW YOU CAN -- GET
TEMPORARY HOUSING IN YOUR
COMMUNITY WE'VE PASSED A NUMBER
OF URGENCY ORDINANCES SO IF YOU
DO A SOME OF THAT ON A FRIEND
AND IT MIGHT HELP YOU.
TRY TO MAKE IT UP AS YOU GO AS
WE'VE BEEN DOING IT THANKFULLY
WE'VE HAD GREAT PARTNERS
UNFORTUNATELY FROM TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FIRES HAVE BEEN
TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL. FOR US AND
AND AND AND LEARNING FROM THEM
BUT I THINK DOING THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL -- BEYOND THAT I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW AS FAR AS YOU KNOW
NEEDS OF OF OF AREAS.
THAT ARE SIMILAR TO VIEW COUNTY
OR JUST YOU KNOW EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS YOU KNOW WE
WE ALL NOWADAYS RELY ON
TECHNOLOGY SO MUCH TELEPHONE
CELL PHONES INTERNET -- SOME
FOLKS ESPECIALLY HER THIS
EARLIER IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
THEY ARE IN REAL COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE TETHERED
TO A CELL PHONE -- SO WE HAVE TO
BE COGNIZANT OF THAT I THINK
EFFORTS IN PROVIDING NUMBERS TO
LOCATION SYSTEMS THAT ARE TED
TETHERED TO TECHNOLOGY IS GOING
TO BE SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES NEED TO LOOK AT
BEYOND THAT I THINK WE'VE --
WE'VE A LOT OF OTHER LESSONS
LEARNED AND WE CONTINUE TO LEARN
THROUGH FEMALE YES I THINK AGAIN
WE'RE STILL KIND OF IN RESPONSE
STAGE FRANKLY WE STILL HAVE OVER
FIFTY OR SIXTY FAMILIES AND NINE
HUNDRED HOUSING CHILDREN RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE PLACES
FOR THEM TO GO YET.
SO -- WE'RE LEARNING AND WE'RE
TAKING NOTES AND WE'LL BE HAPPY
TO SHARE OTHER LESSONS LEARNED
AS WE CONTINUE THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL YOUR
TESTIMONY -- FIRST OF ALL I FEEL
LIKE EVERY LIVING WHAT I WENT
THROUGH I HAD. FIVE FIVE I'M IN
THREE THREE YEARS OF FIRES AND
FIVE MY COUNTIES -- AND I STILL
HAVE PEOPLE IN LAKE COUNTY AND
HOME.
AND THERE'S SO MANY PIECES TO
THIS IS THE YOU KNOW YOU CAN
POINT FINGERS AT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED THE FACT THE MATTER IS
WE GOT TO GET BETTER AT IT.
AND I AT MY ARM I FEEL SO SORRY
FOR YOU BECAUSE I'LL NEVER
FORGET WHERE I WAS WHEN I GOT
THE PHONE CALL FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER WHAT CAN YOU
HELP ME DO.
EVERYONE I JUST LIVE RELIVED IT
NICE TO TAKE A DEEP BREATH THE
PEOPLE GONNA COME HELP.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE YOUR FACES
ON THE FRONT OF ALL YOUR
COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE THEY KNOW
HOW STRONG YOU ARE IN THE YOU'RE
WORKING AS A TEAM.
AND LUCKILY WE WERE REALLY
BLESSED WITH HAVING INCREDIBLE
TEAMMATES AS THEY ALSO REGISTRY
SERVICES TEAM OF THE CITY'S THE
COUNTIES EVERYBODY COMES AND
HELPS WHEN YOU NEED IT.
BUT THESE THINGS LIKE YOU SAY IS
LIKE IT'S FRUSTRATING TO ME IS
LIKE WHEN YOU SEE THE TREE
REMOVAL -- YEAH THE BEEN THERE
DONE THAT WE REALLY WORKED HARD
TRYING THINKING AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER TRYING
TO THINK OF WAYS WE CAN GET OUR
TIMBER OUT THERE.
IF IT'S NOT TIMBER WHAT ABOUT
THE ACT WASTE SO WE'RE ALWAYS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THAT.
YOU KNOW THE RATE ROSE TO TERRY
I SAW ROADS ARE STILL BECAUSE OF
ALL THE TRAFFIC THE TRUCK
TRAFFIC TO MOVE THAT -- DEBRIS --
HOW DO YOU FIX THAT HOW YOU
DOING THE TIMELY MATTER HOW DO
YOU MAKE SURE THAT YOU STILL
GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO BUILD HOMES IN THOSE AREAS
AND GET IT IN AND OUT OF A --
MODULAR HOMES MOBILE HOMES
TRYING TO FIND OUT WHERE YOU
GONNA PUT THEM HAVING FEWER
WHERE YOU I MEAN ALL THOSE
THINGS YOU DON'T THINK ABOUT.
AS A COMMON ELECTED OFFICIALS.
UNTIL YOU ARE FACED WITH IT AND
SO I'VE HAD MY LAKE FIRES OF IN
MY CINEMA FIRES I'VE HAD MY NAPA
FIRES.
I FEEL LIKE I COULD ALMOST
HEALTHY YOU KNOW DESIGN A PLAN
NOT THAT I WANT -- TO BUT YOU
KNOW AND THE OTHER ONE IS IS
REALLY HARD TO WEAR THE PEOPLE
THE WHERE DID OUR RESIDENTS GO
TO LIVE IN THAT AREA I WISH I
HAD A DATABASE OF LIKE I SAID AS
WHO WAS THERE AND WHERE THEY GO.
AND ARE THEY SAFE OR HOW DID
THEY DID OR THE LIVING WITH
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS -- ARE THEY
LIVING IN CHICO -- ALL THOSE
IMPACTS YOU JUST DON'T REALLY
THINK ABOUT UNTIL YOU ARE FACED
WITH THIS TERRIBLE --
EXPERIENCES.
SO -- WITH THAT I I HAVE A
COMMON I ALSO WANT TO SAY TO
MISCARRY SO I GET COME I GET
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE I KNOW WHERE
YOU'RE COMING WITH WITH
COMPETITION FUNDING.
AND I THINK -- MISTER GALLAGHER
IS PUTTING IN THE FACE THIS
EXACT SAME THING IS BECAUSE SOME.
I NEED TO FIND OUT AND I'M GOING
TO DO THIS FOR YOU TO FIND OUT
WHAT THE ACTUAL -- FORMULA IT IS
TO COMPETE.
WHAT IS IT THE WHY IS THE WE ARE
NOT GETTING?
THE OF FUNDING IN SOME OF OUR
RURAL AREAS.
AND I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
WE'VE HAD OTHER THINGS ALONG THE
WAY THAT I'M.
IN WHETHER IT'S EDUCATION HEALTH
CARE AND FUNDING AND THAT WE ARE
UNABLE TO COMPETE BECAUSE THEY
CONSIDER SOME OF OUR AREAS ARE
MORE IN SUBURBAN AREAS.
WHEN WE'RE REALLY IN A RURAL
AREA COMPETING WITH LARGER
COMMUNITIES?
SO AND IF I MAY JUST RESPONDED
THAT REALLY QUICKLY I WOULD LIKE
TO THROW OUT THERE THAT YOLO IS
INCREDIBLY PROGRESSIVE IN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
WE'VE GOTTEN BACKING FROM ALL
FOUR CITY COUNCILS AND THE
COUNTY BOARD AND THE A TO DO HE
WENT TO NATION. TO GO AFTER THE
INTERNATIONAL STANDARD FOR
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
ACCREDITATION BEEN WORKING
TOWARDS IT FOR FIVE YEARS.
SO THE FACT THAT IT'S HARD FOR
US.
JUST REALLY KIND OF SETS THAT
STAGE THAT WE'RE WE'RE PRETTY
GOOD AT THIS THERE'S A LOT OF
SMALLER COUNTIES THAT WE HELP
AND ADVISE WE SENT.
A NUMBER OF YEARS HE PERSONNEL
UP TO THE PARADISE YOU SEE
DURING THE THANKSGIVING WEEKEND
AND EVERYTHING.
AND THEY'RE NOT AT THE SAME
LEVEL WHERE AT AND THEY FACE THE
SAME CHALLENGE RIGHT
[inaudible]
SO -- THERE'S SO MUCH THIS HERE
IN THE ALL THE TESTAMENT TO THEY
IS JUST BEEN -- OPENS UP A WOUND
THAT I FEEL LIKE I STILL HAVE
FROM ALL THE FIRES -- THE LABOR
ISSUES.
FROM DAY.
ONE WE HAD PEOPLE THAT WERE
TRYING TO BUILD HOMES IN LAKE
COUNTY AND AFTER THE FIRES WENT
THROUGH IN -- SANTA ROSA.
THEY LEFT THE AREA LAKE COUNTY
AND WENT TO WHERE THEY GET TO DO
MORE WORK IN A SHORTER PERIOD
TIME UNLIKE IN AND THE
INSPECTORS AMID THE IT HAVING
INSPECTORS AND HAVING -- YOU
KNOW STAFF TO ABLE TO HELP OUT.
EVERY COUNTY NEEDS.
AND THE COLLECTED THE THANK YOU
EARLIER SO LET ME CORRECT THAT
RIGHT NOW FOR YOUR HELP IN.
IN A TERRITORY THAT WE WORK IN
IT IS THE BIG ISSUE WELL IF WE
HAD ENOUGH WORKERS WE COULD WITH
THE PERMITS BEING ISSUE WE COULD
MOVE THIS ALONG MUCH FASTER --
WHAT HAS SLOWED MOST OF THE
RESIDENTS HAVE THE INSURANCE
ISSUES YES VOTES FOR THE TWO
THIRDS OF PEOPLE IN THE NORTH
THEY WERE UNDER INSURED EITHER
MODERATELY OR SERIOUSLY?
YOU'VE HEARD THAT STORY BEFORE
BUT THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST IMPEDIMENTS NOW PEOPLE
ARE COMPANY CONTRACTORS ARE
POACHING OFF EACH OTHER'S
WORKERS AND I HATE TO SEE THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO BE OF
BUILDING COMMUNITY.
BUT IT'S HARD WHEN SOMEBODY'S
TAKING YOUR EMPLOYEES AND THE
THERE ON A FRIDAY AND THEY DON'T
SHOW UP ON A MONDAY THAT'S MADE
IT VERY DIFFICULT SO ANY HELP WE
CAN GET ON SUPPORT.
FOR PROGRAMS ALL BETTER YEAH WE
HAD I AM CONTRACTORS FROM THE
SACRAMENTO AREA DRIVING TO SANTA
ROSA EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH.
A WHOLE BAND FULL OF EMPLOYEES
TO GROUNDWORK GO BACK AND FORTH
SO.
I'M WITHOUT WITH ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
YES ASSEMBLYMEMBER RELIGIOUS YOU
KNOW THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM CHAIR --
YOU KNOW NOT ONLY FOR THIS
HEARING BUT ALSO -- YOU KNOW AS
YOU WERE TALKING AYE I REMEMBER
GETTING THAT CALL ONE I REMEMBER
TALKING TO YOU LAST YEAR YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
EVERYTHING GOING ON IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY HARD TO
PUT YOURSELF IN THAT PLACE INTO
YOU'VE GONE THROUGH IT RIGHT AND
AND CERTAINLY YOU KNOW -- LAST
YEAR WITH EVERYTHING THAT WE WE
DEALT WITH AND TRYING TO FIND.
YOU KNOW.
RESOURCES AND POLICY SOLUTIONS
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE OF THE
FIRES IN YOUR YOUR DISTRICT.
I NEVER WOULD'VE IMAGINED THAT.
YEAH I'D BE FACING THE SAME
THING AND SO I'M AND YOU WERE
YOU WERE ONE OF THE FIRST TO
CALL ME WHEN -- WHEN THE
CAMPFIRE -- OCCURRED IN AND ALL
THOSE THINGS AND GIVEN ME I
STILL HAVE MY NOTES -- OF THINGS
THAT TO HE SAID HEY HERE'S WHAT
YOU NEED TO BE READY -- FOR AND
IT'S IT'S UNFORTUNATE -- AND YET.
THE FACT THAT YOU WENT THROUGH
THAT AND THAT YOU GUYS IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE KIND OF
DEVELOPED.
IN A WAY -- A TEMPLATE FOR HOW
YOU CAN YOU KNOW COME BACK AND
HOW YOU CAN START PLANNING FOR
THESE THINGS IN THE FUTURE AND I
THINK THAT'S GOOD AND AND BRIAN
HAS BEEN -- YOU KNOW RUNNING OUR
ORDERS ARE JOINT TASK FORCE THE
UNITED I BELIEVE THE TEMPLE WAS
KINDA STARTED IN IN CINEMA --
BUT YOU KNOW TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THE FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL RESOURCES ARE TRYING TO
TALK TO EACH OTHER AND WORK
TOGETHER AND THAT'S BEEN A NO.
YOU KNOW.
SOMETIMES JEAN YOU KNOW AND BUT
WE'VE ACTUALLY WORKED REALLY
WELL TOGETHER I THINK.
IN THE GRAND SCHEME OF THINGS.
TWO THINGS I JUST KNOW THAT WE
KIND OF BROUGHT UP.
YOU KNOW FEMA HAS A TEN YOU KNOW
HAS THEIR WAY OF DOING THINGS IN
TERMS OF INTERIM HOUSING.
AND YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S SOME
IT'S BEEN DEVELOPED OVER TIME
BUT ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IS
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS THEY
LOOK. TO BRING IN TEMPORARY
INTERIM HOUSING LIKE MOBILE MH
USE AND TRAILERS THEY WANT TO
FIND SITES THAT ALREADY HAVE
SEWER AND WATER.
AND WE JUST DON'T HAVE THEM YOU
KNOW AND AND THEN.
YOU ALSO TRYING TO FIND THOSE
KIND OF SITES I THINK WE'VE GOT
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET OUTSIDE
THE BOX ON THAT BECAUSE PEOPLE
NEED HOUSING.
AND WE MAY NOT HAVE SEWER AND
WATER THERE BUT MAYBE THERE'S
OTHER THINGS YOU CAN DO WITH OUR
TECHNOLOGY WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO HAVE YOU KNOW ABOVE
GROUND WATER TANKS AND AND YOU
KNOW.
MAYBE INTERNAL YOU KNOW SEWAGE
UNITS THAT CAN BE USED THEIR YOU
KNOW -- TO BRING THAT.
YOU KNOW TO BRING UP SITES
QUICKER AND AND QUITE FRANKLY
RENDON BE ISM TO WE DO YOU KNOW --
PEOPLE SAY A LOT I WANT THAT
HERE.
AND YOU KNOW IN AN EMERGENCY.
YOU KNOW WE NEED THE HOUSING
RIGHT AND AND I THINK WE RUN
INTO THAT EVEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT BUILDING MORE PERMANENT
HOUSING AND THE REASON IN THE
REGION -- AND SO THAT THAT'S A
SECOND FOR INTERIM I THINK WE
NEED TO FIND BETTER WAYS TO
BRING ON TRAILERS IN AND ENTER
AND EMERGENCY HOUSING -- SOONER --
AND REMOVE SOME OF THE
ROADBLOCKS TO THAT.
BUT THEN LONG TERM YOU KNOW
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE THIS PLACE
WE HAVE TO BUILD HOUSING AND WE
NEED TO DO IT IN A IN A MUCH.
MORE STREAMLINED FASTER WAY ASSN
LEGISLATION I'M WORKING ON FOR
FOR BUTTE COUNTY MAYBE -- FOUR
THIRTY BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
START THINKING ABOUT THAT IN
THESE KIND OF SITUATIONS.
AND HOW DO WE HELP OUR OUR
BUILDING COMMUNITY HOW DO WE
HELP OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN BRING THAT
ONLINE AT ALL LEVELS OF HOUSING
YOU KNOW INFILL AFFORDABLE MULTI
FAMILY BECAUSE IT IT IMPACTED
EVERYBODY YOU KNOW IT ACROSS ALL
SOCIAL ECONOMIC BOUNDARIES --
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN IN
THESE SITUATIONS.
TRY TO STREAMLINE THAT.
NOT DOING IN A WAY THAT'S NOT
PLANNED YOU KNOW BUT DO IT IN A
WAY THAT MAKES SENSE -- I THINK
THERE'S WAYS THAT WE CAN DO THAT
AS WELL BECAUSE THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING MORE.
WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE HAVING
QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT WELL I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR ATTENDING TODAY AND
PROVIDING US WITH ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY I APOLOGIZE.
OKAY SEE.
I DON'T SEE ANY -- SO WITH THAT
I'D LIKE AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
YOU I WANT TO THANK MY COACHES
TODAY -- YOU MAY BE I THINK THIS
IS PRETTY LIKE.
VACANT THERE'S THEY'RE SITTING
IN THEIR OFFICES DOING OTHER
WORD AND WATCHING THESE I DON'T
THINK THAT YOU'RE NOT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT -- BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU GIVE US A LOT TO THINK ABOUT --
WE HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO DO --
I REALLY REMEMBER QUITE WELL
WHEN THEY OPEN FIRES HAPPEN.
WHENEVER THIS WAS TWENTY YEARS
AGO NOW MAYBE.
AND I DON'T WANT TO EXPERIENCE
THIS AGAIN BECAUSE I THINK WE
DIDN'T DO ANY STOP GAPS DURING
THAT PERIOD OF TIME WE TALKED A
BIG STORY.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO
PREVENT -- IT TO HELP YOU OUT AS
WELL TO DO YOUR JOBS YOU KNOW
EMERGENCY SERVICES THE CITY'S
THE COUNTY'S.
PLANNERS -- WE NEED TO BE THERE
FOR YOU.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENDING
TODAY.
AND WITHOUT I'M GOING TO DURING
THE MEETING